Sorry, my throat.
Oh my god.
So I was doing recordings earlier today.
So my throat is like really fucked up
Oh my gosh, okay.
Yes, we're back with Marvel Rivals because I am this close to top 500.
Well yesterday I was even closer, but I was so tired I had a lot of work to do so I had to stop because I was playing Marvel Rivals I was doing work and then my manager got a little bit mad at me because they were like, so how's the recordings going?
I was like, oh, I'm resting my which is true.
I was resting my throat because my throat is not really good right now I was like, um, I was resting my throat.
So I I had I was playing Marvel Rivals
But like no, you don't understand I mean, I mean I'm platinum three And like with like 6.6 hours of gameplay.
I'm platinum three.
I actually started rank Two days ago.
I didn't play rank right off the bat.
So I made it to Plat three within 6.6 hours of gameplay and you're like plat.
That's not good Well
And this guy has 20.2 hours by the way that one is the cutoff for top 500 might I add So thank you random guides that use and not only that this is a global This is a global leaderboard Which means it includes the around the world.
So it's not just NA they combine NA, EU Asia and like all the other regions together for this global leaderboard.
So I am this close to To get top 500 What's rank one at rank one is grandmaster three.
They're ready.
It's already people already hitting grandmaster, which is fucking crazy
So Yeah, and the game is like incredibly Hot right now.
So everybody is like grinding So I'm sorry.
Oh, yeah South America NA SA a MEEU Asia all in SEA.
I was in Australia
So So like I'm really proud of myself I'm honestly like incredibly proud of myself to be able to get this close to top 500 with my incredibly fucking busy hours Just cuz like, you know, I didn't play that much too.
I haven't even played that much I played like 6.6 hours and like being able to get this far up within like just like Two days like like, you know last night plus like the day.
I only played like maybe like I played like the two days ago I played till I got to bronze one and I stopped cuz I was like, yeah, whatever and then last night I think I got to actually there was a bronze I think it's not that silver or something and then last night I got to like plaid.
So I was like, oh, it's fine I've been doing solo duos solo duos.
I did duo with sure for yesterday like a little bit was sure for yesterday and I was like higher ranked than him and I was like laughing at him cuz he was silver and I was gold and I was like
But he's really good
Papa smurf, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you thing.
I'm gonna read that.
Yeah, I'll read it later No, but he's now my elo.
He's now at my elo now.
Um but uh We might do it with sure for later I think maybe next his next game cuz I think he's like he just got in a game and But yeah, you guys are wondering who I play currently.
I currently play We do how to check my character.
That's it statistic.
Yeah, I play guess who I play
Guys can you tell who's my main?
Can you can you tell chat?
Yes, guys, I'm a I'm a Luna snow one trick because like She she was like she's been in the game since since Alpha and because of that I already know her entire move set and then I don't fucking know I don't know how play mantis and cloak and dagger.
I already got too far You know when you like get too far and then you're like you can't learn other characters anymore Because you know if you try to play other characters at this elo you're gonna fucking be like you might as well be dead like Just like throw So I was just like I'm just I I just like boxed myself in the corner because I kept winning as Luna snow So like I was like,
well, I kept winning as her So I might as well just keep going with what I know and obviously the more player the better I got So then I kept getting better at her and I was like, well, what do what fuck do I do now?
I'm into deep guys.
I can't learn a new character.
I'm into fucking deep It's too late my elos way too high to do something else so when someone else picks Luna snow I'd be like I'll be like well Actually, I don't say anything.
I just accept the loss like
No, I try to play I try to play like mantis and Jeff when I don't get Luna snow though, like, you know, I try to make it work So like and then when the other support swaps off Luna if we're losing I take Luna back.
I
I Just like I'm just waiting till the other support swaps off Luna and then I'll be like, all right, give me a It's time to play you want to see my win rate on mantis.
Yeah
But like yeah, we don't talk about My nine whole minutes losing on mantis We don't talk about that.
Yeah Yeah.
Yeah when I play tank, it doesn't go so well on tank.
It does not go so well But hey, I'm a pretty good win rate on Punisher three out of two or two out of three.
That's pretty good That's pretty good but yeah, I've been like super addicted to marble rivals only because like You guys don't know about it for those who are new here I don't know this about me.
Um, whenever a new shiny competitive game comes out I speed run to the leaderboards and then after getting it I stop So like I might try and end top 500 marble rivals because after I get it I just don't care about it anymore because that's how it usually goes like
That's how like Yeah, cuz I've done that for splatoon I got the highest rank possible in splatoon I think I got s rank and I got and I was like, I'm done with splatoon.
I like splatoon 3, right?
Yeah, it was a splatoon.
It's splatoon 3, right?
Yeah, so I got splatoon 3 I got the highest rank possible, which was s rank at that time.
There was an x-ran yet.
There was no x-rank yet I got to s and I stopped playing splatoon after that because I got it I was like I'm done and then same with overwatch 2 I got to Grat like I got to top 200 in overwatch 2 and now I was done.
I was like, I'm done
I was just like Fine, it's fine.
I got what I wanted and I don't play as much I do sometimes relapse into it, but like Never to the full point never to like we're like back to like, you know I don't I relapse into it, but I don't grind as if I'll die if I don't get the elo I wanted Right now I'm like that with my rivals at the moment right now I'm just like I have to get this I have to get top 500.
I have to it's the newest fun game it's so like it boosts my own ego and like um You know It's I won't boost my own ego and stuff to make myself feel better about myself because I'm like, oh my god Doki You're not as washed as you think you are Oh My god,
you know what they all say they always like Doki you're so washed But I'm like, but I still made it a top.
Okay.
I haven't yet haven't yet I don't want jinx myself, but like I'm so close to top 500 on the newest game that came out
So like so like if I get it then I can be then I can brag about it Then I can be like egotistical about it.
So like I don't know if it's actually good to enable me like this I Don't know if it's good to enable me to be top 500 because you know My ego is gonna go even higher after that like, you know, it's not my you know, my I'm not gonna be humble at all
Anyway, let me I'll miss it sure for whenever he's ready I'll be like I'll do a quick play cuz you can leave quick play whenever I'm pretty sure I'll just be like you can invite me whenever Right.
I'll do a quick play first.
I think you can do like I Think like you can leave quick play whenever you want.
So that's fine All right Let's warm up.
Let's do one warm-up game.
Oh my god.
Ah I'm so like nervous though, cuz like I tried I try so hard when it comes to like When I play off stream, I actually work try so hard off stream.
Like I I can't I can't like I Have to think so much when I there's a lever Are you serious?
Oh my god.
Oh I get one leave.
Okay, that's good That's gonna be my one leave
My one leave so I might be like super focused in rank cuz like I really want to hit top 500 chat I might be super focused though.
So just so you guys know Wait, did my settings reset?
Oh my god.
My settings did reset itself.
I fucking knew it Yeah, I knew it.
I was gonna say cuz I updated my I updated my graphics.
So all my settings reset all my settings reset itself No, right.
It's just my yeah, it's just this Okay, it's at a hundred and fifty.
That's not ideal cuz I need 200 that is not ideal at all
No, not a hundred
It might as well be playing out five FPS the fuck is this bullshit
No, you don't understand frames matter so much I'm so used to playing 200 so it's weird It's so weird I can barely aim on a hundred frames It's like like things aren't look so different when it's lower when the frames are lower So like it's worse for me.
It's really bad for me Okay Ariel nice.
Oh my god.
I hate this.
I Hate it though He's one nice Okay, I need to I need to readjust my settings because I I cannot play in this Actually, I'm sorry guys for complaining but like it's basically half my frame rate It's half my usual frame rate so I don't know how to play on this.
Oh my god, are you serious?
I Refilled oh my god.
He's so low bro.
This fucker was so low to know.
Oh, am I so?
Oh, no, I'm not so low That's right, I'm FPS shaming right now that's fucking right.
Oh my god, where is it?
No No
My spoiled eyes my eyes are very spoiled They're very spoiled cuz like I've been using I've been playing like not like six plus hours on in rank Oh, oh I fucked that up.
Oh, he's so low though.
He's so low Where is he?
Where did she go?
Oh fuck.
Okay That's fine.
Oh shit That's fine.
You're so lucky because I'm playing basically like half my frames right now.
I'm playing half my frames at the moment She's so lucky I can dance I can dance now
That's right, you're all does nothing
That's fucking right, you're all does nothing
That's fine Get over here You think you can run?
You think you can run?
I can hit my shotgun.
I can hit my shotgun Even though I'm basically playing half my frames That's fucking right.
Oh shit, that's fine.
We're we're healthy.
Oh We're not healthy We're not healthy Oh my god, we're not healthy at all What the fuck how do I?
Okay, show limit FPS No, we're stacked I think it's my I think it's also my monitor too I'm gonna check my monitor too real quick after Okay, I hope trueport isn't waiting for me Because I still have to push this all the way What was that?
That was like Reaper ult from Star Lord.
Oh my god.
I might need gamer subs too because my eyes are a little tired I need all the enhancements Guys, I'm desperate I need all the enhancements I can get I We are aiming for the world right now the leaderboard Oh he's over here Fucking spider-man.
I hate him now.
I know why everybody hates your he's not your friendly neighborhood.
I wanna fucking stomp this spider
Aim but I demands fuel right now.
I'm not healing that much too.
I'm fucking around way too much As Luna, I play more of as a healer than a DPS here Cuz it's just makes sense Cuz like there's so many other characters like my other support is usually the DPS healer So I focus on just healing.
Oh Nice and I'm died
All right, nice Yeah Yeah, I'm focusing on DPSing right now I'm not actually healing Because I won't focus on practicing my because I'm warming up on aim at the moment.
So I'm not like Yeah All right.
Let me fix my frames.
We did it
She is the DPS healer she's more focused on heal she's very good for heals She's very very good.
I think he queued up because like, uh, oh Never mind.
He has to do something Minutes never mind Wait, he said he'll be back at 8 so we'll just play a ranked game.
All right, let's fix my settings too He'll be back at 8.
Wait 8.30 central?
Wait 8.30 8.30 is central or West Yeah, which which one cuz he's not West Coast that's why I'm confused I know he's not West Okay, guys, let me fix my settings real quick Because I don't like playing at half
Let's see limit network stats, okay, we need to know our ping though, too
Global elimination spoilage Yeah, so I was like it's gonna it might be one hour from now I need to make sure all my stuff is okay Let's see.
Is all of this normal?
Yeah, this didn't get reset.
That's good.
Oh, yeah This is my new sense cuz I realized I was playing credibly Oh, is it on is it at it?
Where's DLSS, where is it?
Oh, so like in an hour.
Okay.
Well, we're doing in an hour.
Where's my oh, there it is Do I do performance for this?
I guess I could We'll do performance and then I'm go to training real quick Okay.
Okay.
Sounds good All right, uh Is It a bit too blurry, I don't know I usually just play on default for it I'll do native then This one.
I know I didn't do performance.
Let me check my monitors too because I know like sometimes So we're getting and get like super super nerdy when it comes to enhancing our frames because that's how it goes when it comes to FPS games like
When It comes to like actually grinding for games, this is how it usually goes So we're gonna get like super fucking nerdy when it comes to this Okay, let's see.
Where's my desktop?
I need to go to my desktop.
Well, you won't even let me go to my desktop Okay, yes close my game real fast give me a sec I'm gonna close my game so I can like check my monitors real fast.
Oh my god.
My wallpapers got reset, too All right.
Let's see Events display.
Okay display two.
Okay.
It's all 280 Hertz.
That's good Alright, we're ready then.
Alright, let me make some gamer stuffs.
I'm gonna fucking lock it in guys.
I'm gonna We're gonna fucking lock it in I'll be right back
We're gonna I'm gonna lock in and then we're gonna lose our first game I can feel it I can already feel it.
Knowing my luck, I'm gonna do rank After that
I'm gonna feel my bad luck coming in.
Alright, let's try and see.
I need to see what my okay, where's training?
Okay, I want to see How do I do training mode?
Is it conquest?
No, I want you.
Okay, we'll do one more.
We'll do.
Oh wait practice.
There you go There you go, I need to see my FPS real quick, so I know like my I need to know if it's back to 200.
Why is it 140?
I was playing too- is it cuz I'm streaming?
No, when I was streaming it was 200.
I remember Why is it 140?
I was playing like 200 frames off stream.
It was really weird Maybe I set to low?
Maybe?
I didn't cap it Hmm, maybe I put low.
Maybe I should put low then.
I don't want to play in low.
Yeah All right, guys.
I'm sorry.
Looks like shit I'm sorry, everybody.
It's all about the optimization
Okay, maybe I'll turn off low qual- maybe I'll turn off the lights Okay, no, it's still at hundred and fifth guys.
I'm sorry guys I'm sorry when- if you watch pro- if you watch good players, they're also all their settings are on low I'm sorry, everybody.
It's all about the frame optimization We have to It's the risk we gotta take.
It's the sacrifices we make for top 500 I'm sorry if it looks uglier now All right.
I need the frames!
I need it!
Okay, here we go All right, I did lose a game.
One game.
You might tell- you can see that I got minus 12 because I lost a game and then I stopped because I was like, I'll play tomorrow I'd get back to work.
I'll play tomorrow.
I got plat and I was like, I can do this and then I was like, I lost and I was like, yep That's a- that's for future Doki to do.
I'm nervous.
I'm so nervous now Cuz like I like, you know playing on rank- playing rank off stream is so different versus playing Okay, well, oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Okay
It's okay see they see that and they're like, oh she must be a Luna snow one trick and I'm like damn right I am I got to this elo
I got to this elo play Luna snow, please.
I'm scared of playing other characters now
I'm a problem.
I'm the problem.
They told you about the one tricks they warned you about
All right, I'm the one tricks they warn you It's not that different not gonna lie.
It feels more- I feel like low Low graphics makes the game- makes the models look more comic book-y.
I don't know.
What do you think?
It actually makes it like models look like like the colors look more like a comic book colors Okay All right.
I'm ready to focus up.
Okay.
All right guys, I might be like super focused.
I might not talk too much Yeah, it still looks pretty decent
Try not to move- because like the best thing about Luna is that you can heal from afar, which is nice
I'm just hoping.
Okay.
All right.
Come on Hela You got this Hela.
Nice.
That's why I have it on Hela.
I see her as a carry.
If you insta-pick Hela I assume you can carry like honestly
Hela is usually like the carry potent- carry DPS.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry I looked away for one second
I looked away for one second.
I'm so sorry.
I looked at chat.
I'm scared of- Oh no, not Hanzo.
Not Hawkeye.
Hawkeye's scary.
He can one-shot.
So I need to play corners I'm playing corners right now
Nice, okay.
I have to play corners because Hawkeye is- oh shit, what?
Let's go, Nomura!
There's somebody over there, I heard Let's go, Nomura!
Let's go!
Okay, I need to push up the cart.
Nice.
All right It's fine.
We're so focused We don't want to derank, so we gotta focus.
I have to save this.
I usually use this as a defensive ult
Okay, we have this It's fine
I'll use this if we have to We're fine, we don't need to use it yet.
We got Penny.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
Easy.
She's one Look at that!
Yeah, the the Mantis support ult is basically a Zen ult Mine is like a Lucio- like a Lucio thing as a Lucio ability, but with like DPS so I can change it to damage Don't jinx us guys.
Don't jinx us.
We don't know yet.
Don't jinx us guys.
I don't- I don't want to be too overconfident.
I'm trying to play as safe as I can
Okay, I'm gonna make sure our DPS is okay.
I gotta make sure our Hella is having a good time Okay, nice
Okay, it's fine Let's save people.
Come on guys, let's go!
Have fun!
Do your DPS!
Let's go!
Okay, I need to heal you though Let's go do your thing!
Oh shit.
Let's go!
Survive!
I'm healing!
I'm a support!
Let's go guys!
I'm a one trick!
Oh what the fuck?
What the fuck are you doing?
That's fucking right.
Wait, what the fuck are you doing?
Oh, no, this is bad for me This is bad for me guys, this is bad.
No, he's so low!
He's one!
I didn't have any cooldowns!
I had zero cooldowns, chat!
That's not fair!
I almost killed him too!
I had no more cooldowns!
Okay I'll give it to Hella.
I think Hella's been- yeah.
No, actually Namor's been carrying.
I'll give it to Namor I usually put it on the carry.
If we don't have two tanks, I put it on whoever is the DPS carry and that flanks a lot Cuz you know, they deserve it.
Come on!
I just gassed you up, bro!
I literally just gassed you up!
How could you die like that?
Oh my god, okay.
I'm just sick.
Okay To heal myself by healing him.
I usually use my shiv when I'm low or like as like, uh, what's it called?
Or like if I have to use it to defend myself
Oh, I didn't hit that?
Okay, that's fine That's okay NAMOR!
STOP!
Okay All right He's also- they also ulted too, so I countered support ulted That's okay, I got you.
I got you, Magneto.
Oh my god, just use everything, I guess.
I guess just use everything in your inventory.
That's fine.
That's all that was- we gotta regroup I- I gotta regroup now Bro, they used like literally everything for that.
Oh no, we have two minutes left.
Okay, I'll give you- get over here Get over here.
I'm gonna give you the- I'm gonna give you the Zen orb.
Get over here.
Yeah, I got you You're fine.
You're so healthy I need to watch like pro Luna Snow players and see like what- how to actually- like everything I learned from Luna Snow It's just me learning it myself.
So like I- I don't actually know how to play her that optimally So like I won't watch like an actual Pro player and see how- oh my god, I felt like that- I thought I was like the enemy in the morning thing.
I don't know why Yeah, there's like, you know, there's like Diamond plus Luna Snow players.
Like I basically self-taught myself Luna Snow all the way from Since alpha so like I don't know how to actually play her optimally Like in overwatch I would just watch like players who are obviously better than me and like how they How they learn like how they play their support players.
How they play their support characters So like I don't know what I'm doing is actually like how you're supposed to play her So, so I want to learn from other like Luna players to figure out how like to like play her like the most optimal
All right How the Knights think of the magenta soup, but they get the time to face the consequences of gambling to beat Majora's Mask I'll give you 500, I can't wait to see the content.
Thank you for the magenta soup, but thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah But like, okay, but what if I get top 500 Marvel rivals, it's basically the same thing
I was gonna play Majora's, I want to play Majora's Mask anyway, but like I'll still play Majora's Mask But like, it's the same thing if you think about it It's sort of the same thing You know Yeah
I'm trying to think of like, okay, I'm gonna heal the Namor because I feel like the Namor Greaves so- like not greaves, but like he takes- look at that.
He already took so much damage The Namor is taking so much damage Okay Let me see if I can get random ice Sometimes I throw the ice just to- if I know they're not pushing it, I throw the ice randomly Oh My god, they're so close.
They're scaring me right now.
Oh my god, they're actually scaring me.
I need to use this to fast heal this.
Oh my god, please!
Oh, you're scaring me!
Not has to be Majora's Mask!
Lurkrosis, they give the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Yeah, this is what happens.
Like that's why I try to throw random ice out Just to see if I can get the random ice out.
Oh, it is getting a little scary now Okay
I think like I should try and aim my ice like not randomly if they're like trying to push This is like my weakest point because I'm like, oh they're not fighting it so I can technically fucking throw it randomly if I want to
This is...
Okay Alright, that's fine.
I have ult.
No!
I might have to... I'm gonna use ult.
It's fine.
They counter ulted.
So like it's a good trait because like they counter ult it too.
So like that's...
Oh god, why are you over there?!
That's fine, they used like 200 fucking thousand ults.
That's fine.
Like I'm okay with that.
Like I'm gonna die anyway!
Oh my god,
okay, that's fine.
We were gonna... there was... we were not gonna be alive for that unless like we lost your tank.
Wait, what the fuck?
Guys, there's a fucking Magneto!
Guys, what the fuck?!
What is he doing there?!
Thank god I hit the freeze.
What the fuck?!
Okay.
Why are you all here?!
What the fuck?!
What?!
I...
Okay, I stole... I killed two by myself.
That's fine.
Alright, that's fine.
I got the two myself.
He just stood there.
Oh my god, what the fuck was he doing there?
I found out that this is like activated by... I'm fucked.
Oh my god, please.
Oh please!
I didn't realize there was...
They pushed up that much?!
Holy fuck!
Okay, I walked over and I was like, Oh no, I went the wrong way.
I didn't know I went the wrong way!
Guys, I didn't know!
If I knew, I wouldn't be there!
Is it really throwing if I didn't know?
If I was ignorant?
Oh my god, maybe it is.
Nevermind.
Okay, I can heal myself in this.
Oh god.
Oh, thank god, Hella.
Good job, Hella.
Guys, get the point!
Guys.
Guys!
Oh no.
Oh no, this might be over.
We're getting hard snowballed right now.
Like, we're doing what they did to us.
Oh my god, fuck.
We're getting super hard snowballed.
Oh no, oh no.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
I'm okay, I'm okay.
We're okay.
I'm getting hard.
Oh my god, guys.
Please.
You guys gotta play together, guys.
Nice.
Please.
Push up, please!
You guys gotta push up!
We can't give them so much free space!
I'm healing as much as I can.
Alright, no more.
Okay, who's carrying?
Okay, Punisher's carrying.
You don't deserve this anymore.
Wait, no, Nomura's actually carrying.
Nevermind.
JK, Nomura, I wasn't reading the names properly.
You deserve it.
Don't worry, Nomura, I got you.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
I am ready to put on a show.
I am so ready to put on a show, guys.
Guys, please.
Oh, please.
I am so ready to put on a show.
I think I am.
There we go.
I'm so ready.
I'm so ready to put on that show.
Okay, the Nomura's still alive.
Oh, this is bad.
They're so pushed up.
The thing is, we didn't freaking stand on the payload.
Yeah, the Psylocke ulted when I still had my ult, so that was really dumb of them.
Jesus Christ.
Stop.
Stop feeding.
The fuck are you- Stop.
Okay.
Please.
Please!
Why are you guys feeding?!
Guys, I need you guys to push up!
Oh, no.
He's one.
Nice.
Oh, he's so low, too.
Oh, they're all so low.
It's fine.
We need heals.
Okay.
Alright, we're fine.
We're not so fine.
I don't feel so good, but we're fine, guys.
I almost had my ult.
Oh, guys.
You guys are pushed so high.
So ahead.
Guys, you're scaring me.
You're scaring me when you're up there.
Please.
You're scaring me so much.
I need to, like, pre-heal them.
Okay.
I have ult for last fight.
There we go.
We're standing my fucking- Standing this!
Standing this!
You'll live for so long if you just stand in this!
Oh, my god!
Please!
I have to do a stun!
Oh, they got off!
They got off!
They did it!
Oh, my god!
We did it!
Yes!
They C9'd!
Oh, my god, bro!
Okay, she got 35.
Jesus Christ, how much was their- Their team was feeding.
Holy shit, their team was feeding fucking hard.
Oh, my god, 35.
My 28k heals were insane.
Oh, to be fair, I was DPSing more than her, though.
I was DPSing more than her.
There.
The enemy, um...
The enemy, uh...
Luna had 35k heals.
And I'm like, how?
How the fuck?
Alright.
Okay, we won.
Oh, thank god.
We won the first game, guys.
That seems so sick.
It is.
That's why I'm, like, trying to lock in.
These games are incredibly stressful, so I'm trying my best to fucking lock it in.
They're so stressful.
Alright.
Yeah!
That's right, fuck you, Margo!
Fuck you!
That's right.
No!
Oh, my god.
Okay, we'll do Jeff.
Cause I feel like if I play...
If I play, um...
I can't, I'm weak.
I'm so weak.
Oh, my god.
It's okay.
If we lose, it's her fault.
Not my fault.
It's her fault if we lose.
Cause she wouldn't let me play my one trick.
Alright.
Alright, I'm Jeff now.
My name's Jeff.
I know I should do...
I feel more confident on Jeff than I do...
I feel much more confident on Jeff than I do on Cloak and Dagger and Mantis.
Cause I know Mantis is like super strong but I'm not good enough.
I get too overwhelmed on Mantis.
But Jeff is like a lot intuitive.
Okay, what's the comp?
Okay, we have one tank.
Alright.
Oh, my god.
Already.
Okay.
Reloading my food.
This map again?
I have to play it again?
Okay.
This is dumb.
I have to play again.
Alright.
I'm sad I have to play this map again.
Bro, I wanted a new map!
Oh, no.
There you go.
Okay.
Please.
I can't reload my mouth forever.
Hahaha.
I'm just gonna use this and take it myself.
Guys, I can't reload my mouth forever, guys!
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
I need to get my own bubble.
Jesus.
Guys!
Do something!
I'm reloading my mouth!
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Nice.
I'm going in.
Oh, they're scared.
They're so scared.
Hahaha!
I got their support, too.
There we go.
Easy.
You better be scared.
That was a good ult from me, too.
That was a really good ult from me.
I try not to put too many bubbles because they're very good for, like, like, for backup.
I'm surprised the Luna died!
I was not expecting the Luna to be dead.
Because they're good burst healing, so I'm trying not to use too much of my...
to use my bubble as, like, to put out my bubble.
It's fine.
You guys are fine.
Reloading mouth!
Oh, okay.
I'm fucking leaving.
Goodbye.
Especially if I have to reload.
There we go.
Oh my god, please!
I can't reload my mouth too much!
Like, I put backup here, but...
Oh no!
My backup was right there!
This is a hate crime!
Against sharks!
I fucking hate sharks!
Okay, I'm coming back.
But, um...
Yes!
Against sharks!
It's like Jaws all over again!
It's like...
It's like Jaws!
Yes!
Sharks are not bad people!
They're not people either, but they're not actually that bad!
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Okay, I might be able to...
If they push, I'm gonna ult them off the point.
I think that's, like, the plan.
Are they push up?
There's no way.
Are they actually gonna push up?
Are they gonna give it to us?
Yes!
We got it for free!
I'm not gonna ult then.
We got it for free too.
Alright.
It's good.
Oh shit, I didn't see you!
Sorry!
He's so low!
Get him!
Come on!
Don't be a pussy!
Don't be a- Sorry, I should've healed you.
Sorry, bro.
I should've healed you.
Okay, I can ult this whenever.
Let's see, I'll do it here.
Wait, what?
Oh, I did get him.
Woah, woah, woah.
No!
I got too cocky!
I thought I got more!
Oh my god.
I got way too cocky.
Bro, I saved them!
I might go...
Warlock...
Atom for the res.
I don't think- I don't think shark is good this area.
I'm gonna go- yeah.
I'm gonna swap healer.
Okay.
I think warlock is better at this point.
Just for the...
Okay.
I think it's better only because the res is really good.
Okay, nice.
Come on.
No!
No, not me!
I'm the closest too!
Oh my god, thank god!
I was like, no, not me!
I'm so close to everybody!
No, I'm sleeping too!
Why me?!
Why is it always me?!
Why?!
Is it always me?!
Oh my god, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, bro.
I'll respawn right here.
Okay, I'm gonna friendship bracelet in 7 seconds.
Don't worry.
Friendship bracelet- Oh my god, don't worry.
Friendship bracelet in...
There we go.
Friendship!
Oh!
There we go!
Oh, please live!
Please, I'm clicking as much as I can!
Maybe I should play Jeff.
These guys are not doing well.
I might play- I think I'm gonna go back.
Oh my god, do I have to learn?
Do I learn?
Do I learn him right now?
Learn Mantis right now?
Like- Guys, I think I might have to learn Mantis.
Like, right here.
There we go.
Okay, nice.
We have respawned, so we'll be fine.
We literally have respawned, so we'll be fine.
I'm not too worried because we have respawned.
Okay, we don't have to respawn anymore.
Oh my god!
Please!
Okay, I'm going back.
I'm gonna learn Mantis then.
Learn and adapt, overcome!
Alright, it's time.
Oh my god, it's time.
There's so many- the reason why I don't like Mantis is like, there's so much.
There's so much, we got locked in!
Learning on the run!
I'm gonna adapt to it!
I have to adapt!
I just didn't think Jeff was the pick for the last point.
Jeff was not the pick for the last point.
It was just way too...
There was like nothing I could do, as Jeff.
I felt like, like no matter how much I was healing them, there was just nothing was getting done.
Only have one tank?
No one likes playing tank.
It's just...
life.
No one plays tank in this game.
Play Cloak and Dagger?
Cloak and Dagger?
I'm so confused when I play Cloak and Dagger.
I think like if I'm gonna... Cloak and Dagger makes me even more confused.
I play tank.
You're like literally the 1% in this game.
Have you tried Loki yet?
I don't like Loki in...
the current meta.
I think they just have better DPS than us.
I'm gonna avoid Margo.
Because like, I'm avoiding every support.
Like, I can't play with another Luna Snow one trick.
I'm avoiding Margo.
I have to.
I'm gonna Inspire.
What's going on?
Oh.
Oh, that's what's going on.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
What do you mean?
I'm healing.
I literally clicked on him.
Oh my god.
I'm literally... That's all I'm doing.
I'm clicking so much.
Oh my god.
I don't even have heals left.
That's how much I heal.
Inspire too.
Do something.
Oh my god.
Like, I don't know what you wanted to do.
You fucking went in there by yourself.
You're fucking crazy.
All I do is right click.
What do you want me to do?
I'm literally acing.
Because I've been right clicking so hard.
I'm literally the ace right now because all I do is right click.
I'm just gonna wait.
Not even our fucking Luna Snow.
Shut the fuck it up.
Oh my god.
Oh fucking hell.
No!
Sleep!
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm not ace anymore.
Yeah, I need to get headshots.
That's why I'm scared of playing Mantis because I'm not that good at her.
I need to get better.
Oh my god.
No!
I'm sorry!
You're taking so much damage!
I'm so sorry!
What do you mean?!
I'm 18!
Oh my
god.
Alright, I'm gonna avoid Margo.
Because she's a one trick too.
More healing than like their support!
What do you mean?!
We have more healing than their support!
I'm almost dead!
Okay, I'm gonna avoid you.
Thank god there's an avoid.
I can't.
There can only be one Luna Snow one trick.
He's bottom frag.
Yeah, he is.
Why are you flaming?
Yeah.
What do you mean?!
If anything, our tank struggled the most.
He got out tanked 100%.
Who was it?
The voice chat is broken as well.
I don't even know who was the one that flamed.
The voice chat is broken.
I am Groot.
Was it Punisher?
Bro, I think it's also because...
Alright.
Yay!
Guys, I know I should learn another hero.
I know.
I'm in too deep, guys.
When I hit the leaderboards, I'll learn a different healer.
I'm in too deep.
I'll play quick play and learn something new.
It's too late.
We're already too high.
This is plat 3.
It's plat 3 at the moment.
No, I want to end top 500.
But to be there, I do need to learn all the other support characters.
I became the thing I hated the most.
A fucking one trick.
I can't help it.
I legitimately...
I can't help.
I became the one thing I hated the most.
A goddamn one trick.
A fucking one trick.
Yeah, but Jeff is so situational.
I don't think he's that good.
He's not meta.
That's the thing.
He's like an off-meta support pick.
Cause he's actually pretty trash.
I think my Jeff is decent but he's just not meta.
If he was meta, I would love to play...
I would want to play him frequently, but I don't think he is.
That's the only issue.
If he was meta.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
He's so low.
I got him so low.
Did you guys see that?
I got this.
This is what happens when you're a Luna Snow that can aim.
That's right, guys.
I'm a Luna Snow that can shoot.
That can defend herself.
I'm not like the other Luna Snows.
Okay, I'm sorry.
You got walled off.
I don't know what you want me to do there.
Oh, he's so low.
Not the fucking wall!
Please.
No!
I need one heal!
I need...
Oh my god.
I literally...
I got too cocky there.
I wanted to get the one and then so I could do the... Oh no.
If I didn't die there, I think we could have won that easily.
Come on, go in.
No!
Get in here!
Just live!
I'm sorry, but we're so dead.
We're so dead.
I'm sorry.
We're so fucking dead though.
I'm so sorry.
We got walled off again!
Oh my god.
What a wall combo.
Jesus Christ.
These walls are so... I'm gonna put on a tank.
It might be more... Wait, what?
Why did you ult?
I'm gonna put in a tank because like...
He keeps getting walled off.
It might be easier so I can heal like others.
No, I have to reload.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Bro!
Oh my god.
No, please no!
It's not just a lunar counter.
It's like an everything counter.
I'm getting heavily picked though.
I'm gonna put it on a tank because like our tanks are getting cooking.
Yeah.
Don't worry, I got you.
Oh my god, this stupid wall.
Shoot the healer!
Let's go!
Let's start the show!
Let's fucking go!
Let's go, Strange!
Oh, that is very risky.
I'll put on this, Dr. Strange.
Dude, this fucking tree.
This fucking tree though.
He has tree ult.
I can tell.
Focus down this root every time.
Oh my god.
He has the ult.
I'm focusing the tree.
I'm focusing as hard as I could!
Oh my god.
Please, I have to reload.
Oh no!
No!
You're all so low!
There was nothing I could do!
I'm sorry!
This Groot is so good!
The Groot just put the wall down!
I can tell too!
I thought the Mantis would get her ult before.
Oh, I guess she didn't.
She used it already.
I think the key right now...
Is that...
I saved my ult for Groot's ult.
I had to save my ult for Groot's ult.
There's no other way.
Yeah.
So like, I have to...
I have to play more defensively.
Yeah, I think she popped it for Mantis.
It's like Lucio-Zed and double ult together.
Which is not good.
Groot is very annoying, yeah.
The Groot-Sylocke combo is very fucking annoying.
I'll put it on the Thor, because he's gonna be flanking a lot.
I usually put it on the DPS, but like...
When we have double tank, I put it on the other tank.
So I don't have to worry about healing both tanks.
I can just heal one tank for the price of...
I can heal two tanks for the price of one.
I'm gonna do this, because...
That's like double healing.
Oh my god, good job guys!
Good job!
I do this if they're like super close together.
So then I know I can do double...
I can do double the healing.
Pushing so far up.
Because it can...
It...
It can like combine...
Oh my god.
No more?
It's okay.
Oh!
Oh, he is so fucking dead.
He is so dead.
There's no way!
Wait, he's alive!
Oh my god, he's alive!
What the...
Mantis would heal me.
Heal me!
No, I literally walked in front of the mantis!
Hey!
Sup?
I literally walked in front of the mantis because I thought I would...
I thought I was gonna get it.
Oh my god.
That's a nice portal though.
Yeah.
There's a Psylocke there.
Oh my god, I have to...
I'm trying to keep it for...
I'm a little scared though.
Okay.
I might have to do this.
I don't want them to cap.
I don't want them to cap so I'm gonna fight on this point.
I'm gonna fight on this point until I fucking die.
Okay, I leave now.
Hahaha.
Haha.
Got this.
I need reload!
Oh my god!
How much damage are you taking?!
No more!
Nice.
Alright.
Yay!
Let's dance!
Oh my god.
This game is so stressful.
Okay.
I have one more round.
And then you can invite...
Alright.
Trapper's ready.
This is fine.
This is so fine.
Hahaha.
Yeah, but we're not gonna be in voice VC.
We're just gonna like...
Uh...
We're just gonna be chilling.
Off voice chat.
Oh my god.
This is so stressful.
Okay, I'm gonna put it on Dr. Strange.
The thing is, what I like about it is that it's not fully cluttered.
It's not full cluttered.
Yeah, he's the ace but we have two tanks.
It's not worth putting it on the more.
If we have one tank, I put it on the best DPS.
But since we have two tanks, it's easier to just put it on one tank.
So I can heal the other tank.
I don't have to focus on healing both tanks.
I don't know if that's the right thing, but this is how I feel has worked the best for me.
Jesus Christ!
How?!
How are you taking so much damage?!
Jesus Christ.
I have a point.
What?!
Oh my god, it's Hawkeye.
It's fucking Hawkeye.
That's how.
Oh, that makes sense.
I was like, how?!
I'll just heal you.
Don't worry.
Oh, shit!
Get back in here!
That's the key right?!
Oh, shit!
Oh my god, please!
I'm sorry!
Let's just push.
That's the key right?!
You thought you were the DPS?!
Get out!
Get out of here!
Alright, I panicked.
I don't know if you noticed.
I wanted to live after that sick fucking play.
Yes, I can heal them.
You're supposed to be the DPS healer?!
I'm the DPS healer!
I'm the DPS healer now!
Oh yeah, I emoted on them too.
You're right.
I basically ulted on them out of confidence.
Because I was like, that's the key right?
That's me.
I'm her.
I'm fucking her.
Oh, shit.
I think we're fine, right?
We're not.
Oh wait, they're on point.
Guys, they're on point.
I know!
Please, I know!
I'm so low!
Okay,
now I have ult.
Oh my god, I just got it.
We still have point though.
No, we don't.
JK.
What the fuck are they talking about?
Why are they mad?
Why mad?
Oh my god!
Get in!
This is it!
This is the push!
This is the Lucio beat!
We got the Lucio beat in!
The girls are fighting.
Left side!
I'm scared.
I'm scared, hello?
They're coming over.
I froze him.
Oh, I'm scared.
I'm definitely scared.
Oh my god!
Oh, you're alive!
Oh!
I'm alive.
Oh, he's ready.
I froze her, but it doesn't work because she's in the ult.
Oh, I'm trying!
Go, go, attack!
That's fucking right.
We're gamers.
We're fucking gamers.
Let's go.
See you guys.
That's how you play Luna.
No, she's basically Lucio Zen.
That's why it's so easy.
Like, I can transition to Luna very well.
Because I can play both Lucio and Zenyatta.
I want to say to that fucking Mantis, get fucked.
That fucking Mantis, that was like, I can totally take her.
Get fucking shit on.
That's looking right.
Okay, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
Exactly.
I can't believe it.
Mantis is supposed to be the DPS player.
What the fuck happened?
Huh?
Alright, let's see.
I don't want to be the one to request.
I don't like queuing up.
I want him to queue up.
Invite whenever.
Alright.
Where he at?
Where the fuck is he?
He's buying skins?
Are you serious?
He's buying skins.
I don't like Luna's skins.
I don't like it.
I like her current outfit.
But to be fair, I don't like dresses in general.
So like, I think that's why.
I don't like, I mean, I don't like it.
I don't know.
I don't really like this green color.
I like this outfit more.
I don't like this outfit.
I'm not like a huge fan of like these types of dresses.
I think.
I do like certain types of dresses, but like, I'm not a fan of this type of, this cosmetic.
I think this one's cuter.
I think this skin is a lot cuter.
No, I like girly stuff.
I just don't like this dress.
I find this dress to be not appealing to me.
I don't know, I don't like this color of green.
Cause like, asparagus.
Yuck, cause it reminds me of vegetables.
Disgusting.
It's hot.
Yeah, it reminds me of vegetables.
And I hate vegetables.
Yuck.
Doki, are you like five or something?
I'm just not a fan.
What can I say?
Just not a fan of this color.
Eat your veggies, Doki.
I don't get a lot of MVPs too, so it's like, there's no point.
There's no point in getting any of the cosmetics.
Doki, eat your broccoli.
I'm here for lasagna.
Alright, nice.
It's time to game, gamers.
Alright.
Where's his rank?
Wait, he's plat 2?
He climbed?
Wait, what exactly plat 2?
Oh shit, we're in.
Did he just rank up?
He climbed?!
Oh my god, he was silver before!
He was silver!
Oh my god, I was the gold and he was the silver.
No!
Oh no, it's time for Jeff, I guess.
Oh my god, do we have like 3 Luna players?
Oh no, I guess we're gonna avoid this person.
We have 3!
This is bad!
We have too many Luna players!
Why do we have so many support players?!
No!
Oh wait, it's plats and 1.
Oh it is!
Wait, it is!
Wait, this is a streamer lobby!
What the fuck?!
This is actually a streamer lobby.
Wait, we have the full streamer lobby!
Let's fucking go!
Yeah, we're streamers.
Guys, we're gonna lose this streamer lobby, I can feel it.
We're gonna lose the streamer lobby.
This is a Overwatch lobby.
Our team is full Overwatch.
This game is gonna be on YouTube!
This map again?!
I'm fucking so tired!
Why?!
I played 3 games!
And all of them were this map!
This is so stupid!
I'm so tired.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, okay, goodbye I guess.
Goodbye.
Alright.
I wanna shoot my gun too!
I wanna shoot my mouth!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I have to reload!
I have to reload my mouth!
I'm sorry!
I have to feed myself!
I gotta keep feeding my mouth!
Okay, nice.
How did we get into full streamer lobby?
That's crazy.
I'm avoiding their Luna snow.
I'm gonna avoid all the Luna snows I see.
It's the only way to go.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ, how did he die?
Okay, guys.
Oh my god!
Alright, I can't save that!
Bro, I don't know what you want me to do!
I'm spitting my mouth!
Like, look at all the balloons I'm giving you!
Look at all these bubbles!
Nice, okay.
I'm giving so many bubbles!
Okay, I can ult, but like, I don't know.
I feel like this ult is so...
I'll just eat the ult.
Goodbye.
I'm just gonna spit you out.
There's an enemy coming in!
I'm sorry!
I took him as far as I could go!
Goodbye.
We're halfway there.
There, I'm spitting bubbles at you!
Take the bubble!
I'm gonna get rid of this guy too.
This guy's annoying.
Alright.
You're fine!
I have no more bubbles, but you're fine!
I'm fucking... I'm spitting!
Bubble!
Oh my god.
I'm sorry, bro.
Holy fuck.
I might have to...
Okay, after my ult, I'll play a different character.
He's so situational, I know.
That's why I was like...
I use my ult if it's a team fight.
And then I can get rid of people during my team fight.
I could try Mantis.
Okay, that's unfortunate.
Right there.
That's very unfortunate.
I don't know what you want us to do.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, Surefour!
Just take all the bubbles!
I literally have so many bubbles for you!
Oh my god!
Surefour!
I don't know what you want!
I think...
You know what?
We might as well just run three support.
Because I don't think Jazzy...
Oh wait, Jazzy's ace.
But I thought he was a Luna player.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Guys.
Oh my god, guys.
I can't...
I can't!
I've been spitting!
All I do is spit!
All I do is just fucking upload!
Go!
Take the bubble!
Oh my god.
That's unfortunate for him.
Maybe I do lowkey...
I don't think I should.
Okay.
There we
go.
I was hoping to kill him.
Okay.
Sorry, I had to kill...
Sorry, I had to...
I had to work on killing the Hawkeye.
I'm sorry I couldn't help you, bro.
I'm gonna swap.
Hahaha.
I go swap healers.
Boom, boom.
Alright, let's try it.
Let's learn her live!
We're gonna learn her live!
I don't know how to play her, but we're gonna...
Oh, but at least we get to look at something nice, I guess.
Like...
We're gonna learn her live!
That's looking right!
We'll figure this out!
We're gonna learn her live!
I don't know how to play her, but we're gonna learn her today!
I don't know what I'm doing!
Okay.
Oh my god!
How?
Random!
Hahaha.
You got killed two people!
Oh my god.
It's okay.
I'm learning her live.
Hahaha.
Alright.
Do we learn Mantis?
Okay.
Cloaker, Dagger, or Mantis, guys.
Who do we learn live?
Hahaha.
Which one?
Who do you think I...
Who do you think I would do the best on?
When we're learning...
Mantis should be... Okay, we'll learn...
We'll learn...
Mantis?
Cloaker, Dagger, or Mantis?
Okay, we'll try Mantis.
Cloaker, Dagger...
Hahaha.
I just have a feeling that like...
Wait, I was one hit with four kills.
You're an Overwatch player.
Bro, that jazzy kid who is a support main, he was like, please just give me Luna.
Because I need to avoid the Luna...
The two Luna players.
Okay, we'll figure this out.
Dagger, give us a better view.
Guys, who would help us win?
Guys!
This is like the streamer lobby here.
Oh my god, I'm in elo hell right now.
Alright, here we go.
Let's figure this out.
Alright, surefour.
I think you're gonna get a headshot.
Okay, did he do it?
Hahaha.
Guys, did he get it?
I think you're still gonna... Okay, I'm gonna fucking heal you though.
Oh my god, he did it!
I fucking told you guys.
I knew it.
What?
Ow.
Okay guys, I need you guys to back up now.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm gonna inspire to...
WHAT THE FUCK?!
HOLY SHIT!
I didn't expect all of them to be there.
I was like, I'm inspiring you, please.
Be inspired.
Oh yeah, I didn't remember my sleep.
I forgot my shift.
Oh my god, I could've slept in.
Okay, thanks for reminding me.
I actually forgot about my sleep move.
I legitimately forgot.
I don't play...
inspire you.
Now get that headshot.
Oh my god, I fucking knew it.
Okay.
Alright.
And then, get that headshot again!
Oh okay, so it's like a explosive.
Okay, that's good to know.
Okay, now I know.
Alright.
Okay, I know that...
Okay, I'm gonna hit something though.
I don't have a lot of heals.
Don't worry, I'm gonna spy...
Oh shit.
No!
There's someone behind me!
There's flankers!
Oh no.
Don't worry, I have my ult.
I'm coming back!
I will ult if I need to!
Okay, we gotta go in though.
Oh, what the fuck?
Okay, nevermind.
I'm gonna stay over here.
Okay, this is...
Okay.
I'm just...
Come on, let's go in, guys!
Okay, I...
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
Okay, I died so fast in my ult.
Wait, we had three ults?!
We had three ults!
Oh my god, everybody just kept getting picked!
Everybody kept getting picked!
It's alright, I'm still positive.
Alright, let's see.
I gotta avoid all the Luna snow.
This is a detriment to me.
This is actually...
Okay.
No, did I avoid them in time?
I did!
No, I avoided them in time!
No, please don't play me!
Oh, thank god!
Okay, we avoided them in time.
Okay.
Alright, that's good.
Guys, no, you don't understand.
I'm in too deep.
I don't know how many people you can avoid.
Me playing...
Unless I play Jeff, me playing other healers will not be good for the team.
I literally am just Jeff or Luna.
But Jeff is like...
Jeff is just...
Not good!
He's just not good!
What can I say?
I need to...
I need to learn Mantis!
I like how like...
I say that and then we have a Jeff now.
We have a Jeff with us.
We had like two... we had three Luna players.
Literally the Jazzy guy also wanted to play Luna.
Alright.
And that dude's okay.
And then I do that and then he'll never die.
That's basically what I do.
If I play a duo with somebody.
Don't be mean to Jeff!
Alright.
It's fine.
We can do this.
I believe in us.
I think we can get to top 500.
We were just very unlucky.
We're very unlucky.
We can do it here.
Okay.
Okay, but my Luna gameplay is pretty fucking sick though.
You gotta admit.
It's pretty fucking sick.
Okay.
There's all of us here, so this is like...
We should just do this.
Oh my god, how many fucking...
Oh, I missed the ice.
Okay.
See, I don't have to heal him ever again.
I literally don't have to give a fuck about him.
What the fuck?
We have a Ironman?
I literally don't even have to look at him most of the time.
Get this out.
Actually, get this out.
I can't see!
Get this fucking thing out.
Jesus.
Jesus Christ!
Okay.
Oh, get over here.
I had to look at him because nobody else was taking damage.
It's fine.
Okay, we got the wrath.
We have Sniper?
Really?
Widowmaker?
As long as our Magneto takes damage, Short Fork gets healed!
That's the plan!
Oh!
That's not good.
It's fine.
Just need to keep getting damage.
Okay, nice.
Oh shit, sorry.
Nope.
People are just too good!
No one's getting damage!
Jesus.
Okay.
What's that all about?
Oh my god, is he okay?
Okay.
It's fine.
There's too much stuff going on!
I'm gonna dance!
Oh, thank you.
I really appreciate that.
There we go.
Oh!
What?!
Oh my god!
I was on top!
Oh!
What?!
Oh my god!
That was actually bullshit!
How did that land on me?!
I was in the fucking tower!
Oh my god!
That was fucking bullshit!
How the fuck was that?!
Oh
my god!
That's actually crazy that that hit me!
That should not have hit me at all!
Oh!
Oh my god!
That actually shouldn't have hit me!
I'm so mad!
That was actually bullshit!
Jesus Christ!
Building!
Oh my god!
Holy fuck!
Like...
I just got pulled into the fucking vortex of war!
The vortex!
Yeah!
See what I did there?
The vortex!
That was crazy.
I did not expect that.
See guys?
I never have to heal him.
It's so nice.
He doesn't complain about heals.
And then I don't have to give a fuck about him.
Until like...
Until he gets died by 20 people.
That's the thing!
Why is the hitbox so high?
What?
Alright.
Of course it's me and Churn4!
Us not paying attention!
We were both not paying attention!
Of fucking course!
Because we were fucking streaming!
I bet they said that there's mines and we didn't care!
I bet you like the chat was like...
Their team was telling us there were mines in the chat, but we didn't fucking care.
We were just like...
I can see that.
I can see us not fucking paying attention.
This is not fair.
This is a streamer diff right there.
Now they all know to play high ground.
You know about the high ground control now.
Nice.
Nice, where is...
Fine.
Nice, we did it.
Yeah.
This actual streamer debuff right there.
Of course.
Churn4 might have also been talking to his chat.
And then I was talking to my chat.
And then my team was like...
I had to penny the door.
I'm like, I don't give a fuck about Churn4.
Poor guy.
He's sorry for me.
He's not sorry for Churn4.
He's not sorry for him.
Alright.
The insta pick.
Oh my god.
I hope we don't have more Luna players.
My shit talk Jeff and then all I get is Jeff players.
I'm sorry.
He's not even meta.
He's not even...
Wait, what?
I was like, yeah, Jeff is not the most optimal for support right now.
And then I literally get all the Jeff players on my team.
Literally, he's not meta in high elo.
Yeah, but Mantis and Cloak and Dagger are just better.
Yeah, everybody stop.
Stop playing Luna.
She's actually trash.
But I make her look good, guys.
Stop playing Luna.
She's actually trash.
Except when I'm on Luna.
Then she's good.
If you see me in the lobby, don't play Luna.
But the Luna-Jeff team up though... I still think Mantis is better overall.
That's my opinion though.
I personally think she's just... I think like Mantis overall is just a better character.
Despite the team up.
I think like Mantis is all in Cloak's Mantis is all in Cloak's healing output is just overall better than Jeff.
That's why I want to learn Mantis.
Because I saw so many really good players playing Mantis.
So I really want to learn her.
I just wish I...
What the fuck is Captain America going to do anyway?
Okay.
Bye.
Goodbye, Captain America.
Oh, unless... Oh, shit.
Nevermind.
He also have a tree.
Wait, did he tree?
Wait, he treed Captain America!
That's fucked.
That's so fucked.
He like...
He killed this tank buddy.
Did we get... Did we kill anybody?
No!
That's fine.
We're fine.
We're still healthy.
Easy.
Shark on shark violence.
No!
Jeff!
Okay.
We're okay.
Yeah, I see Captain America.
I barely ever see anyone play Captain America.
He's just not that good.
Like, what is he tanking?
Who is he tanking for?
Oh, no.
Who is he gonna eat?
Oh, no!
No!
I'm sorry!
I can't do anything about it!
Oh!
I killed him, though!
Okay, we're not winning.
Yeah!
It's okay!
I did it for you guys!
He is tanking for America.
Wait, who's again?
Okay, we can ult with my ult.
We can use it to engage like a Lucio beat.
Alright, let's go!
Let's go, guys!
Woo!
Let's fucking dance!
Let's go!
Keep dancing!
Oh my god!
I'm literally ulting for Q!
Oh my god, that's so fucked.
He solo ulted him!
That's so fucked!
Like, they were not gonna win that fight and he solo ulted him.
That's actually crazy.
That's like...
That's so toxic.
That's so fucking toxic.
Like, they obviously lost the round and he still ulted.
That was actually disgusting.
Oh my god.
When I'm in Atlanta, I'm gonna fucking see a doctor.
I'm gonna fucking see a doctor in Atlanta, guys.
Woo!
I need antibiotics, man.
Alright.
I really need antibiotics.
I haven't been able to see a doctor in Canada.
Hahaha.
I'm okay with paying for it.
I got sponsors.
I have a sponsor stream when I get back.
I'll use that.
Hahaha.
I have a sponsor stream when I get back anyway.
It's fine.
I'll use that to pay off my medical bills.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god!
Fucking...
Stop taking damage!
Jesus Christ.
I'm gonna capture the point.
I hope you guys get Jeffy's.
This is why I like shift.
Like, some people...
I don't... I plan my shifts very well.
Like, I try... I try to plan my shifts well to the point where, like, if they're all, like, together and there's a team fight, I usually use my shift.
And if I feel like it's gonna be a... Wait, what?
Why is there a Dr. Strange in here?
Oh, shit!
And I try to make... use it as, like, a...
either a defensive shift or, like, or if I need to... if I know, like, there's gonna be a lot of... a lot of damage together.
I don't know.
Just in case.
Oh my god!
I'm dead!
What the fuck?
Oh, goodbye.
You know what?
I think we can do it.
Guys, I think... Let's go.
Let's fight here.
Guys, I think we can do it.
I think I can live.
I think... I think I can stall for, like...
Okay, now that's a little bit scary, though.
That would... Yeah, I don't... Guys, I think I don't think we can... I don't think we can live anymore.
I don't... I don't think...
I, like, I danced on the point alone.
Where was my teammate in that?
We're having a little dance battle.
Okay.
Alright, now I don't have to care about you.
So I can heal my team now and then you'll be healed.
What the fuck?!
That's so fucked up!
That's so fucked up.
That's so...
That's actually so fucked up.
That was a solo Oh my god.
That's toxic as fuck.
I saw that happen and I walked away.
You just...
Doki, you just walked away.
Doki.
What was I supposed to do?
Of course I walked away.
That shit was scary as fuck.
It was nothing for me to do.
I had to just walk away.
Okay.
Nice.
Yay!
Not my problem.
Bro, he got solo ulted two times.
That's why I also like playing with Surefour.
Because everybody targets him instead of me.
Because usually you target the support but then because he's there, people know who he is as a streamer so everybody just targets him instead of me so I get to roam free.
Like, I get to...
I get to be free.
What did it do to make them that mad?
Because he's a streamer and they're like haha, time to kill the streamer.
You guys don't know that!
Yay!
Let's go!
Yeah!
Luna snow!
Yeah, I am a streamer but I'm on YouTube.
They don't know who I am.
That's basically it.
I have the YouTube diff.
So I don't get targeted.
That's basically it.
I've actually been thinking about doing Twitch streams occasionally but that's going to be the new year because my manager is telling me how because a lot of not just YouTuber viewers but regular viewers Hey Doki!
I'm getting recognized so much.
Because my manager is telling me that I should try to stream on Twitch more and just to grow my audience in NA for people like the non-VTuber watchers or people who don't normally watch VTubers on YouTube and he was telling me that maybe I should do something like occasionally where I just stream whatever the fuck I want but like an actual Twitch streamer but it will be like occasionally and stuff.
It won't be like something I do, like try to do regularly No, not regularly but more so like maybe like once every two weeks where I just stream whatever the fuck I want.
Or maybe once a week on Twitch.
Like there won't be a set anything set.
Just be like OH SHIT I WAS NOT PAYING ATTENTION I don't like multi-streaming I don't like multi-streaming and stuff Because I don't like splitting the audience in general Okay, now I got focused I was trolling.
Whoops My bad I was trolling.
I'm sorry I was having a conversation not related to my video game match My bad I'm sorry I won't do that again
Okay, I'm locking in But YouTube will always be my main platform.
But that's something I'm thinking about in 2025
But I'll talk more about like how I see, envision it Who's that?
Oh, it's the cloak and dagger Is he gonna be okay?
I see
Jesus Christ.
Groot!
Groot please!
Drink the water!
Goodbye, hella There was nothing we could do I had no ult I had- oh that's Oh no!
Jeff!
I did this to protect Jeff!
This was for Jeff!
It was only for Jeff!
Oh no, they're gonna be born again What the fuck is that?
Okay Let's buy Oh shit!
Oh shit!
Jeff keep healing!
Jeff!
I was like, what's that ult?
This is how little I see I- oh my god This is how little I see Storm I did not recognize that voice line I literally was like, what's that?
Who said that?
I feel like I don't see I do not- oh my god I don't see like Storm that often I got confused
Okay Oh my god, come on.
Come on guys We all have to Oh nice, nice Hella I'm surprised Triforce is playing Natasha.
She's fucking dog shit
Hawkeye is just a better
Oh my god, I can't heal you Please stay near me I just personally think Hawkeye Is just a better Natasha
Jesus Christ
Oh my god Oh my god he Guys I can't He dashes too much Oh
my god, okay I have ult though I was just like Back forth, back forth
Okay No Jeff
Jeff Jeff I'm sorry Speaking of Natasha Hawkeye being just a better Nice, okay No!
Get over here!
Okay I legitimately couldn't see there I was blind There was too much That was like That was an Overwatch moment That was an actual Overwatch moment I legitimately couldn't see
I was like freaking out
I was like where is everything
Oh my god okay Please we need you to take more damage so I can Okay nevermind Oh my god Good luck everybody Good luck
Oh my god, good luck, good luck everyone.
Good luck to me, good luck to...
Oh my god.
I think we just need like...
Alright, one of our DPS is lacking.
The fact that the person that's playing Storm is making it work is a little concerning.
It's very concerning that Storm is working for him.
And you know I am doing so much to keep you alive.
Don't worry!
Don't worry, she can't tornado us anymore!
She can't hurt us anymore!
Oh my god.
Please.
She can't hurt us.
She can't, oh, she might be able, she might hurt us.
She, she might hurt us.
She might hurt, oh.
Okay, okay, she definitely hurt us.
I have no idea.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
The bad woman.
Yeah, the board again, all is so strong.
That's why I want to learn Adam too.
Cause her, his res is really good, but I just, his heal output is so scary.
I feel like, um, I feel like, um, Adam's heal output is so like scary because it's like very limited.
You literally play Adam for the res.
But like, he doesn't heal that much IMO.
So like, you gotta be really scared about what to do.
Okay.
Oh hey, we got two tanks, let's go!
Oh my god, woah, we got three tanks, let's fucking go!
Now, now we just don't need DPS I guess.
You know what, let's fuck it, let's go, let's just be, let's bring back Ghost.
Let's play, let's play three supports too, let's fucking go.
Yeah, why the fuck not?
That's great.
We'll just put this on him and he'll never die.
As long as we heal the support, he'll never fucking die, right?
Technically that's how it goes.
He's like, Luna is like, is like basically Lucio-Zen.
A sexy Lucio-Zen.
Like, but Zen's already sexy.
True, true.
They're like a sexy non, non-robot.
Okay, oh wait, he swapped off tank, okay.
Oh.
I, I heard her too late!
I heard her too and I tried to drop down!
Oh my god, I should've dropped earlier.
That was my bad.
I mean like the moment I hear that I shouldn't even challenge her.
I should've just dropped down.
That sucks, that happened.
But it's fine.
I can, we can contest this.
It's fine, I got, I got the clap!
I got the power of clap!
Nice.
Clap, clap, clap, clap, clap.
Here we go, push up.
I have ult soon too.
I'm not gonna do high ground.
It's way too risky.
I'm scared of getting flanked.
I'm so scared of getting flanked.
I'm just gonna, I'm gonna play backline.
I'll play backline close to my other team.
Cause I, I can hear her.
I hear her footsteps, yeah.
C'mon, keep healing, keep healing each other.
We're friends, we're gonna be friends.
You can't do anything about this.
Woah, that's right.
That's right.
I'm dancing!
I might live this.
Here we go.
Nice.
That was, that was a good dance off right there.
That was a really good dance off right there.
Okay, one minute, that's two fights left.
They used a lot too.
I think they used, uh, they set up Black Panther ult and Storm ult, which is scary because we had no defensive ult for that.
We had no defensive ult for, uh, Black Panther and Storm.
So, we'll hope everything will be okay.
Nice.
We got two kills.
Woah.
Sometimes I have to, like, three.
I have to, like, 180.
Oh my god, there he is!
Please, he's one!
Okay, nice.
Nice.
I have to be like...
When I see Black Panther, it's just...
Alright.
Bye-bye.
360?
No, he has no scope yet.
Oh, no!
No!
Dang!
Oh my god!
That's what I'm saying, there's no defensive ult!
Oh, no.
Okay.
I'm fucking...
I'm coming over.
No!
And then he brought the Mercy Rez them all!
Yeah.
Oh my god.
This is why I don't...
Like, Jeff is, like, hard.
Like, it's such off-meta.
He is...
Like, they have so many...
I can't use...
I just got my...
To be fair, if I...
You guys see that?
That was pretty cool, though.
If I live, that would be pretty cool.
If I live, that would be pretty cool if I live!
Okay, I live.
But we lost group.
We lost...
Oh my god!
We lost them!
I couldn't...
Oh, the Panther!
I had...
Oh my god.
If I...
I should've just ulted when I got dove.
Oh, that sucked.
Oh my god, there we go.
We have to fight this.
We have to fight this, guys.
Please.
Oh my god, please.
We have to fight this.
Nice.
I had to ult there.
It's literally the only way to win that fight.
Oh no.
Please.
Oh my god.
I'm solo healing everything.
No!
Oh!
I lived, but like for how long?
Oh, thank god.
Oh my god, I'm actually carrying this!
No!
Not Storm!
Please just live.
No, I literally just got my ult.
I literally just got my ult too.
Please.
Oh my god, I'm sorry.
I couldn't help!
Oh my god!
Oh!
No!
The shark doesn't count as a person!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I played so well.
I actually played so well!
Oh my god.
I did so well there too.
Hmm.
Like, he's really good at Jeff.
It's just that we needed two defensive ults because they had so many...
They had way too many aggressive ults against us.
So we needed to...
We really needed an ult to defend ourselves with.
Yeah.
Like, his ult did nothing for us.
Yeah, not enough defensive ult.
Like, I can only do so much with a Luna ult.
I can only, like, I can defend against Dr. Strange ult.
I have to pick between Dr. Strange, Storm, or...
Dr. Strange or Storm or Hella.
And I can only use, like, one of the three.
So we needed, like, Adam.
Yeah, we needed Adam or Mantis.
That was a very intense game though.
That game was fucking crazy.
That was a good one.
That was a good game, IMO.
The person who played Storm actually made Storm look like a good character.
They made him look like an actual good character.
Hella can still... Not!
Luna heals can outheal the Hella.
I think.
I have tried it.
I feel like...
I feel like I can outheal Hella.
I just need, like...
Oh shit, nice.
I have... What was this team up again?
I don't remember this team up.
Oh, he gets my team up, right?
I have his channels into transferring her.
Yeah, what does this do?
Oh, it launches people.
Okay, I can heal with this.
Okay.
Alright, I get to heal.
This also heals, and I can, like... I can challenge people with it.
Like, if I get hit by flankers.
Can it be the Wazler and the thingy with the super cat thingy thingy?
Oh, we have three supports.
Okay, three supports works.
As long as the other support goes DPS-ish.
Like, plays DPS.
Cause it can work.
Oh, we lost one of the supports, so...
We lost two of this.
Okay.
Oh, goodbye.
Guess we leave.
It can work.
I just was not expecting us to go three supports.
I legitimately think there's more...
It's surprising, cause you would think there's more DPS players than...
I honestly would prefer three DPS over three supports.
Cause if we want three supports, we need another team.
Cause I can't do enough healing for the, uh...
For the...
For the little... For the Zen orb shit.
Oh my god, let's go.
It's time.
It's time for the clap.
Oh my god.
Woo!
Oh, we're running...
We're running two supports now.
Okay.
That's good.
Okay, nice.
Alright, I'm focused now.
Alright, we lost two players already before the match started, but that's okay.
That's okay.
I'm just gonna hide here.
Oh.
We're fine.
I'm locked in.
What?
Oh!
I was like, what the fuck was that shit?
Fuck!
Oh my god!
I was like...
Huh?
What?
I just...
Oh my god!
And it gets me!
Of course it gets me.
Like, fuck me I guess.
Just a little bit.
Why me?
What did I do?
That's so fucked.
That's actually so fucked.
I'm so fucked.
There was nothing I could do.
That's right!
Beat him up!
Beat up the shark!
Jeff knows your sin.
I need to give him the orb.
That's good.
He beat up the shark.
For real.
There we go.
The only hard part about healing Trifor right now is because we have one tank.
So I need to figure out how to get him healed.
Alright.
This is it.
We're ready to put on a show now.
I'm dancing!
I'm gonna die here.
Where is he?!
There you go.
I freed him.
You're free now.
Nice.
Alright.
We did it.
He's right there.
He's gone.
I gotta dance.
Gotta dance!
I should turn on my humidifier.
I got a humidifier, guys.
Orlyx was my life.
But wouldn't it be fabulous to have an awesome...
Because the air's been like super dry lately.
So I had to get a humidifier.
I think we're doing pretty well.
Climb-wise.
We're like up 80 points.
If we hit plat 2, it's possible.
I think we can hit plat 2 by...
In an hour, I think we can...
I think we can get to plat 1 within...
I think...
I think it's possible!
Because plat 1 is top 500.
Take the fist.
No, don't say that, guys.
Don't say that.
Guys, don't say it's gonna be a long stream.
It's possible.
It's so possible.
Guys.
You just gotta give me your energy.
Oh shit, there's Hawkeye.
There's Hawkeye's ult.
Oh no!
That's all of us!
No!
I heard it.
I heard the...
Wow.
Guys, I even ran.
I insta-ran too, but it didn't matter.
It didn't fucking matter.
That's the worst part.
I ran so fucking fast.
The moment I could...
The moment I could, I just fucking booked it.
But it didn't matter.
It didn't matter.
There's just no counter, I feel like.
There is a counter, just shoot it, but still.
It's so close.
Okay.
Get frozen.
You need to do this, because you're all low.
Then you...
You can do this.
And I'm gonna dance here.
I want... Oh, can I use this aggressively?
I don't know, it's very risky to use this aggressively, but...
I'm gonna use it aggressively.
I'm gonna do it.
Come on, push with this.
Push with this.
I knew it.
Oh no.
That was a huge risk to use it aggressively.
I felt like there was nothing else I could do.
There's nothing else I could do there.
Guys, something's not working.
We gotta change something, guys.
I think we gotta change our comp.
Maybe change the Widowmaker?
I don't know.
No!
Goodbye.
Every time.
I'm red, I'm red.
There's no...
You hear the ult sound and I'm red!
I'm red!
I'm red so far.
You don't understand.
I am so red.
This is a good Jeff map.
You can't see!
It's cause this is actually a good Jeff map, chat!
Oh no, that's bad.
This is bad.
We lost two already.
Okay, nice.
Oh no, nice!
Oh, we recovered.
Holy shit, we recovered it.
That's so good.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
What?
Oh, they're going in!
He just beats them up and goes in!
He's like, I'm not done with you!
I like how Dr. Strange didn't even go in there.
He's just like, yeah, I'm not fucking done with you.
Oh no, he's gonna fucking smash, guys.
Oh my god, I don't need to use it yet.
There's no reason to.
No!
You can't eat me!
I had to!
I fucking had to!
It was the only way to live!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I'm alive!
I ulted to live!
I actually ulted to live there!
Oh no, no!
Wait, oh, we can... we got this.
Guys, get the point!
Get the point!
Stay on point!
Stay on point, please!
The champ is a menace.
Not again!
I can't!
I can't keep getting eaten by Jeff!
Not again!
Jeff's so hungry.
So hungry!
Wait, BRB.
Bathroom.
Don't... okay, I hope he doesn't Q instantly.
I'm back.
Okay, that shit was so fucking scary.
Holy fuck.
I swear it was targeted.
I swear.
There's no way it wasn't.
That shit felt so targeted.
I was like, what the fuck do I do?
I literally had to like... I ulted just so I could stay alive.
I ulted so I don't have to deal with Jeff's fucking bullshit.
The thing is, when you're ulted, he can't eat you.
So he's still trying to fucking eat me!
That's so fucked up!
Like, I ulted so he doesn't eat me and he still tried!
What the fuck is wrong with you?
There's something not right about him.
Alright.
He said Jeff is a good dog.
It sucks.
That was actually a really good Jeff map too.
Alright.
See, this is why people are like, why is everybody hating on... This is why.
Now you know.
For those who don't play Marvel Rivals, now you know why people hate Jeff so much.
Now you feel our pain.
What the fuck is that sound?
I was like...
I'm gonna use this.
I think they're taking too much damage.
Then you heal both tanks at the same time.
Woah!
What the fuck?
Oh shit.
Please, please!
I didn't even ping!
I didn't even ping for heals!
Mantis, please.
We gotta help each other, Mantis!
Mantis, we have to... Oh, you're alive.
Of course you are.
Of course you're alive.
Okay.
Of course you're alive, Mantis.
Whoopies.
Oh my god.
I could easily just, you know, let you die so you know how I felt.
Bro is on Ironman?
No way!
He's a really good Ironman, guys!
Oh no.
Okay, nice.
Oh no, not the moon!
Oh no!
Okay, that was a really good snowball from me.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
She's so low!
I got her!
Whoops, that wall needed freezing.
Why the fuck do we have Ironman?
Is he okay?
No, he's not Ironman.
What is he?
Oh, he's not Ironman anymore.
Yeah, I was like, what the fuck?
He just wants to be in the air.
Okay.
Alright, here we go!
It's time to dance!
Yippee!
It's dance time!
What am I?
Oh, got hella.
Get shit on, bitch.
Oh my god.
I'm so low.
Somebody can poke me and I'll be fucking dead.
Please, oh my god, please!
Thank you!
I just, I needed, I was gonna say, I just need, if somebody touches me once, I'm fucking dead.
Nice.
Oh, I have C!
I forgot about the C!
Oh my god, again!
Yes, again!
Again!
Holy shit!
Is he having a ga- OH MY GOD, TRIPPER, YOU'RE FUCKING CRAZY!
GET OUT!
GET OUT, TRIPPER!
Holy shit!
The again chain!
Again!
Oh, he died!
He actually died.
Bro, that sucks, bro.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, let's go.
He's fine.
Nice.
We used a lot of ults there, but that's okay.
We're fine.
Everything is fine.
Again!
I can't believe, like, he actually...
Nice.
Oh...
Oh, I had to do it!
I got...
I had to!
Oh, this is where we die, though!
This is where I should have used it.
Oh my god, wait, what?
Again?
Oh my god, again!
Don't worry, I got it.
I'm coming over.
I don't know if he was saying that sarcastically or not.
I don't know!
Yeah, I'm just gonna try and keep...
He's Groot!
Oh shit, he's Grooting!
He's Grooting right now!
Anti-Psylocke on the left side.
Oh my god!
Okay.
Oh my god, what do I do there?!
No!
That's like everything in Grooted!
I was like, what do I do?!
Everybody wanted to fucking kill me!
That's fucking scary, that's for sure.
The way I push up.
Let's go!
Let's
dancing!
Yeah!
I used up all my cooldowns!
If I didn't use a freeze, if a fucking giant venom, giant thick-ass toxic shadow ran at me, that's when you know I had no cooldowns.
That's when you know I had no freeze.
I didn't consecute everything that I did.
You think I willingly stared him down without freezing him, chat?!
You think that was consensual?!
Like, I had no free cooldowns!
Well, except for, you know.
I don't know about TPing on this point, because they can kind of see us.
Yeah, I mean, only if I'd rotate.
He's literally right.
As he slowly walked up to me, the first thing I wasn't thinking about was like, I gotta do this, I gotta...
This is the sad part.
I don't have C, he's moonlight.
I am Groot.
Alright, I think I froze somebody, yeah I did.
OH SHIT!
God, bitch.
That's fucking right.
Be afraid of me!
I am a Luna Snow that can fucking aim!
That's fucking right!
Be a fairy afraid!
Oh my gosh.
I need to do this, for the stronger heals.
OH MY GOD!
BE AFRAID!
HAHAHAHAHA!
That's fucking right!
Be fucking afraid of me!
You're the deepest healer!
Cause there's a lot of Luna Snows that just know how to heal and can't aim.
But I'm not, I'm not that type of Luna.
Okay, let's just dance a little bit, guys.
Let's just... let's just...
Yay!
Again!
Where did he go?
Oh!
I was trying to find where he went!
Where did he go?
Alright, nice.
Again!
Oh, there he is.
There they go.
Oh, they can't...
HAHAHAHAHA!
You're so toxic!
Easy.
HAHAHAHAHA!
Cause you know how, like...
You know how, like, um...
Maywa?
You can break the Maywa by shooting at it?
I don't think you can do...
Again!
I don't think you can do that with...
Um...
With Groot.
Yay!
One more rank, guys!
One more rank!
One more rank up!
Two!
We're good!
We're gaining!
We got one more!
We have one more.
Yeah, I saw.
He's going for...
Coke.
Um...
Yes, it's still plat one!
Oh my god, we're so close!
Okay, yeah, it's full plat one.
Okay, there's like...
A full hundred page...
A full hundred people.
Oh my god!
We're so close!
HAHAHAHAHA!
Yeah!
I'm so...
Can you put three...
Oh, you can?
I feel like it's so hard to break the Groot wall.
I shot at the Groot wall...
And it's so fucking hard to break it.
But him being able to put three of them...
Is actually pretty fucked up.
Like...
I think you got...
There's a lot of things you got to nerf...
In...
Marvel Watch.
Haha!
Marvel Arrivals.
Golden Freeman, thank you for the superchat!
Thank you!
Um...
I still can't believe the first 3D animation from these mods was a Hulk making Jeff bite the curb.
HAHAHA!
Look...
That was fueled by pure hate, guys.
That...
That was...
Hate transcends...
Guys, you guys gotta know...
Hate...
Uh...
Transcends over...
Um...
Over lust.
HAHAHAHAHA!
If you hate something...
That is a bigger motivator.
HAHAHAHAHA!
For real...
HAHAHA!
I am more motivated from spite than anything else.
Oh my god...
I hope...
I hope my Luna Snow gameplay has been fun to watch.
Cause I know like...
Sometimes support's not that...
Fun to watch...
Overall.
But like...
I'm...
I'm DPSing a bit.
HAHAHA!
I mean...
I killed that...
You saw that...
Sick kill on the sidelock there?
You saw...
HAHAHA!
I'm glad.
I'm glad it's fun to watch.
Yay!
The battle from the backlines.
Oh my god.
Yes!
There we go.
I like how we get like the same...
Like usually the same people in this ELO.
Cause there's not a lot of...
Us anymore.
HAHAHA!
So we're just bumping into the same people over and over again.
No, don't say that.
No.
Don't say that guys.
Please.
I don't want to derank you...
Already guys.
Please.
I worked so hard.
HAHAHA!
Alright.
Oh my god.
It's possible!
Okay.
It took a little longer cause we kept bumping into Luna mains.
But like it's getting easier.
The moment we don't have another Luna main...
And I get to play Luna...
Everything is okay.
Everything is okay guys.
I just avoid all the Luna snow players.
HAHAHA!
It's just like Overwatch where you have to like...
Shoot these.
For better angles and stuff.
I have to like get rid of these railings so I can see.
I'm gonna be able to see.
Okay, this can be broken too but I don't want to break it.
Cause I can use this as cover.
Okay.
Nice, I froze Groot.
Oh no!
Groot is so fucking tilting the play against.
It really is.
I need to do this cause our tank needs help.
I can do double tank heals right here.
Oh my god.
Wait, I just realized I never used my...
Oh no!
Oh, I'm backing out though.
Okay.
Oh no!
I couldn't heal him!
What the fuck is Shurpa?
How am I supposed to give you this?
I'm gonna give it to the tank for now.
Oh my, there he is.
Oh!
I looked away for a sec!
I'm sorry!
Okay, there you go.
I'm sorry I looked away!
To be fair, he has a pocket mantis.
So I legitimately don't have to look.
Oh shit.
He actually has a pocket mantis.
So I'm just gonna heal the left side.
Okay, he's dead.
Okay.
That's awkward.
That's so awkward.
Okay.
I did not expect that to happen.
Not gonna lie.
You know, I thought he would honestly live a little longer.
Oh no.
It's not me.
I'm sorry.
Oh.
It's okay.
We can DPS this then.
Because this is...
Oh.
Oh my god!
There's too many!
Holy shit!
That's so many spiders!
Holy fuck!
What do we do?
It's just all spiders!
It's okay.
Holy shit!
It's just all spiders!
Oh my god, we're alive?
What the fuck?
We're alive?
Holy fuck, ow.
Wait, I'm gonna do something really risky.
No, I couldn't get it to work.
I don't know how the fuck we pulled that off.
I legitimately don't know how we pulled that off, not gonna lie.
Okay, 30 seconds.
Oh my god!
Captain America, please!
I'm trying to see where you are!
Holy shit!
Dance!
No!
Oh wait, I'm in all form.
It's fine.
Just as long as you guys are alive.
He just ate Captain America.
Sucks for him.
He ate Captain America.
Thank god.
Cap is playing like it's Marvel.
I forgot I was in all form.
I literally had like PTSD when I heard...
I went like full panic mode.
The fear.
Guys, after that one Jeff game, I can't... anything could happen.
Anything could fucking happen.
Yeah, PTSD.
Three penny alts, that's crazy!
Holy shit, how did we win the fight?
They literally had two penny alts.
How the fuck did we win?
That's post-traumatic shock disorder.
Jeff fear.
It's spidey time!
I legitimately don't know how we lived that.
We had no defense at all.
We just lived.
That's crazy.
Penny alt kinda doo-doo.
Honestly, I don't think I've ever died to a penny alt before.
I don't know.
I've yet to know what it actually does.
Yeah, I've already learned.
I remember when I... I remember when I... that was me.
I legitimately don't know because I feel like I've never like got hit by it, like died to it.
Oh nice.
Like, where do I look at?
Where do I look at?
Like, who do I look at?
Who do I... who do I kill?
Where do I go?
Alright, this is where I look at.
How did you guys get up top?
Oh, there we go.
Easy.
I'm like, everybody was like literally on their own.
Nobody was... I'm just like, everyone was just like in six different directions and I'm like, where do I go?
Where the fuck do I go?
Yay.
Nice.
Where the fuck is the other support?
Oh my god, they have three different supports because there's three different healers.
Nice.
Easy.
I'm plat 2, currently.
Plat 1 is... Plat 1 is top 500.
I'm plat 2.
Clap to win, guys.
Clap to win.
Halfway there, we're halfway there!
Clap to win, just like Luna!
Clap to win!
I forgot I was muted a little bit.
I had to blow my nose.
No, no, they have a Luna icon.
No, don't do this to me!
Don't do this to me, I'm faster!
I see a Luna icon, I'm like...
Please, don't do this.
I've been... I don't think I've... I don't know, I think I only lost one game on Luna.
I'm gonna avoid this person.
They had a Luna icon, I know.
I know.
I'm faster.
It's like the Mercy insta-locks.
I can't believe we lost with a fucking streamer team, that's actually crazy.
What are they like, Luna?
You don't know.
It's like Mercy players that have their icon and banner and everything.
They make their whole personality Luna.
I can't believe... IT'S... IT'S AIM!
IT'S TECHNICALLY... IT'S TECHNICALLY NOT MERCY!
I AIM WITH HER!
I FUCKING SHIT ON TPS!
COME ON!
I FUCKING KILLED SO MANY TPS PLAYERS AS LUNA!
If anything, it's like Kuroko.
If you think about it, it's just that she's sort of like the Mercy of...
Oh my god, where the fuck are you, Margaret Robb?
Oh shit.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna do this, because it's just... the heals are just more...
WHAT?
NO!
I got Hawkeye'd!
Fuck, okay.
I got Hawkeye'd.
Oh no, he's so eepy.
Okay.
I got Hawkeye'd.
That made me so sad.
I need... I'm gonna stand... I'm gonna stand in the back.
I don't want that to happen to me again.
Oh god.
I'm so scared, Durst.
He's like... he's like shooting random logs.
I'm so scared, guys.
Someone... someone get him.
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
Oh my god.
No!
Don't!
Please.
Please look at me!
Look at me!
Okay.
Holy shit!
Bro!
Look at me!
What?!
Oh no.
This is bad.
Guys, I think this is a team diff.
I think.
Guys, I have a feeling this might be a little team diff, guys.
Switch tank!
Fight!
Alright, I might ult this.
Oh, this is not good.
What?!
Oh, there's a fucking flanker!
I didn't even see him.
He ulted in front of me.
Fight!
I'm trying.
I'm trying so hard.
He's just like, fight!
Yo, Hela's scary.
And the thing is, they have Hela and Hawkeye.
So they have two, like, very heavy poke characters.
So it's very scary.
Like, right now.
Alright, here I go!
It's time to dance!
It's- Jesus Christ, okay.
Alright, it's dancing time!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I- How long is that?!
It's time.
Guys, I have a feeling that, um, I think it's a team diff right there.
I have a feeling it's a- It might be a little- Woah!
It might be a little bit of a team diff.
Oh my god!
Bro, this guy's so bad!
Woah!
Let us- Let us mute this guy before he starts saying something crazy.
He's hitting that level already, guys.
He's hitting that level of, like- He's gonna- He's gonna say something really bad next time.
He's gonna- He's gonna- He's gonna say something really, really bad next game.
He was getting there, I could feel it.
Alright.
Yeah, I had a feeling that- You know what?
Maybe I can- I can- Yeah, I know how to look at his profile.
Okay.
Oh, I can look at it now.
I'll look at it after this game.
I wanna know his win rate on- Oh wait, he plays support.
Wait, he could've done this his entire time?
He could've- You're trying to tell me that he could've just played support this entire time?
I'm plat 2!
I just made it to plat 2, so like, I'm gonna lose a little- Some points now.
I already just made it to plat 2.
I'm scared.
I'm a little scared.
Not gonna lie.
I'm a little scared of the peak.
I'm very scared of the peak right now.
I feel like I'm gonna get logged.
I feel like I'm definitely gonna get logged.
I feel like they're looking to log me right now.
Woah!
I can get this real fast.
Oh, he's one!
Liv!
No!
They're all trying to kill you!
Oh my god, I panicked.
I panicked.
I- I led my shot.
I could've killed the hell out of her!
I panicked!
She came out of nowhere and I choked!
My hands started shaking!
I was like, what the fuck are you doing here?!
The hell, I choked.
Yeah, she came out of fucking nowhere!
We're gonna win anyway.
We're definitely not gonna win that anyway.
Holy shit.
Okay, that's fine.
We got...
Okay, we're definitely gonna avoid him.
And then we're gonna avoid this guy because he was not having it.
He was... How do you have 433?
Yeah, this guy was definitely...
That's actually crazy.
This guy had like... was Mantis and only had 433 damage.
That's not good.
That's not good at all.
That's Mantis.
That's actually so bad.
Bro, the Irfuss had 1000 damage?!
No way!
No fucking way!
Oh my god.
Bro.
No, it was 100% a team diff.
It's a 0% accuracy.
This was definitely a team diff.
How the fuck did he get to plat like that?
They were just... Oh wait, we were playing against them.
Alright, we're playing against them now.
They have a good Storm player, by the way.
Oh, dude, Storm, I can shut him down so easy.
Oh shit.
Really?
Yeah, dude, Spider-Man, I mean, as long as it's not a closed off map, I can absolutely shit on Storm.
I'm trying to give you some damage boost, man.
He sounded so hopeful.
Yeah.
They were playing against a really, really fucking Gamer Hour Luna Snow.
Okay, they might lock in now.
Because they actually got some good players.
I do wish this comp... I mean, I guess we do have one team up on this comp, so it's not terrible.
Really?
Twirls hair?
Manny, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
What the fuck?
Wait, where is he?
Why is he not in the... Where is he?
Where's Iron Fist?
Where was he?
Wait,
how do I get up?
Okay, there you go.
Don't change, don't change, don't change.
Bro, bro, I'm trying so hard.
Yeah, no shit.
Bro.
Oh my god.
Bro, bro, I can't.
Wait, wait.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Oh no, he's Grooting.
Says the Spider-Man.
Guys, we just need two tanks, guys.
Guys, come on.
Come on, guys.
We just need two tanks, guys.
A true DPS player.
I'll do it.
Really?
A double support ult?
They're gonna use... I just hope we have the defensive ult for this.
You live!
You fucking live!
I clapped and you all live.
Guys, did you see how they line up for the clap?
Holy fuck, that was like the perfect lineup.
Oh my god.
It literally hit everybody.
Simple geometry right there.
I literally geometry'd that shit.
10 out of 10 clap.
I've only been clapping for four years now, so I hope so.
Oh god.
Guys!
Guys, please!
Where did my support duo go?
Oh, she died.
How the fuck did she die?
We got a mantis spawn.
Mantis spawn.
Okay, I'm coming back.
I got clapped hard.
Yikes, bro.
I killed Luna and Ironman.
I'm coming back.
Alright, okay.
I'm portaling above them to ult.
Alright.
Do you need damage?
I'll be here.
Nice.
We're in!
Oh my god.
That scared the shit out of me.
I thought I was gonna fall.
I don't think I need to ult this.
Yeah, that was a waste.
Portal above.
On him.
Nice, we got him.
What the fuck is this portal?
Now they're thinking we're portals.
What the fuck?
Okay.
I'll give it to the Spider-Man.
The Spider-Man is like feeling it right now.
He's really feeling it right now.
I'm dancing!
Oh, fuck!
Where are you?
Yep.
Nice, he's still, he's still.
Nice.
Go!
I'm gonna save ult.
Yep.
Nice.
We did it.
Good job, team.
Let's fucking go.
He's starting to believe.
He really is.
I still love the fact that, like, guys, guys, we need one more tank, guys.
Guys, we need one tank, guys.
That's the fucking Spider-Man player.
That's anybody but me, guys.
Except me, cause I'm Spider-Man.
I am Spider-Man.
Yeah, I think he, I think he, like, right-clicked me, and then shifted me, and then just headshot me.
350 damage burst combo, that's insane.
So cynical.
He's, he's popping off, though.
Spoken like a true one-trick, right, Dookie?
I mean, yeah, I think we just save portal for when we want to go in with ult is loaded.
Alright, he's him.
Alright.
It's okay.
I gave him the orb.
I'm sorry, Surefour.
But, like, I think he needs it more than you at this point.
Like, by the way he was playing there.
I don't think we should be falling.
Nice.
Let's go!
Oh god.
Oh my god.
It's okay, we're fine.
We're so healthy.
Wait, they're calling...
It's him!
It's because I have his chat blocked!
He's calling GG's again!
Oh my god.
That's, like, hilarious.
Oh my god, thank god I avoided him.
Free farm.
I hope I get to farm him again.
Sorry.
Sorry, Surefour, but you're not Spider-Man.
You're not him.
Sorry.
I had to.
What the fuck is going on, man?
Oh, yo, he's... he's alive?
Okay, I'm just...
Woah!
You're alive!
How did he...
Bruh, let's go!
We're fucking gamers!
He was not supposed to live.
But we Dr. Strange, we actually recreated Dr. Strange.
We...
We recreated the movie.
He came home.
Wait, Storm?
We literally recreated the movie there.
What an ult.
He changed the light.
Alright, I have ult here.
I'm gonna go behind them.
I'm gonna let you know when to damage boost me, okay?
I can see them.
Can you boost me now?
Right here?
Boosting.
Alright.
I'm getting dove.
I fell.
Wait, where?
Oh my god!
Please stand on me!
Okay, nice.
Okay.
I see a Venom.
Nice.
Oh my god, we did it!
What?!
Oh no, not again!
Oh no!
Oh no, he's coming for me!
He missed though!
I missed!
Oh my god, the team wins!
Looking easy.
Thank god we avoided him.
Thank god.
We avoided the enemy support.
I saw it!
The moment he went, he was gonna go gamer!
I was like, it's time to go.
You're out of here.
You're fucking out of my lobby.
Yeah!
We're so close!
Check his stats?
Oh yeah, you're right.
Okay, let's see if we can get it before our game queues up.
Uh...
History.
Like this, right?
Or is it view career?
He's plot one?!
He's top 500?!
How?!
Oh, is it because he's a one trick?
No, he plays...
Oh my god.
He's lost 30 plus games though.
No way!
He's higher elo than me?!
No fucking way!
Wait, what's my stats?
Oh, I can't see.
I'm gonna steal their spot.
I'm gonna take it.
I'm gonna fucking take your spot, man.
Okay.
I'm getting faster at locking her.
I'm kidding!
Not only am I getting better at Luna Snow, I'm getting faster at auto locking her.
I like, zone in.
It's muscle memory.
Yeah, I know exactly where it is now.
I gotta like, insta-scroll and everything.
Okay.
It's time.
What I'm happy about is that you lose less than you gain.
Which is great.
That's always a good thing.
Here's the orb.
I'm getting better at being a one-trick.
I think I'm gonna go for...
I'm gonna go for plat 1 and then I'm gonna call it.
Cause then I don't have to like, speedrun anymore.
I'm only speedrunning cause I wanna touch the leaderboard.
And just to be like, hey guys.
Look at me.
Or maybe I'll play like...
If I hit it, I'll play until I lose.
And then lose top 500, I guess.
What if I lose top 500 though?
Guys, what if I...
Guys, what if I lose it though?
Guys...
You can throw somebody?
Okay, I did not expect that.
Not gonna lie.
What the f...
Oh shit, sorry for laughing!
Oh my god!
I'm so sorry!
I should not have laughed!
Oh my god.
It was so funny in the moment.
You know what I'm saying?
It was so funny in the moment though.
It was so...
Oh shit.
It was like some FNAF jumpscare right there.
It was like legitimately a FNAF jumpscare.
It was so funny in the moment.
You don't understand.
Oh my god, bro.
He's coming over!
He's coming over.
I'm so scared.
Look, he laughed and then all came over.
Bro, I didn't expect it!
Holy shit!
He's fucking...
You're crazy!
He just fucking jumps in like that.
You're fucking crazy.
Bro said hug you.
It was so funny though.
It was so funny.
Couldn't help it.
The health is really good.
Yeah.
I agree.
That's why I'm not like peeking too much.
I don't know if I should use it defensively because like...
Liv...
Oh my...
How much damage are you taking?
How much
are you taking though?
Oh my god.
That's fucking...
Fuck, that's fucked.
She ulted the ult.
Guys, I think this is a team diff.
I...
Guys, I think...
I think this is a team diff right there.
I...
I don't know.
Oh my god.
He's coming over.
I'm sorry for laughing.
I'll never laugh at you again.
Holy fuck.
He's coming.
I'm so sorry.
Ever since I laughed at him, it's never been the same.
It's been very scary.
The Hulk is so good.
Like, I think their Hulk and Hela are carrying.
For sure.
Oh my god.
Bro.
Adam.
Adam, he's coming over.
He's...
Oh, he's walked away.
He walked away.
Because he knows.
He knows we were scared.
He knows we were so scared.
Adam.
He knows.
He knows we're so scared of him.
Bro, somebody kill him.
This Hulk is really good, though.
Not gonna lie.
I think our tank is worse than...
Our tank is definitely not as good as theirs.
I mean...
I don't know what...
Let's go.
We fight.
Wake up.
Bro, wake up.
Oh no, he's gonna smash now.
Oh shit, I didn't see her.
I didn't see her.
I was worrying about 300 other things going on in my fucking screen.
Oh god.
There were so many things going on.
I was scared about so many things.
You know...
I was so scared about so many things, guys.
No!
Why me?!
Please!
Heal!
Just keep...
Beat him up, shark!
Please!
Oh my god.
No!
He didn't even kill the shark.
Oh my god.
Yay!
This is definitely a team diff, guys.
I can't...
I'm too scared to go up there.
No!
He hasn't died one single time!
I'm gonna avoid our Adam.
Adam is definitely not the character we need right now.
Also, our Groot is not that good.
He's getting tank diffed a lot.
I mean, he is getting hella tank diffed.
This is not it.
This is not the game, chat.
He's hulking all over us.
Oh, you know Surefour's giving up.
He's on the worst...
He's on the worst DPS possible.
He's just like, it's over.
It's so...
He's recreating...
He's recreating a comic book right now.
He's recreating lore.
No, don't say that.
We were so close.
We literally needed like two to three wins.
Well, now we definitely need three wins.
Lore accurate.
Guys, no, you don't understand.
Wolverine is the worst DPS character.
Or duelist.
He's literally one of the worst ones.
Oh, our Groot has given up.
Our Groot was like, I ain't tanking this.
Okay, goodbye.
I don't think our Groot wants to tank this anymore.
I think he's like very done in general.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure he's like...
He's like, bro, I ain't tanking.
Bro, he's left!
Oh my god, he's actually done.
He's just like, bro, I'm not tanking this.
Oh my god.
Oh, he's back.
Is he gonna play the game?
We'll find out.
Oh my god, please.
No, he is not back.
He is actually AFKing.
Oh, he's... oh yeah, game crashed.
Yeah, likely story.
Yeah, very likely story.
The game crashed.
Sure, buddy.
Just like that?
Okay, I'm gonna give it to like...
The one with the fleshies, cause...
Oh, what the fuck?
What the fuck?
Okay, I didn't see that.
Now's your chance, play.
Play.
I'm gonna avoid the Atom and the Groot.
I don't think your Atom is a good player in general.
Oh my god, there you go.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, he's recreating a movie!
He's recreating a movie right now!
Wait, we capped it?
Oh.
I'm gonna freeze him.
It does death thing.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Wait, we're here.
How did we cap this?
For real?
Avoid the Wolverine.
Wait, we actually capped it?
How?
One of them turned on their aimbot?
How the fuck did we cap it?
Is there- Oh my god, Hawkeye, are you okay?
Hawkeye!
Speak to me!
Holy shit, he lived!
He's Groot.
No, no.
Oh, thank god.
I'm trying!
Guys!
Jump!
I couldn't!
I swear, I tried!
I shot him!
I legitimately shot him!
He has no head, it's just a fin!
What do I do?
What do I do when it's just a fin?
This is Groot, guys.
We dance.
We fucking dance.
Groot, please, I can't heal you when I'm dancing.
We start dancing.
We start dancing!
Now they're gonna do the Psylocke ult.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry they start- There it is.
I called it.
There it is.
There we go.
Groot, please!
Groot!
Just keep Grooting!
Oh my god!
I know that doesn't do jack shit, but like...
Oh my god.
How are we?
Oh my god, he's second raging!
Psylocke's so desperate.
You know what?
I'm proud of us for pushing this far.
We're doing it.
He can bleed.
Guys, the Hulk?
The Hulk can bleed.
He's not a god.
He can actually bleed, guys.
There's hope.
There's actual hope.
He's Grooting!
Dancing!
I'm dancing so hard!
No!
Oh wait, it's fine.
Oh, he's doing not fine, but...
It'll be okay.
It'll be so okay.
Oh my god.
I am trying to heal.
Please.
Please, I've never stopped healing.
Oh no, the big boy!
Oh, and he used a bubble so I can't do anything about it!
Are you okay?
Oh, you're okay.
You're okay.
He's fine.
Oh my god, we made it to the next checkpoint!
We made it!
He took it like a champ.
He sure did.
Okay, that was a...
I think Adam's good at attack.
I don't know about defense, though.
Because now Adam's working for...
For attack.
Oh, I thought I got the...
Okay, guys.
Groot.
Oh!
I didn't even have to take one damage!
I'm coming back.
Wait, is he...
Is that...
Oh my god!
Yep.
I'm gonna...
You guys can kill him.
I'm coming back, guys.
You're fine.
How the fuck did you guys live that long?
Oh my god, it's okay.
Put on a show!
Just attack!
Just keep fighting!
Oh, okay.
This is a little bad, though.
I don't know where I am.
I...
You think she knows I'm here?
You think she knows?
I'm sorry, Adam.
That was my hiding spot.
That was my hiding spot, Adam.
Only...
It's only one allowed.
Kodoki to go put on a show.
Oh my god, we capped it?
What?
Oh my god, we actually capped it?
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
Okay.
This is doable.
This is doable, chat.
This is so doable.
Oh my god.
Surefour on Wolverine is the play.
Don't underestimate Hulk and Wolverine.
Wait, he's also Canadian!
Wait, it fits!
Yeah, this is the new Marvel Watch game.
Um, mixed account.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, three minute defense.
Okay, we have a one minute attack, though.
But we also have three minute defense.
It all comes down to this.
I'll be very, very surprised if we win this.
Cause like...
The odds are very against us right now.
It's fun!
This game is very addicting.
I know a lot of people are getting super addicted to this game.
Cause it feels just like when Overwatch first came out.
And the games are like super competitive cause I'm in high elo.
So it looks...
So like, I trick you guys into thinking Marvel Rivals is this fun.
And then if you're like in the lower elo and...
You're like, why is it my game just like this?
Why are my teammates...
Why don't my teammates play like the teammates in Doki's games?
I don't think it was smart for them to go there.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
He's one.
No!
He was so low!
That Captain America was so low!
I almost got him too.
The only bad part is that I'm not charging.
I'm not getting support fast enough.
So like, I'm a little worried.
I'm a little worried about that.
Okay.
Oh my god!
That's Jeff!
I was like, where did he come from?
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
Bro!
Jeff came out fucking...
Holy shit!
That was crazy!
I saw him fucking kidnap!
No way!
I'm so crazy!
I'm kidding!
That was actually crazy.
Watching that kidnap.
Oh my god.
I'm not focused right now.
That shit was so funny.
That shit was so funny and I'm not focusing right now.
I'm shaking too much!
Oh my god!
That was so good.
I have to use it.
Okay.
Oh my god!
Goodbye everybody!
Goodbye!
Oh shit!
Wait, he fucked up!
Jeff fucked up!
Oh shit!
Goodbye Jeff!
Goodbye!
Oh my god!
Adam!
Get over here!
Wait, we just all got off.
We all just got off the cart.
Guys, guys.
I can't feel you guys up there.
Oh my god.
Jeff is up there.
Oh god.
He's brute, guys.
Holy shit!
Every time!
He just...
That's so funny!
He just shows up next to me!
I'm just like, where did he come from?
Every time!
I just turn around and I'm like, he brings somebody over.
Oh my god.
They don't expect the...
I switch hella, dip that guy like three times and then he's fucking...
Holy shit!
What the fuck is he saying?
I am...
What the fuck?
I'm optic!
He really is!
Fucking Wolverine optic!
Bro, it's like a fucking Roadhog hook.
Wolverine wants to play all along, guys.
Who would've thought?
Bro, he does...
Wolverine wants to play all...
Wait, why are we in three supports?
Oh my god, we have Jeff now.
Who said...
Bro, he's literally the worst character.
I don't know how he's making it work.
Oh shit.
I forgot to click confirm.
I don't know how he's making it work.
He's literally the worst character in this game.
His abilities fucking suck.
Oh my god, so much healing.
He's just like, I'm gonna learn Wolverine today.
And then ends up fucking killing everybody.
I am Groot.
Did you hear that?
He's Groot.
Guys, do you hear that?
He's Grooting.
Guys, he's Groot.
He's Groot!
I don't know how the fuck...
I'm Groot.
I am Groot.
I should eventually hit him, right?
There's like a clusterfuck of people there.
I'm just shooting in the general direction, hoping I hit something.
Oh no, oh no!
I had to reload at that time!
We had three healings and all of you guys had to reload!
Please.
Okay.
Guys, there's like a guy right here.
Guys, guys.
Guys!
We're Grooting!
We're Groot!
Oh my god!
I'm sorry, goodbye!
I'm Groot.
I'm Groot!
Guys, no!
Groot, come back!
Holy shit!
We got it to like a minute though.
Like, that was a good defense.
I still don't know why we have Jakey on Sharkboy.
Jakey was doing so well as attack.
Wait, was Jakey on... wait.
Yeah, Jakey was doing really good as attack.
I don't know why he swapped off.
Oh my god.
I guess we can use it to get off point too.
But now we're so...
Okay.
Alright.
It's time.
He's Groot!
Oh shit!
Wait, that's not...
Oh no.
Wait, we lost that?!
Oh my god, please!
Please!
I'm sorry, Groot!
No!
How much is my ult?!
I have ult!
Oh my god, enemy team is locking in too.
Did we even use the Jett ult?!
What did you do with it?!
He's Groot.
No.
I have ult.
I have ult though.
Oh no.
They're all locking in.
I think the three support was a troll pick.
I legitimately think this is troll.
I think if we didn't run this...
Everything would've been fine.
I'm going in!
I am Groot!
Oh, it's not me.
No, my god!
The three support was troll!
It was troll, I swear!
Eat them!
Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, we won!
Holy shit, I can't believe we won that game!
Oh my god, he ate them!
Oh my god, go back to...
What the fuck does that even mean?!
I is Jett the MVP!
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Bro, that was hell.
I kept everybody alive for so long.
Oh my god.
I literally...
I'm literally healthful.
I'm literally like medical care right now.
Oh my god.
That was crazy.
That was a crazy game.
I can't believe we won that game.
I'm gonna get water real...
Oh my gosh.
Okay, I'm gonna insta-lock and then get water real quick.
Yeah, I deserve like 50 points from that.
I'm better health care than Canada right now.
Oh my god, that was crazy.
That was a fucking crazy game.
What do we have?
Alright, I'm gonna get water.
I'll be right back.
As bad as things get, I try to stay positive.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready!
This could be the rank up game, but it doesn't guarantee top 500.
Chat, we don't know exactly where top 500 is in plat 1.
But this could be the rank up game.
Alright, here we go.
I still can't...
I can't believe Wolverine worked.
Like, that was fucking crazy.
That was actually fucking crazy.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Got it?
Is Luna still... No, I'm just a Luna one trick.
I sadly don't know how to play any other character.
Oh wait, they went behind.
Nope, no intel.
I didn't know that.
I didn't know they were on TP.
I was AFK!
No, not more Groot.
Oh no, I'm Groot!
I am Groot.
Oh my god, he's Grooting.
Jesus Christ, how much damage were you guys taking?
Calm down!
We're all Groot.
Warlock is good, but like...
He has the lack of... His heals are very limited.
Luna... I think Luna is better for sustainability.
I think it's Luna... I personally think after playing for this long...
I think it's Luna, Mantis, and Cloak and Dagger.
IMO, I feel like are...
Are the best healers.
Oh my god, it takes fucking forever!
To break the walls!
Like Mei... Mei is like... Mei walls are easier to break than this.
Oh, I have ult.
Let's go.
Let's go, let's fucking dance, everybody!
I'm ready to put on a fucking show!
Wow!
Let's take a... Yeah, baby!
Let's go!
Let's fucking go!
I got ult anyway.
Bro, get out of spawn!
Get out of spawn!
Okay, that's on you.
That's on you.
That's on you, honestly.
Like, you did not have to be there.
Oh no.
Goodbye, Groot.
Oh no!
I've always been a support main!
I was a support main in Overwatch!
He was feeling way too frisky there.
Oh my god, how the fuck?
Okay, I was gonna say.
How the fuck am I not hitting that?
Oh, okay.
I looked away for one second.
Why don't I Jeff?
Jeff is fucking situational.
This map is a terrible Jeff map.
For example.
And like, Luna Snow is just overall a better character.
Okay, I did not realize we were going high ground, but here we are.
Oh my god.
What?!
Again!
Don't again me, please!
No, he's gonna again!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that scared the shit out of me.
Again!
I'm heading over, I'm heading over.
Please, please live.
Please.
Oh my god, I'm dancing too.
I'm putting a show just to start hitting.
Oh my god, shoot the turret!
Holy shit, you're alive.
Wait, Dr. Strange died?
How?
He's grooting.
Nice.
Time to dance.
Oh my god.
He was tanking all the alzheimer's like, Dr. Strange, what are you doing?
Don't be a hero!
Dr. Strange, get out of there!
We can't fucking fix you up a second time!
I mained Lucio at first.
And then Lucio went out of meta at one point.
I basically mained any character that was meta.
Back then in Overwatch, but right now.
But at that time, I learned every character as I was ranking up.
So I was able to play almost every character.
Every support character.
But I really enjoyed Luna in Marvel.
And Luna was there since Alpha.
So because Luna was there since Alpha, I occasionally played her the most.
So I had the most experience with her as a support.
So because of that, I went in too deep and I kept ranking up as Luna.
That it was too late for me to learn another support character.
It was way too late.
Because if I try to play a different character right now, it will not go so well.
If I try to play a different support.
Because I know my skill wise, I have a high skill.
I know that I'm good at...
Oh my god, I know that I'm good at Luna.
So I'm not too worried about it.
Jesus Christ, how did everybody fucking die?
Oh my god, I'm sorry.
Oh, okay.
I can't keep anybody up there.
Oh my god, you guys are fucking crazy.
You guys just went in there to die.
I'm so surprised we... oh my god.
That was not my fault.
Okay, let me make sure he doesn't die first.
Okay, you guys are gonna come up top.
I'm just gonna make sure this fucker doesn't fucking die.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright, that's scary.
Oh, he's dead.
Okay.
We go, we go.
He's dead.
Oh.
Nice.
Wait, me too.
I am also ready to put on a show.
Hey, me too.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh, guys, calm the fuck down.
Guys.
There can't all be... we gotta calm down with all the shows, guys.
Jesus Christ, how did I live through all of that?
Yeah, nobody dies.
That's like literally almost all their ults there.
We're fine.
We're still healthy.
Okay.
We were almost all healthy.
We were almost there.
Oh my god, I froze him though.
Oh, that was a good freeze for me.
Oh.
Oh, no.
I'm sorry.
Go, Dr. Strange and Groot.
I'll keep you guys alive.
Jesus, it's only 40%?!
I feel like I've been...
Oh my god, I feel like we've been here for a while now.
I can't believe it's only at 40-50% now.
Oh my god, okay.
That's awkward.
That's really awkward.
Guys.
Guys, I'm ready to put on a show.
Alright, goodbye guys.
Oh no.
Oh no, please.
Live.
Live, tanks.
Tanks, as long as you guys are alive.
The show must go on.
Don't let him do this to me!
Stop!
Holy shit, he's still chasing me.
What's wrong with you?
Oh my god, what's wrong with all of you?
Oh my god, that's so much damage.
Holy shit.
Okay, yeah, that, we were not living there.
We were not, that was targeted.
Holy shit, we're coming in with five ults.
Like, if we don't win this, this is like, we deserve to lose that round.
Like, we're literally coming in with like, six ults, five ults.
Alright, go in.
I like how he set up a turret there, he's like, this is it.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
We almost didn't stand on point.
That would have been so fucking bad.
Guys, you know what that means?
Let's put on a show!
Oh my god, almost C9.
Yeah!
Thank you, superchat, thank you, thank you.
Hey Toki, it's my birthday today and I thought I'd share something with you.
Happy birthday to you, happy birthday to you.
Yeah, plot one!
We're better than 99.93% of people in the world!
Oh my god, look!
Yeah!
Happy birthday to...
No!
I couldn't check the link!
I wanted to check the link!
No!
I need to know!
I need to know how close I am.
Wait, I'm in diamond lobbies?
Oh no!
Happy birthday to you, happy birthday dear Nuh-uh.
Happy birthday to you.
Yeah!
I didn't even get a chance to look at my rank!
Wait, can I...
Can I look at my profile?
No!
Oh no, it's not fair!
I didn't get to look at my rank!
I need to know how close I am to...
I need to know how close I am to top 500!
I didn't check!
Guys, am I on the leaderboard, guys?
Guys!
Am I in the leaderboards, guys?
No, it was my fault.
Yeah, I wanted to show people that I'm better than 99.93% of the people playing this game.
Someone check if my name's on there!
And if it is, someone screenshot it!
Please, that's all I want to know.
What the fuck?
How do you have took damage already?
Like, how do I play this?
Oh my god, I'm gonna clap here.
Because everybody's lined up for clapping.
Oh my god, what are you doing?
You're crazy!
I'm on the leaderboard in our hearts.
But I need to know if I'm on the leaderboard in general!
No, I'm plat 1!
I made it to plat!
I'm plat 1.
Well, I was always plat, but I made it to plat 1.
Guys!
Guys, am I in it?
Yes or no?
No?
Okay, that means it's not over yet.
We gotta keep grinding.
Yeah, that means I gotta keep playing.
If it's not, if I'm not on it.
Oh my god, someone help me.
Alright, so we gotta keep playing anyway.
Thank god.
Oh yeah?
Wait, not yet.
I shouldn't put on a show yet.
Oh my god, woah!
Woah, I'm ready to put on a show too!
No!
I didn't expect him to insta-die!
Oh god.
Oh my god, you guys.
Oh my god, goodbye.
I did not expect him to insta-die there.
He still stopped the car.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Please.
No, he's one!
No, I couldn't press C!
Oh my god, I couldn't press C.
I'm so stupid.
I forgot that he's... I forgot he's Iron Fist.
If I pressed C, I could've lived.
I always need to remember to team up stuff.
I forget to team up stuff sometimes.
I need to remember that when I've teamed up, I need to press C on...
Woah!
Whoops, I did not think he would shoot me there.
Um, I can have like... I can heal myself and also have like a...
A thing that can skip dive targets off me.
Okay, you... I...
I can't keep you up forever.
Oh my god, I babysat...
I babysat him so hard.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
That solo ult on our fucking other support.
Jesus Christ, I'm surprised she lived.
That shit was crazy.
Oh my god, he's...
I can't... I need you to kill him.
I need you to kill Groot.
I need you to kill Venom right now.
Oh no!
I honestly thought he was gonna kill him.
Oh, this is bad.
Oh no.
I legitimately thought he could do it.
Oh nice.
Oh my god!
That ult was insane!
That was actually such a good ult.
The Psylocke ult was so good.
Nice.
Yeah!
Yeah, Psylocke popped off in the last round.
Hydrating.
Who's ace right now?
Fire?
Oh, it's our Groot!
A really good Groot is so scary though.
Yeah, do I have a main yet?
If you watch this vibe, it's been four hours of Luna Snow.
Guys, I don't know yet.
I don't know what my main is.
I don't know what my main is, guys.
Four hours of Luna Snow and then like two minutes of Jeff.
There was Subzire and then like 30 seconds of Mantis.
Could be Jeff.
Who knows?
Remember when I used to be a Loki main?
Oh, those were the days.
Those were the days.
Yeah, I'm just trying to figure out what character I like so far.
I'm just trying to figure it out.
Woo!
Yeah, if Loki had better heal output.
His heal output is so bad now.
Like he's just a DPS support.
Which is barely a support in general.
Jeez!
Poor Doctor Strange!
Holy shit!
That poor guy!
What the hell?
I'll just stay here on the cart.
Yippee!
I'm just- It's just like Lucio.
Feels just like Lucio.
Feels just like home, guys.
Just like home.
I gotta make sure the cart pushes fast enough.
Oh shit!
How the fuck?
How the fuck?!
Oh my god!
Goodbye!
Goodbye, Groot!
Groot!
Holy shit!
Go, Groot, go!
I don't think Groot's gonna live.
Okay, yeah, I was gonna say.
I was gonna say.
There's no way he lives that.
Surefour, I swear to god.
Surefour.
Peek me.
Peek me so I can give you your stupid orb.
Yeah, I almost have ult, though.
What?
What happened?
What the fuck happened?
Oh!
Guys!
Guys, we just gotta stick together, guys!
Guys, I have ult!
Just gotta stick together.
Okay, I'm ready.
I'm gonna ult in.
It's Groot, guys!
Guys, did you guys know?
It's Groot!
It's Grootie!
Oh, she's gonna sidelock ult.
I can feel it.
Yep, there it is.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh my god, there he is!
Holy shit, how much- I can't!
I cannot heal all this damage!
Oh my god, I cannot heal!
Jesus Christ, we have 60 seconds left.
We have 60- No, please, I have to reload.
No!
Oh my god.
Please.
This is the last fight.
This is actually the last fight.
I can, I can.
No!
Me too!
I'm putting on a show as well!
Please.
I can't put on a show forever!
Oh no.
Please.
No!
We actually lose this?!
No way!
We trolled!
Oh my god!
We actually trolled!
I can't believe it!
Oh my god!
It's okay, I still stay in Plat 1.
I still stay.
We weren't- It's okay, we weren't in- We weren't in Top 500 yet anyway.
Guys, we weren't in Top 500.
See, look at that.
We weren't in Top 500 anyway.
It's okay.
It's okay, we still have a chance.
We're still a team.
Yeah, everybody was just like everywhere.
Nobody played together.
What is it?
Wait!
No, it's so close!
I'm so close!
Where is it?
Oh my god, I'm so close!
It's like right there!
It's right there!
Oh my god, it's almost close to Diamond.
Top 500 is almost Diamond.
It's like...
50 spots left in Plat 1.
Oh my god, please!
Please!
We're almost there!
Please, I just want to be Top 500!
And then we can chill.
I think we might have won that game.
Yeah, we trolled that one.
Our team was like super split up.
And nobody played together in the end.
Everybody was like...
Everybody was just going in like by themselves.
Oh my god, we're so close though.
Like, it's literally...
I'm pretty sure he's in Top 500.
He's literally Diamond.
Oh, I was going to check.
I think he's Top 500.
Three-ish games?
How do you know?
Let's see.
I think Shuriblur's the only...
Oh no, there's another Diamond on the enemy team too.
This is a Plat Diamond lobby.
Oh my god, initial class!
No, Top 500 leaderboard is instant.
I know because so many friends...
The moment they get it, it's instant.
To be fair, two tiers?
From Plat 3 to Plat 1 in four hours?
I think it's pretty fast.
We only lost...
I don't even know what my record is.
What is my win to loss record?
Right now.
80 points?
Wait, how do you know that?
How do you know it's 80 points?
Wait, how do you know it's 80 points, chat?
Oh, were you there?
Source type main?
I don't know what the points are.
Oh wait, it's Storm.
Only have one DPS, this is a little scary.
And one tank, say.
Oh no, he's coming.
He's coming over.
Wait, what?
You guys heard that, right?
Yeah.
Wait, you guys heard...
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god!
He's opening a portal, guys!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, he is opening up a portal, everybody!
Oh my god, I can't even get to my teammates.
Alright.
I heard, I'm opening up a portal, and I was like, where?
I'm okay.
I feel okay.
I don't though.
Yeah, that was a really good play by them.
He was definitely opening up a portal.
That was an incredibly good pick by them.
Come on.
I'm locked in, guys.
I'm gonna be super locked in now.
If I can heal and also do this.
Wait, where did he go?
Oh!
Jesus Christ!
I...
Bro, all we did was heal.
Please.
No, I...
I couldn't get the angle!
Oh no.
No!
Oh my god.
The angle...
Sure, her head was in a weird ass angle, so I couldn't get the headshot in.
The angle was so fucking weird.
It was a good freeze though.
At least the freeze was cool.
Okay.
It's fine.
Locked in.
Goodbye.
Oh, thank god.
Alright.
I'm ready to put on a show now.
Yay!
Dancing!
And I leave nothing.
No!
Goodbye.
Good fucking bye.
That was...
A sad...
I think we have three support players.
Because why the fuck do we have Jeff?
Oh my god, please.
No, I still have like...
I think I can lose three.
This Venom is really good though.
This Venom is very annoying.
What the fuck?
He like dodged it?
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
I'm locking in.
I'm so locked in.
I'm trying so hard right now.
You're gonna live.
You're gonna fucking live.
He's gonna fucking do that thing.
Bro, this Venom is fucking...
Nobody has died!
No one has died on the enemy team!
Please!
Jesus Christ.
Please, all we do is heal you!
Oh my god, thank god.
Oh my god, some people actually died.
That's crazy.
We actually killed people.
That's insane.
We finally have kills.
Jesus.
Come on.
Yeah, but they have two supports.
Oh, that's true.
But like, you're right.
The two supports...
The three supports are just healing.
They're not actually, like, shooting things.
Oh my god, please.
I froze him.
Please.
You cannot die.
You don't die.
Oh, but you both...
You do not die until I tell you to die.
You...
Oh, get over here!
Get your ass over here, old man!
Get your ass over here!
Jesus.
I don't know how we lived there.
Oh my god, he just walked away.
He just walked away like that.
I froze somebody.
Nice.
The freezing worked.
That's good that I didn't get ulted too.
That was, like, the perfect time for me to not get ulted.
Because I saved the game with that.
The only bad thing is that my...
Because there's three of us.
Support ult.
Support ult's gonna take fucking forever to build.
Because we're all trying to build ult.
Please, I really need ult.
Please, I'm the most important.
I have a defensive ult.
None of you have defensive ult.
All your ults are aggressive.
Oh my god.
He's dead.
Oh, I don't have... I can't get it in time.
Frozen guy.
Oh, but she's dancing.
All she does is dance.
Please, I have to...
I can't.
I have to reload my hands.
My hands are reloading.
Jesus, fuck.
This fight is forever.
Oh my god, they're...
Please, she's one HP.
Good stuff.
Good job.
Okay, nice, we got her.
We have to heal.
Oh, I have it.
I have ult now.
They're gonna have Dr. Stringjolt, so I'm gonna have to be very far away from them.
I can feel it.
Oh, that's ours.
That's ours.
I was like... I didn't even realize.
That's okay!
Because I can predict all...
Because I came from Overwatch, baby!
I know how to count ult charge!
That's fucking right!
Oh, shit.
Oh, this is bad now.
That's actually right, I came from Overwatch, so I'm...
Oh, this is very bad now.
Oh, my god.
This is a lot of damage.
Good luck.
Good luck, Magneto.
That is a lot of damage.
Good fucking luck.
Jesus Christ.
Oh.
I think Magneto might die here.
I am!
That's way too much.
No!
I could've killed her!
Oh, shit.
Let's go, let's go, let's go!
I have to be in here.
Oh, I had to get on!
Guys, get on the point!
Oh, my god, okay.
Why am I the one getting on point?
Guys, just stay on point, guys.
Just stay on point.
Oh, they got off.
No, he doesn't.
He doesn't.
Oh,
my god.
That was a crazy game.
That was such a crazy game.
Oh, that was way too close for comfort.
It was.
How did we...
All my friends kept telling me that...
Like, all my DPS friends kept telling me, like...
Oh, my god, everybody keeps picking DPS.
How come when I queue, everybody keeps picking support?
Like...
Like, where are my DPS players?
I don't understand!
Everyone tells, like...
My DPS friends, they're like...
You have to fill out support because everybody wants to play DPS.
And I'm like...
Everybody wants to play support in my lobbies!
We don't get DPS players!
I'm just lucky enough that ShortForce is a DPS player.
Yay!
TP left.
Alright, TP.
Alright.
Oh, we're gonna do that thing.
Oh, my god, we're doing it.
He's fucking figuring out.
He's thinking with portals.
Oh, my god!
That's crazy.
I'm just gonna stay here.
Where's Magneto?
Is he okay?
Down there?
Is he okay down there?
That's, like, fucking freaking me out.
I thought I was lagging.
Guys, get on the point.
Nice.
We basically did what they did.
You're awake now.
Wake up.
Nice.
That was smart.
Oh, my god.
People are learning the game.
People are actually learning the game, but they don't know yet.
They don't know yet what to actually do.
They're learning, but they don't know what's ideal.
Because this reminds me of Volskaya.
You know, where the DPS, where people would be over there?
It reminds me of Volskaya.
Okay.
And we have three supports, so one of them can push up.
Nice.
Alright.
I'm gonna do this.
I missed.
It was a nice gamble.
Sometimes it hits and sometimes it doesn't.
Let's go gambling.
It's all about that gambling life.
Oh, my god.
Okay, that's a lot of...
Guys, how did you guys get ult already?
Wait a minute.
Wait, how did you guys get ult?
I'm still here trying to figure this shit out.
Oh, no.
Guys, I'm so close.
I got it.
Let's go.
It's time.
We're putting on a show.
That's fucking right.
It might have taken me forever to get...
Oh, I can't jump up because I'm too busy dancing.
Guys, don't you hate it when you're dancing so much that you can't jump?
It's not fair.
How did they get support ult so fucking fast?
I'm out here trying fucking...
I'm fucking begging for support ult right now.
Please, somebody get damage so I can heal.
Oh.
Goodbye.
He hit the bridge!
Oh, my god.
He hit the fucking bridge.
I wasn't paying attention.
Oh, my god.
It's so funny.
It's so funny so I didn't pay attention.
I wasn't...
I wasn't paying attention.
Oh, you're gonna live.
You're gonna live, Strange.
You're gonna fucking live.
It was funny though.
It was so funny.
Okay.
Bro, I'm 60%!
Bro, I'm 60% ult charge!
This is not fair!
Okay, I'm 80% now.
Wait, is he ulting?
Wait, oh, no.
Oh, no.
Okay.
I'm okay.
He's one.
Yes!
We got him!
Guys, you know what that means, guys.
You know what that means.
Oh, shit.
They're ready to put on a show!
Oh!
It's time.
The battlecry.
Everybody just shooting the fucking drum.
Oh, my god.
The drum.
I don't think that was a solo right there.
Oh, my god.
How close am I?
I don't know!
Is it 80?
It's 80, right?
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh, it's getting close.
No!
I might have to beat Diamond soon to be in it.
I need to get there faster!
They're climbing so fast!
Oh, we're sure for it.
I can't even...
He's definitely...
Oh, my god.
They're climbing so fast that like...
I might even have to beat Diamond.
Everybody, stop playing!
Everybody and Diamond!
Stop playing!
Right now!
I need to use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready!
I owe you one for rescuing me from Hydra, Clint.
We do make a pretty good team.
Kate's not returning my calls, so...
What do you say?
Wanna be my new partner?
I said I owe you one.
Eh, I'll take what I can get.
The battle starts in 5...
4...
3...
2...
1!
Back!
I'm back.
Alright, here we go.
Come on!
I wish I know...
What the fuck?!
I wish I know like who's talking sometimes.
It's so annoying because I don't know.
Guys...
Guys, I cannot keep track of you guys.
Guys, you guys...
You guys are LOSing the healers, guys.
Yeah,
I think porting would've been the first thing you do.
We're gonna port.
Alright, here we go.
Guys...
Hey guys...
Alright, here we go.
Fucking hell, oh my god, that poor guy.
He's so low!
Oh my god.
Please, he's so low!
I'm ready to put on a show!
No, they're also putting a show!
Okay.
Alright.
And I am ready to fucking leave.
Oh my god, really?!
No...
I feared.
There's two shows?!
That's illegal!
Was she trying to fucking take the attention away from me?
Fucking whore.
How dare she.
Alright, I need to go.
Okay, goodbye.
Jeez.
How dare she steal my spotlight.
What a bitch.
I'm gonna put on the other tank because...
Oh my god, I had a feeling.
Oh, that was insane!
Oh my god, that ult was crazy!
The Overwatch player was...
Bro, the Groot!
Did you guys see the wall from...
Can she say that?
Guys, it's okay, I came from Overwatch.
That was a crazy play from the Groot.
Honestly.
Oh my god.
Oh...
Okay.
I'm running out of health.
I'm gonna save my ult.
Goodbye.
Keep walking with me, bro.
It's kind of nice.
I can kill them all.
Whee!
Okay.
That was good.
That was my bad.
I was too forward.
Our Hanzo is really good.
Our Hawkeye.
Sorry, surefour, you're not getting orbs.
I can kill them.
Don't kill that!
Bro.
Bro, I'm sorry, man.
I cannot kill that, bro.
That shit.
That shit is a little too much.
That shit was definitely a little too much, guys.
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my god, they're dancing.
They're dancing, Dr. Strange.
What do we do?
They're dancing.
Holy fuck.
Okay.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
No!
We got ulted.
There's nothing we can do.
That's okay.
Surefour started punching!
Okay, we're fine.
He just started punching.
Help me, help me.
Please, please, please.
I'm fucking...
We're giving you so much heals!
Oh my god!
Everything...
I'm just healing.
I've never stopped healing you.
Oh shit.
We never stopped healing!
Oh my god, please.
Guys.
Guys, you're scaring me.
Guys!
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god, he's grooting.
He's grooting again.
Get over...
No!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he's living!
Bro, he's living!
Bro, just live!
Oh my god, Doran's the item of...
The item, whatever.
Oh, he's putting a show again.
I wish you could just...
What?
Where are you?
No!
What the fuck?
The current score is 2-2.
Sorry, 4-4.
We just gotta...
We just gotta protect our Hanzo.
I'm killing everybody except the Psylocke.
They insta-locked?
Who are you, you fucker?
You fucker!
I can't believe they insta-locked her.
I can't believe it.
I gotta avoid them now.
No, there's no reason to play Jeff.
I gotta avoid this Luna player.
How dare you?
How fucking dare you, you fucker!
What the fuck?
That's right, get out of my lobby!
Alright, I don't know how to play Mantis, so we're gonna lose.
He's gonna learn today.
He's gonna learn today that I'm a one-trick.
How dare they also...
Peter can only be one Luna, one-trick.
And it's me!
What the fuck?
Oh my god!
That shit's crazy.
He's gonna learn that I don't know how to play this character.
I...
Alright, go!
Go do your thing!
Go feel... Oh my god!
I... I healed you so much, like, I don't know what you want me to do.
Go feel inspired right now!
I don't know her projectiles.
And that's my issue too.
I don't know her projectile speed.
So I can't...
Be inspired!
Yeah, like, what the fuck is her projectile?
That's right.
Be inspired!
Still be inspired!
Keep being inspired!
Go do your thing!
Inspire!
Oh, what the fuck is her projectile speed?
Go do your thing!
Feel so strong!
Feel... Oh my god.
Um...
Good luck.
Let's go.
Go do your thing.
Oh my god, that's fine.
It was not gonna work.
I wanted to swap off anyway.
Uh... I don't know.
I could do... Let's do Cloak and Dagger.
Let's play Mystery Hero.
Oh my god.
Fuck it.
Okay,
that's fine.
Get healed!
Nice!
I don't know when I'll ever use Cloak, but I'll just heal.
We'll be like... just Dagger.
We'll just be Dagger.
I don't know how to use the other heroes.
Just Dagger.
But just Dagger, please.
Oh shit.
Oh,
we're gonna push in?
Oh, nevermind.
We're not gonna lose this game, are we?
Yeah, we're not gonna lose this game, right guys?
Right guys?
With two Luna one-tricks, we're not gonna lose that game, right?
Surely we're not.
Is that gonna ult us?
There we go.
Oh my god, they're all putting the show again.
No!
Put on a show, Luna!
No, she doesn't have the show!
If only we can be two Lunas, guys.
How do I fucking run?
Oh, okay.
That's how I leave.
Oh, I should have Cloaked there.
I think if I Cloaked, it would have been fine.
Okay.
I think it's because, guys, I think we might lose because we have two Lunas.
It's just a maybe.
I don't know.
It could be it.
Honestly.
Okay.
I don't know why I went there.
Oh my god, please.
I'm trying my best to keep up.
Jesus Christ!
Oh my god!
I kept Doctor Strange up for so long!
I swear to god, if I check the stats and I still have more healing than this person, I swear to fucking god.
Sorry, I don't know how to play.
Guys, can you tell I don't know what I'm doing on this character?
No!
He saw me!
I didn't think he'd turn around!
Alright.
I hope they avoid me, so I'll avoid them just in case.
Just in case.
Guys, I don't know how to play the dagger and cloak.
Wait, who is- which one?
No, cloak.
I don't know how to play the cloak and dagger.
Yeah, that's what I meant.
Okay.
Give me a chance.
Come on.
I can't- I can't avoid them yet.
Okay.
There we go.
There can only be one.
And I'm gonna avoid you just in case you're also a- just in case you're also a Luna player, I'm gonna- Just in case.
I can't.
I can't also.
I gotta get them.
I don't know how many- I don't know how many, like, uh, uh, avoid slots you get.
But I'm making sure- I got- I'm trying to, like, get all my priorities straight.
Oh my god.
Games are definitely harder because he's in diamond now.
There can only be one.
I mean, I learned the Luna par- I learned the dagger part a little bit.
I just don't know how to do cloak yet.
I get so confused on cloak.
I just don't know how to play cloak at the moment.
Okay, let's see.
Yeah!
There's no other support player!
Let's go!
Oh.
Alright, here we go.
Yeah!
Okay.
Wait, what?
Okay, we're- there we go.
Oh my god, thank god.
Top 500 in two days?
It's possible!
I literally need to- we just need to win, like, two- three games, I think.
Three games, and then we'll be top 500.
Just three games.
Come on!
Just three games!
If I avoid all the other Lunas, it'll work!
I hate this map.
Honestly, like, um...
This is, like- I think this is, like, my most hated map.
Only because I've been fucking playing this map for 20 years.
Like, I've been playing this map for so long.
It's always this map for some fucking reason.
Do you think our Thor's gonna die?
Oh, there he is.
Yeah, I called it.
There he is.
Dead.
Holy shit.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
I realize that we can't push at all.
I can't even get there.
Okay.
Oh my god, what the fuck do we do with this guy?
Of all the characters you can grapple!
Fuck you, why him?
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, he shielded.
Oh.
How?!
My guys barely took- Okay, to be fair, they have two teams.
Okay, come on.
They actually have two teams, that's how.
I was like, how the fuck do you farm that shit?
I just feel bad for our...
Please.
We gotta kill.
Oh, this is a really good Hawkeye.
Second take or I'm burning!
Spiderman!
That's crazy!
Oh my god!
Bro, that's like wild!
He's gonna hold us hostage!
Everyone, he's gonna hold us hostage!
What do we do?
No!
Bro, he's gonna- He's gonna do it!
Bro, he's not fucking around!
He's gonna actually do it!
Learning sp- Oh my god!
No!
Why?!
How are my games that unlucky?
Oh my god.
Guys, he's learning Spiderman.
Guys, in Diamond.
This is actually the craziest part.
Bro, how did my games get that unlucky?
Guys,
it's okay.
We can out-DPS all of this.
You lost your point.
It's okay.
We can out-DPS all of this still.
We can out-kill this, maybe.
Alright.
Okay.
I leave now.
Now we have too many DPS players.
We actually have too many DPS players now.
Oh my god.
Guys, guys.
Guys, five seconds left.
Guys.
Oh hey, I cancelled it.
I'm furious.
Oh my god.
Thanks, DPS.
Question mark?
Oh my god.
How is this a DPS problem?
Holy shit, this guy.
I can't believe this guy said that.
Oh my god.
I can't believe he said that.
Of course the DPS said that.
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
Oh my god.
This is high ELO but very egotistical DPS players.
Welcome.
Is there already top 500?
There already top 500 so they don't care as much.
Cause they know they can get it but I didn't get to be top 500 yet.
What?
Our guy literally said Spiderman.
Tink or I'm wearing Spiderman.
Wait, now we get another Tink?
Like, what?
This is fucked up.
Why do we get another Tink now?
This is actually fucked up.
Like, we have plenty of other times to...
We had plenty of other times.
Now we get another Tink.
Oh my god.
Feels just like Overwatch.
Holy shit.
Oh, it's me.
Wait, no.
That's not me.
I thought it was me cause it looked like...
Oh no.
No.
Second game in a row they threw?
Who?
These two?
I'm playing... Who?
Bro, what?
Bro, he didn't swap to Tink.
Like, what do you mean?
What do you mean?
He didn't swap to Tink.
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
I don't believe the other guy.
Alright, here we go.
It's time to lock in.
Oh my god.
Please, I need like four wins.
Why?
When I get to plat?
Oh my god.
Why is this so hard now?
It was smooth sailing before.
Please.
I just...
The battle starts in 5, 4, 3, 2, 1!
Alright, here we go.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Yeah, Top Island is still plat 1.
So this is the future.
Or one future, anyway.
Oh my god.
This is so difficult now.
I'm literally so close though.
Okay, at least we have one Tink.
Like, I'm happy with one Tink.
Oh my god, please.
Where is our Tink though?
Where did he go?
No, not the Tink.
Oh my god, I swear I'm playing like a puzzle.
I have to do like a fucking puzzle.
Oh my god, please.
I'm sorry!
I have to look so...
There's so many fucking walls!
Oh my god!
It's just all walls!
It's just walls!
How?!
Get him!
Get the support!
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, I'm gonna use this now.
Bro, nobody's dying!
Oh no, I'm stuck.
No, now she's gonna put on a show and now we're never gonna leave.
Oh my god.
We never got the point back.
That's actually crazy that people put Overwatch in their name.
Like, I think Overwatch is literally the only game that does that.
Like their entire identity is just Overwatch no matter what game they're in.
They put like, something something Overwatch.
And I think that's a little cringe, I'm sorry.
No other game does that.
It's literally just Overwatch.
Please, she's one!
Oh my god.
But that's the thing, that's what I'm saying.
Literally like, it's always Overwatch.
I've never seen any other game that does that.
There's a flanker somewhere.
Alright, let's...
Alright.
What?!
They hate us.
They hate us so much.
No.
No!
Why are the games harder?!
We're so close!
I want to tell people they're from Overwatch.
That makes me like, but why?
Why though?
But like, I'm sorry for anyone whose name is something something Overwatch.
But it's time to change your name.
It's been like, six years.
It's been six years, it's time to move on guys.
Yeah, but I didn't do like, Overwatch name.
I never did that.
I never...
I've never like, had that.
It's been six plus years, move on.
How do I put my... how do I emote?
Oh shit, sorry.
I didn't mean to emote now.
Okay, lock in.
We gotta lock in.
I can't keep playing this game.
I have actually... I didn't think it'd take this long.
I legitimately didn't think that it'd take this long.
I'm locked in guys.
I'm super focused, it's time for real.
Are you ser... still?!
Oh yeah?!
Cause I am too!
That's fucking right, kill them.
Fucking kill them.
This is my show now.
It's time to kill.
Alright.
Heal, heal, heal, heal.
You can tell that I'm tired.
I'm getting tired now.
I didn't think it would take this long, that's the thing.
I didn't think... I didn't think we'd still be here.
Where did he go?
Where did Dr. Strange go?
But you're still alive, Mr. Strange?
My game is still alive.
Gamersups is wearing off guys, it's not good.
Oh no.
Where did he go?
Oh there you are.
It's good that I didn't finish my gamersups, I gotta drink some more.
No, how are you still putting shows on?
How?
How are you still putting on your stupid fucking show?!
Fucking bitch, this is my show!
I'm streaming!
Okay.
Bye.
By the way, remember to use code DokiBird for 10% off your gamersups order.
I'm like, tweaking right now.
I'm sorry for people who have motion sickness.
I'm actually so locked in.
This is so good, that's insane!
That's an insane ult!
Oh my god!
That was an insane ult!
Holy shit!
What the fuck?!
That ult was crazy!
That was a crazy ult!
I told you I'm locked in.
Guys, I'm so locked in.
I didn't think this was going to be a very long stream.
I'm not going to lie.
I legitimately did not think this was going to be a long stream.
I thought we were going to make it.
I think if one of our games was not fucking thrown, we would have won it.
Oh, that's funny.
Say hi.
I didn't know that.
Hello.
Get out of here.
Can I freeze her?
Oh, she was distracted.
Alright, let's see.
Okay, lock in.
Lock in, Doki.
Lock in.
If you win this, you just need three wins.
You just need three wins if you win this one.
That's not too difficult.
Lock in.
Yes,
I'm ready to put on a show.
That's fucking right.
I'm dancing.
I'm leaving.
Dancing over now.
Dancing very over.
Whoa.
What?
I didn't see this kill cam.
Was he even aiming for me?
Jesus Christ.
Okay, yeah, he was.
Okay, you deserve that kill.
Oh my god, you deserve that.
You actually deserve that.
That was a really good shot.
That was a really, really good shot by him.
His aim was actually top 500 right there.
I actually hit somebody.
Nice.
Oh shit, let's go.
Fucking party.
No, hella mains are definitely really scary.
No, I agree.
I think they have Luna ult.
For sure.
Wait, how the fuck did he die?
I'm trying not to...
Uh...
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
That was insane.
No.
Oh my god, he's learning Spiderman.
Wait.
Okay, nevermind.
I was gonna be like, oh my god, he's gonna learn Spiderman too?
That was a really good ult by...
Moon Knight.
I have ult soon too.
Because we're gonna start putting a show!
Guys, I'm fucking leaving.
Good luck.
Good fucking luck.
Be nice.
Dr. Strange is here?
Yeah!
Oh my god, three more wins.
Please.
Please, they're so there.
I just need three more.
Oh my god.
I just need three more wins.
Moon Knight.
Fucking life.
What?
Oh my god, surely I win three in a row, right?
Surely, I win three in a row, right?
Surely, right?
Right?
We can do this, right guys?
No!
Okay.
Oh my god, it's over.
It's the same team.
Okay.
Paladin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But less than 14 spots in the top 500.
Tier 1.
The rest are tier 2 and above.
It keeps going up every 10 minutes.
It's okay.
It's tier 2 or 3.
Three wins.
We can get this in three wins, guys.
Oh my god, it's possible.
Greg, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you for the super chat.
Just started watching you recently...
and really enjoyed your content.
It's all amazing.
Keep being great.
Much love from down under, Australia.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
I can't believe I streamed so long that people in Australia are watching now.
That's how late I stream.
Gonna do this.
I need that spot.
I need that spot and then I can relax.
Because now the goal is just to end top 500 after that.
Then I don't need to try as hard.
Because I just need to end at that point.
Because I just want to get it on stream.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Guys.
Guys, we're friends.
We're all friends.
How the fuck did we live?
What the fuck?
Oh my god, we're in what?
I don't know how that hat worked.
Same map, same team, awesome.
How the fuck did we win that?
How am I alive?
I should not be alive right now.
I legitimately should not be alive.
After everything I went through.
Guys, I'm on point.
Oh my god, that was okay.
Alright, but come on.
Was that not crazy?
Come on, was that not a crazy play I just did right there?
I'm so used to flankers now.
I swear to god.
All I do is get flanked these days.
That is just reflex now.
That's fucking right.
Whoops.
Don't worry, you are not okay.
You are definitely not okay.
Gather the Lucio!
That's fine.
Because then after this, we do this.
Because it's my turn to put on a show.
Because I know it's ending soon.
That's fucking right.
Alright.
My show first.
There we go.
After this is two more wins.
After this is two more wins, guys.
Can I heal from this?
Right here.
1 HP!
Nice.
Oh my god.
After this is two more wins.
C'mon, c'mon, c'mon.
C'mon!
C'mon.
Fucking footsteps.
It's like they forgot.
People make footsteps.
Hope we get to farm this team again.
Oh, I already had dinner.
Technically...
Okay, to be fair.
Technically, I had lunch dinner.
I ate like one meal today.
But it was a really big meal.
I made myself pasta!
I actually put too many spaghetti in there.
Because you know when you boil spaghetti, you don't know how much it actually is until it's done.
I picked it up and I was like, that seems enough.
And it was a lot of pasta.
I ate all of it.
So like, I'm not hungry at all.
Because I ate way too much.
And I ate at like 4pm.
Because I cooked at 4pm.
Because I had to do work stuff.
Um...
Oh shit, okay.
It's time.
What if I just messaged surefour and be like, haha, two more...
Two more wins to top 500.
Haha.
You think he'll like, he'll like make sure he won't troll the last two games?
For me, like...
Or, if me saying that is gonna make him troll.
Like, that's the thing.
I don't know if I should say it or not.
Yeah, I'm just like, if I say it, do you think he'll start throwing?
HOLY SHIT!
BLEEEEHHHHHH!
HAHAHA!
OH MY GOD!
HOLY SHIT!
Okay, but like, I got at least like, you know.
I got the black panther!
HAHAHA!
Okay.
I got the black panther though.
At least.
That shit scared the holy fucks.
I was not expecting that.
I was like, what the fuck is...
That shit's skittish.
That was actually crazy.
Okay.
Oh nice, we got two!
We got Collat.
Okay.
The point of the thing is literally... I saw him, he was about to... it was like watching...
Uh, like seeing like a fucking, uh, uh...
Like a fucking FNAF jump scare right there.
That was, uh...
That scared... that scared me so much.
I was not ready for it.
It was like foxy jump scare right there.
That's what I was thinking, yeah.
Jesus Christ, he did not.
Okay, nice.
Well, he's retired.
He hasn't been a pro.
He's also 30, so he hasn't... sorry.
But you guys all know about like shelf life of pro players.
Pro players tend to retire very early.
That's crazy.
But he's also 30.
You can still be pro at 30, I think.
It's usually a lot of pros tend to like retire before, like when around that age.
Because like it's all like people are like, oh faster reflexes and stuff.
I know you're like, oh, but Shroud came back as a pro.
Yeah, but it was more so of like, I feel like it was more of an image.
Like, uh, what's the word called?
Like a publicity thing type deal.
When and usually like people who are around that age do better as content creators.
Then you make more as a content creator than you do as a pro.
It's like because a lot of them tend to go towards, uh, go towards, uh, content creation around that time.
And then you make more.
Pro playing is more about being competitive and just like, unless you play League.
Unless you're like the best team in League because like...
But other than that, other than that, it's just you just make more.
There's no reason to go back to pro.
Guys, stop.
Stop.
Don't count the spots.
I just want to be like, surprised.
You know, just be like, yay.
Let me use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
Fiona They'll be coming in 30 seconds stay strong
We're gonna need your sharpshooting Clint good.
I didn't bring anything else
Fucking I'm skating.
I'm skating.
Oh, I'm skating so fast.
The battle starts in five.
I'm skating three two One team wait up You need to stop that team
There you go, I finished skating Oh, that was a good freeze by me good job Doki
That's right, I gotta compliment myself, you know Good job Doki you you did that Remember what you did there.
Jesus Christ Oh, he was so low too No
Oh Okay, please I need to get over here Can you reload I gotta reload my hands
Jesus Christ, please keep backing up.
I can't get to you Hey You already got all okay to be fair they are bunched up together.
Okay.
I got all two Okay, oh I got you
Nice oh my god.
Oh
Okay, we're just gonna dance here this is where we're dancing Why are you running away?
I'm so confused
Here's something I was so confused because he kept running
Okay, yeah i'm not i'm not doing that
Okay, okay our captain america's a little um Um, yeah
All right, our captain america needs help
Let's stay here I don't want my shadow
That was oh my god
I don't deserve this
What is that sound?
You guys hear that?
Okay,
I can save the captain.
Holy shit.
Okay, this captain... I don't know.
What the fuck?
I am strengthened.
No, I have to reload my hands!
I'm sorry!
My hands couldn't be reloaded in time!
Let's go.
Let's fight this area.
We just stall.
We just keep stalling.
We just gotta stall.
Goodbye.
And of course, fuck me!
In the corner.
Wait, what?
I didn't realize I was rezzed.
I didn't realize I got rezzed there.
I got revived!
I got rezzed!
I couldn't... I didn't know!
I was like, what?
Am I alive?
I forgot about Rocky Raccoon's rez.
I think our... I just think our Captain America is not that great.
I think he's a little of a troll pick.
Unless like...
No, I missed!
I missed!
No!
Oh my god, Rocket, please keep them up!
Why is it always me?
I don't understand!
Just get away from me!
Oh yeah, definitely dead.
No, he's... yeah, he's definitely dead.
Oh please, I can't heal you up there.
Oh my god, he didn't like... oh, he's dead.
He's dead.
He unleashed it though.
He did the thing though.
He's reloading hands.
Oh, that's two people that got rezzed.
No!
Do I have ult?
I do, I do.
Okay, we have final fight and we have ult.
I am...
We gotta fight this.
We have to fight this.
Guys, just kill him.
Just kill him.
That's... just kill...
No!
I'm sorry.
I'm trying.
I'm trying to keep you up, bro.
I can't.
I can't keep you up, bro.
Alright, we're up there.
No!
Fucking slow-mo with the Magneto.
Oh my god.
No.
I wanted two more.
Oh my god.
I just needed two more.
I just think it's... I think it's Captain America.
I honestly legitimately think...
Captain America is not the right pick for our tank.
Maybe he's like the best fucking Captain America on our team.
Like, ever.
But I just don't think he's the right pick against that comp.
He's playing for Captain America in this elo?
Does he use the fucking Captain America one-trick?
Like, I barely ever see Captain America in general.
Yeah.
Yeah, I heard he's like one of the... He's like a D-tier tank.
But at least... Hey, I might be a one-trick, but I'm an A-tier one-trick, guys.
My support is A-tier.
So like, she's not S-tier because that's Mantis.
But...
But she's A-tier.
And that's good enough.
Oh.
At least it's not D-tier.
You're fine.
Stop complaining.
Oh my god.
This elo.
Oh,
nice.
Oh, I thought they'd be closer.
Please, please heal me.
Thank you.
Oh, guys, guys.
I can't heal you guys up there.
Guys.
I can't heal you guys up there, guys.
I need you guys to know that when you're...
When you're on high ground.
Oh my god.
I have Iron Man?
Guys, I have to look up.
This is... I'm fucking giving him the thing.
I don't want to look up.
I'm tired.
I'm tired of looking up, so I'm giving this to him so I never have to look up again.
Fuck this.
I'm using it.
I should use it when I get a pick.
This is it.
Oh.
Attack!
How?
Okay.
It's okay.
We pushed it up.
Alright, I'm backing out now.
Alright.
That's a scary ult right there.
Oh.
I think it's like DPS tanked it.
I'm not gonna lie.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I legit didn't think... It's just a Captain America.
This is just not the right tank.
I fucking... Oh my god.
I could hear the footsteps too.
I heard the fucking footsteps!
I like looked up!
Yeah, okay.
Two more games.
Two.
We lose this.
Two more games.
No, three more games.
Three more games.
So close.
So close!
What the fuck?
Okay.
Guys.
Guys, I don't think this is it.
At best, I can stay here and beat up all his cover down.
Fuck your covers!
That's right!
No covers!
Oh shit!
Sorry bro.
You got headshot.
Oh my god!
Guys.
Gather around, guys.
Guys, gather around, guys.
Guys, it's time.
I'm putting on a show, guys.
Guys, gather around, guys.
Guys, if you want heals, you gotta stay on the point because that's the only way you're gonna...
Oh my god.
Oh yes!
No, there's no hope.
There's no hope.
There was no hope in that game.
That game was a full team dip right there.
Oh my god.
I'm just gonna... I don't know if he's avoiding...
I don't know if he's avoiding...
Oh my god.
I'm gonna avoid him.
I just don't think Captain America is the pick here.
What is his profile anyway?
Oh, I can't... I'm avoiding just because I don't think Captain America was the pick.
And now avoiding him because he was DPS too.
Oh.
No.
I need to avoid him because, okay, we gotta...
We gotta fix our settings.
Oh, is he GG's?
Okay, GG's, man.
Alright, thanks for games.
Alright, here we go.
Oh my god.
Okay, we can do this.
We can fucking do this.
Okay, I gotta adjust my avoids.
I gotta... I gotta...
Wait, how do I adjust my avoids though?
Alright.
How do I leave?
Oh, leave.
Alright.
We just need three games.
Three games.
Three fucking games.
Oh my god.
Come on.
We might be lucky.
We can be lucky.
I believe in us.
We'll be lucky.
There's no way.
There's no... We can be lucky.
I believe in us.
Come on.
We can be lucky.
There's no way.
There's... Wait, is this the Necros?
Wait, how is... Why is he in this elo?
Does he make another count?
There's no way.
That can't be him.
He's literally top 50.
There's no way.
He's top 50 right now.
What?
Isn't he top 50?
Oh shit, he's... Wait, is he on an ult count?
Oh my god, it is him.
Wait, is he on an ult count?
Alright Necros, you get this.
You get this.
You get this, Necros.
Yeah, he's a...
He's the Genji main and who's the...
434?
Wait, he's not?
Wait, what's his win rate?
Wait a minute.
He's been playing this game for a long time.
What's his win rate?
I'm a little...
I'm a little worried because he's been here for a while now.
Bro, you're taking so much damage, man.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's when he started?
Okay.
Okay, that's not bad.
That's not bad.
Okay, I got a little worried because you guys were like...
You guys were like, he's ranked 43, 434 and I was like, there's no way.
Or maybe he started late.
Because I thought he would be diving already, you know?
Because he's been playing for a while.
That's why I wasn't expecting it.
See, I told you guys.
It's all about the gotcha.
Oh, that was not what I wanted.
Nice.
Let's go!
Let's fucking go in!
Go in!
Oh my god, don't go in.
Don't go in.
Holy shit!
Nevermind.
He instant died.
Do not go in there.
I did not expect him to instant die, you know?
Oh, I missed a... I missed a...
Oh my god.
Sorry.
Can you reload my hands?
I'm so sorry.
Oh no, not again.
Oh no.
No!
They can win this.
They don't need healers.
I'm coming back.
No!
Okay.
Everything is fine.
See?
It's all about the gotcha!
Oh my god.
Bro, I'm gonna play against them.
They'll take back the elo they gave me.
I can feel it.
I'm gonna queue up and they'll take back the elo.
Knowing my luck.
Alright.
How many more games?
Three games.
If I win three in a row, I get diamond.
And then that secures top 500.
Because I don't think there's plat spots left.
I don't think there's plat spots.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
We're so close.
Whee!
I don't think there's plat 1 spots left, guys.
I think it's just diamond 3.
There's no more plats at top 500.
I gotta be a diamond player.
Okay.
What the fuck is he doing?
Jesus Christ.
Keep fighting!
Keep punching, Hulk!
Oh my god, I have to do this!
Okay, nice.
We're fine.
Okay.
Oh my god, I'm trying so hard right now.
I'm actually so focused.
I need to get out of this.
I need this.
I need this so badly.
No, Hulk!
We'll keep you alive!
Build your ult charge back!
You're gonna live, you skinny boy!
You're gonna live!
He's alive.
Oh my god, no.
He actually lived.
We put all our resources on him.
Oh my god.
He actually lived.
It's okay.
He fucking lived to tell the tale.
Okay, guys, I don't know about this though.
Alright,
I'll just stay here.
Guys.
Whoa.
Guys, we're a little... Guys.
Guys!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, Hulk.
Hulk, you fucking... You madman!
You madman!
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Guys.
Oh, shit.
They made a portal.
Wait, they actually made a portal.
Holy fuck.
They made a portal to get away from us.
No, they literally made a portal to get away from us.
That's actually crazy.
That's so funny.
I'm like 1 HP.
How do I live this long?
Oh!
Shit!
Holy...
That's crazy.
That was...
What I saw from the Hulk was...
I don't know.
I don't know how I'm alive, chat.
Guys, I'm ready to, like, lose this by facing Necros.
I'm so ready.
I'm so fucking ready.
Alright.
Two more.
Two fucking more, guys.
Two fucking more.
Here we go.
Alright, let's see if we fight Necros.
Yeah!
Get two more and then I'll be diamond.
Oh my god!
Okay, it's literally RNG.
I'm trying to RNG this right now.
Okay.
I like how her name's Emma Frost.
Oh my god.
I'm fucking trying to RNG this so badly.
Alright.
No, it's a... No, he's dueled with the Bruce Banner.
Skinny boy is back.
Oh my god.
Look, wouldn't it be funny if we lose?
And he did take away the ELO he gave me.
That would be so funny, guys.
That would be so fucking funny.
Don't say that!
Alright, don't jinx it.
Shh.
I'm so tired.
I'm fucking delusional now.
Okay.
I've been playing ranked for so long.
Oh no, that Hanzo's scary though.
I remember that Hanzo.
He's actually really, really good.
I only lost with him because my team was mad.
My team was actually griefing.
There's a team where he was like, if you don't play...
If you don't play second tank, I'm gonna play... I'm gonna learn Spider-Man.
Oh no.
Little... No!
Oh no, I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Okay.
Guys, can we touch?
No, that's cool.
That's cool.
That's okay.
We don't need a touch.
Sorry.
Hot guy.
I just think of... Oh, he's not on Spider-Man.
Oh no.
It's okay.
It's fine.
He doesn't need to be on Spider-Man.
He doesn't need to be on... Guys.
Oh my god, again!
Oh, this is where I'm a little scared.
Wait, did he... Oh.
Okay.
Okay, I have ult, guys.
I can ult in there.
Oh shit, guys.
We're... Whoa, guys.
We're fine.
We're so healthy.
Oh, we are so healthy.
Hulk, no!
No, Hulk!
I cannot heal him!
I'm sorry!
Get back in the fight, Hulk!
Jesus Christ.
Okay, we're so healthy.
We're so healthy.
We're...
I'm gonna clap because of how healthy we are.
I'm gonna start clapping because I feel so fucking healthy right now.
We're gonna clap so hard because I feel so fucking healthy.
Oh no, Hulk.
Goodbye, little boy.
I feel so healthy.
I have... I'm so close to ult.
I have to do this.
What?
Oh no.
No, Giddo.
No!
Okay.
Oh no.
Guys, he gaveth and he taketh.
He gaveth and he taketh, you guys.
Guys, I don't know anymore.
Okay.
We'll be fine.
We will not be fine.
That is scary.
We'll be fine.
We'll be so fine.
Did you watch?
Guys, did you watch?
I think, like, something happened.
Okay, that's cool.
Okay, now we have damage.
Alright, now they ult.
Okay.
Alright.
Ah, but... I don't... Oh, fuck.
I wasn't on heals.
I'm sorry.
Oops.
I don't know why I default DPS, but that was awkward.
That...
I think I'll do auto DPS.
What?
How?
How is it auto damage?
That would
be...
I don't know how that happened.
It actually auto damage.
I pressed Q and then it went to damage.
It, like, double tap damage when I pressed Q.
Whoops.
That was my bad.
It's Jeff time.
I didn't know.
I didn't know how.
How that happened.
Okay.
I did one bad thing that entire game.
Guys, just one bad thing.
It cannot be fully all my fault.
That's literally one bad game.
One fucking misclick.
I did so much in the rest of that game.
And then I did one bad move.
Yeah, I only killed my whole team once.
Guys, how can that be my fault?
We landed that far.
Also, I'm avoiding Wacky for fucking being a Luna main.
Just a little oopsie.
It's not my fault.
It's just one little oopsie.
I think we have three support players.
Legitimately.
Because the MF4 Frost wanted to play Luna too.
I hate this group.
Oh no, I have to reload my hands.
I have to reload my mouth.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Okay.
Oh my god, please.
Live!
I can't keep healing forever!
You guys do so much damage!
Fuck this.
Oh my god, Ashley, fuck this.
Fuck off.
Oh no.
Reloading mouth.
Throwing bubbles out.
Throwing more bubbles out.
Alright.
Throwing more bubbles out!
I feel like I hear something near me.
Wait, is that guy lagging?
Like what the fuck is going on with him?
You guys see that?
Guys, I'm a little worried here.
I'm a little...
Woah!
Yeah, I had a feeling that we were not gonna live there.
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
I think this person does not know how to play Penny.
Bro, bro!
You gotta stop!
You gotta stop doing that!
Stop peeking!
Bro, I'm healing as best as I can.
No, I legitimately don't think this person plays Tank.
This person definitely doesn't play Tank at all.
That's basically it.
Like, he does his all.
He just gets fucking...
Like, is he okay?
Hello.
That's the thing, right?
No supports!
No supports for you!
That's fucking right.
RUN!
Fucking run, bitch!
Guys, I can play other things, guys.
See?
I... what?
How?
Oh, shit!
What the fuck?
Bro, I have to do a 1v1 against fucking Hawkeye!
Not in one trick!
Bro, I literally just did a 1v1 against a fucking Hawkeye!
That's impressive!
Who is she?
Alright, I heal myself.
Oh my god!
Jesus Christ, I gotta heal myself sometimes.
Let me out of here!
Let me fucking out of here!
Jesus Christ.
Bro!
What do you want me to do?!
Oh my god, 57% accuracy?
I'll take that.
As I told you, he giveth, then you taketh.
He giveth, then you taketh.
I still don't know what that fucking thing does.
Bro, I can't.
I can't, bro.
Bro.
I fucking can't deal with this.
I took one of them.
I took the Hella.
That's all that matters.
He went high ground?
Oh my god, I gave him high ground.
It's fine.
Two people died.
Two people died anyway.
I didn't think he would fucking fly up there!
Kidnap!
I kidnapped the one person that could fly!
Okay.
I don't know.
I think we just need two tanks.
That's really it.
They have two tanks and we don't.
I think that's our only problem.
They literally have two tanks.
Guys, I fucking did so much to keep these guys alive.
Oh
my god.
I went over.
I had
no...
Yeah, and our Penny guy is not a good tank.
She does not.
She does not play tank.
Yes.
Oh my
god.
Yeah, Penny was not the play.
Bro, I'm like stuck in this fucking... I'm stuck in this loop.
I'm never leaving this fucking loop, guys.
I'm never leaving this fucking loop!
Oh my god.
This purgatory.
This actual purgatory.
I'm avoiding you?
You can manage lister anytime in settings social.
Okay, we gotta manage this.
Okay, settings social.
We gotta manage this because I need to make sure all my voiceless is just...
Okay.
Okay, we need to... Okay, we're keeping that.
A maximum of three players.
Okay.
We're gonna make sure they're all just Luna players.
We gotta make them all Luna players then.
Oh my god, this is a problem.
Oh boy, her.
Oh shit.
No, please.
I don't want to be your friend.
Don't be my friend.
Don't accept it.
Oh my god.
I didn't mean it.
I clicked too fast.
I clicked way too fast.
Oh god.
Oh my god, please.
Okay.
I'm... Okay.
It's still possible.
Sorry.
My mic was in front of my face.
It's still possible.
Oh my god, it's been six hours.
Okay, at the seven hour mark.
Oh my god, I'm supposed to do some recordings too today.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't think this would take this long.
I really did not think it would take this long, guys.
Emmanuel, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Okay, by the way.
Also, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm gonna wish you a happy birthday soon.
But...
Before I say anything...
Okay, but like...
I gotta say...
Even if I didn't fuck up that one ult...
Even if I didn't fuck up that one ult there...
Where like, you know, everybody died...
Because I accidentally... I don't know how I did it...
But I accidentally double pressed Q...
I would... We would not have won.
We would not have fucking won.
There was no way.
Our team was...
We had one tank that didn't know how to play tank.
Emmanuel, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you, Emmanuel.
Happy birthday!
Oh my God.
Here we go.
Oh my God, we were so close.
We were so close.
Okay.
God, I hate this map.
Why do we always play this map?
We have two tanks.
Okay, I'm gonna give it to Groot.
That's fucked.
That's fucked, bro.
Oh my God, and he's dancing.
He walled us off and he's dancing.
That's so fucked.
He walls us off and then he starts dancing.
That's messed up, bro.
I don't know if I should...
Oh, maybe I should have given it to the Iron Fist.
Yeah.
The thing is, I don't know how good our Iron Fist is.
So like, you know, when you don't know how good your DPS is, I don't like putting it on a DPS.
Just because I don't know if I can trust him.
Oh no.
No, no, that's...
That's fucking right.
And I go back to healing.
As if nothing bad happened.
That's fucking right.
I go back to healing as if I was not in that fight anymore.
That's why I play back there.
I don't know.
I think I'll give it to our Doctor Strange, maybe.
This is why I play over here.
Because I have the health pack.
I also forget that...
You know what?
Fuck it.
I knew it.
I caught me in a good call here.
That's right!
It's time to fight!
Okay, it's time to heal a little bit.
But then we fight again!
And then we heal.
And then I back away.
Jesus Christ.
Because we got a mixture.
Okay, I...
Whoa!
Okay!
I'm fearing a little bit.
Just...
Oh, they're blocking.
Oh my god.
This is where we leave now.
This is exactly where we leave.
Alright, that guy is crazy.
What happened to the whale?
That's a good question.
Okay.
Alright.
That is a very good question.
Oh my god.
Oh, don't you think you're gonna do that again to me?
Really?
Oh shit!
Of course he fucking ults!
That's the only way you can kill me!
That's...
That's right!
I'm salty!
Of fucking course I'm fucking salty!
Literally, I shit on that kid and then he ults because he can't kill me any other way.
He can't kill me!
He doesn't know how to kill me any other way but that.
Of course I'm fucking salty.
Okay.
Almost out of ult though.
Is that a Hawkeye?
No.
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
Oh my god!
Oh, that's fine.
That's fine.
Alright, that's okay.
Okay, I'm not making that mistake again.
Guys, I don't know if you noticed but I'm not making that mistake.
Oh shit.
Oh yeah, no.
They're fucking dead.
They're...
I'm dead.
Oh my god.
Why do people run away from my ult?
You do not need to run away from my ult, guys.
Maybe a Hella?
Our DPS is dying way too much.
I don't feel comfortable about that.
I'm gonna give it to our Hella.
Just see if that helps.
Oh my god, please.
I'm asking that question too.
I'm so close to an ult.
Please.
Yes!
Nice.
Get over here.
I got it just in time.
And then I leave.
Oh, that's such an insane ult!
That's insane!
But we used two support ults.
We used two support ults for that.
This is an OP spot right here.
Hold this.
Oh my god, he's grooting.
There's a Spider-Man ult too.
Hold me, hold me, hold me.
This is bad.
This is very bad.
Sorry, I couldn't do anything.
Sorry.
Did he stand down?
Oh, he died.
I thought, you know, he stood down.
But he's dead.
Oh no!
Oh shit!
Jesus Christ.
I don't know what else I can do.
To be fair, it's only OP because...
To be fair, if...
If he didn't have a Spider-Man ult, we would've been fine.
But he did.
I didn't see her!
Oh my god.
It's okay.
Our team's okay.
I didn't see her.
Oh nice.
Hella got it.
It was only because Spider-Man had ult that it fucked us over.
The only way we could win that was that...
If...
If I had ult or like...
Oh no, Hella.
I legitimately can't...
Oh, this is scary.
Because I could get headshot at any time.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
I need to reposition myself.
I hate this map.
Like, I don't know how to reposition myself here.
No!
He followed me!
I don't have crowd control.
Which one?
She actually...
Wait, can...
Does she have walls?
With the Hella?
When she's ulting?
No, she has a million HP.
There's no point in sniping her in the air.
Unless the entire team hits her.
No, I used the freeze.
I just didn't have...
I just...
Didn't have a chance to use it there.
I mean, I can't freeze her in the air.
When she's in the air...
Uh...
I can't freeze her.
Oh, I used the X-Ray.
I didn't know that.
Oh my god.
Do I just have to lock-in lock-in?
If I lock-in lock-in, I don't talk.
XD
Okay.
Alright, if we lose this one, I might lock-in lock-in so we can end the stream earlier.
XD
I might lock-in lock-in.
Cause like...
When I stream, I get distracted more.
Okay.
If we lose this one, I'll lock-in.
I'll lock-in so fucking hard.
XD Okay.
Alright.
Okay.
No you're not.
You can lie.
Oh my god.
I'm in.
Okay, we gotta get the...
The double heals to our tank.
Alright, it's fine.
He's gruting.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh my god, thank you.
Alright.
We're doing it.
He's gruting it.
I'm gonna get my fucking ult charge off you.
Nice.
Okay, but not gonna lie.
Playing Apex has made me less headshot-y.
Cause like...
Less focus on headshots and more focus on body shots.
Because like...
In Apex...
It's just more efficient to do head- body shots.
When you're playing tra- When you're a tracker.
Cause I play- I use tracking gun- I'm so good at tracking guns.
So I prioritize body shots more.
So like...
I'm like- I need to like...
Train myself to headshot again.
Cause I- Oh my god!
I don't- What?!
I didn't even see the Spider-Man!
Oh my god, here I go.
It's just...
Makes sense to do...
Body shots.
Like center mass.
Yeah.
Nice.
Oh, he's gruting.
He's gruting.
That's right!
I'm on heals this time!
I'm on heals!
I remembered to be on heals!
That's looking right!
That's right!
Oh no.
Oh, he fucked up.
He fucked it up.
He fucked it up!
Oh my god, he fucked it up.
Okay, but R also fucked it up too.
So like, it- There you go.
That's a freeze.
That's a freeze right there.
Okay.
Super tryhard mode.
That's right.
This is what I was like when I used to grind video games a lot.
But like, I used to be better.
Now, I'm just...
Trying- Trying my best.
I froze somebody.
Oh no.
Oh, that was a waste of the clap though.
I think I wasted the clap there.
Keep punching!
You know you want to!
Just play Tekken!
It's fucking Tekken.
Okay, I almost have a-
I hit a headshot- Woah!
No!
How did he know?
Okay, I need to look at this.
What?
What the fuck happened while I was dead?
What the fuck happened there?
It's time to dance!
Oh shit, I should've used my ult.
Oh.
I accidentally- I accidentally- I fat fingered my ult.
They don't have to know.
They don't have to- Oh, it doesn't matter!
Oh, it resets!
Thank god!
I thought it'd carry over.
Guys, it didn't matter.
It doesn't carry over!
I- It doesn't carry over!
Oh my god!
Oh,
thank god!
Oh, I didn't post it!
Thank god!
I was like- Oh shit!
And then I realized- It doesn't carry over.
Thank fucking god.
I thought I fucked up.
I got scared for a bit.
I was thinking about cough.
Holy shit.
Mistakes didn't happen.
Where do we go when they port?
That's the thing.
Cause like, if they port here, they can go down and flank us here.
So at best, I feel like I go here.
But we go here, they get the point for free.
Yeah, I need to remember the C move.
Okay.
Oh my god, I'm trying my best to keep you all alive.
But this is very difficult.
You know, this is incredibly difficult.
I'm sorry, but like, what do we do?
They just start punching!
Oh god, he's healing himself.
Good.
Heal yourself.
We're coming back!
Just live!
Nice.
Live!
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god.
We did it.
Oh my god, we did it.
Oh my god.
TP first.
Devin diff?
Unfortunately, who the fuck is Devin?
Oh.
Lock in, lock in, lock in, lock in.
Gotta lock in.
Lock in, lock in, lock in.
Please, I just wanna be...
I just wanna be Diamond.
Meow.
Literally TP onto their tank.
Bro, what?
We have Wolverine?
Okay.
Oh.
I wish I was a good Mantis player.
I think if I was a good Mantis player...
I can climb even easier.
Because Mantis...
Like, less people are...
Less people main Mantis than Luna.
Porto time.
Goodbye.
God, please!
Can you take...
Make it...
Oh shit.
I think you messed up.
I'm just gonna say...
I think he, like, messed up the...
The grabbing.
Remember when he was like, I'm gonna grab them?
I don't think he grabbed them, guys.
I don't know if he's grabbing them or not.
Oh, he's so low.
Yeah!
We did it!
Oh, yeah.
He took so long.
He was, like, deciding where to go.
And I'm like, are you okay, bro?
Like, are you okay?
Danko, welcome...
Dank, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Two more.
Back to two more games.
Two more games.
Two more games and we'll make it.
Oh my god.
Bro looked at Google Maps to find out where to go.
Two more games.
Ah!
Forever two more.
Come on!
He's timing it for the best timeline.
Oh, no.
I got Devon.
Didn't they told me to avoid Devon?
Oh, no.
Were they saying avoid Devon?
Bro, what's wrong with you, Devon?
What's wrong with you?
Wait, what's wrong with Devon and metal?
Not as good as Devon.
Devon, you better fucking lock it in, Devon.
I've been playing this for way too long.
Devon, you better fucking lock it in.
Dev, where are you, Devon?
I need you to lock the fuck in.
Oh, they have the Dirt Tank.
Dirt Tank was really good.
They're like, avoid Devon.
I'm like, why?
And then I get Devon.
Instructions unclear.
I got Devon on my team.
Devon, please.
You better fucking lock it in, Devon.
Please, I need to be top 500, Devon.
I don't know who I should give it to for this one.
I do have a...
I do have a Hella, though.
So, maybe the Hella?
Goodbye.
I think I've learned to just insta-freeze when I see a portal.
Oh my god, guys!
Come back into the portal, guys!
Guys, no!
No!
Come back, Devon!
He got locked in.
Holy shit, that's scary.
Get back in here, soldier!
He jumped in.
Holy shit.
That's crazy.
That's fucking crazy.
That's the Storm player, too.
Apparently, he's really good at Storm.
So, like, I'm a little nervous.
Oh shit, that pillar was so close.
This is fucking scary.
You don't understand.
Sorry, you're gonna have to deal with that yourself.
I fucking left.
I was like, I am not dealing with that guy.
I'm sorry.
Good luck.
Okay.
You got this.
Live!
I'm gonna save my ult as a defensive.
I don't trust it, like...
I don't know.
You guys are fine, right?
Okay.
What?
Oh shit!
He's forming a spirit ball!
He's...
Fuck!
What the fuck?
What the fuck was that?
Oh, no.
No!
Guys!
Please!
He's in our spot!
Guys, please!
Guys!
No way!
Like, I had...
And then the worst part is like...
I was like the character they had to solo ult.
Like, legitimately, solo ulting me was the...
What's the word?
Was the...
Guys, we're fucking dead here.
Guys, we are so dead.
It was the right move because I had the ult that was going to win the game for everybody.
Oh my god.
Oh, goodbye!
You're so...
I saw a man die today.
Bro, I keep getting fucking...
bored.
Vortexed.
Just break it.
Just fucking break it.
Who cares?
I don't know.
What the fuck do you want me to do?
Okay.
He's over there.
I'm scared though.
Oh, I just looked at him.
I'm sorry.
I just looked at you.
I missed.
Are you serious?!
Hey, there's like a guy right here.
Like...
Jesus Christ.
No.
No way.
No fucking way!
Oh my god, he ate them all!
He ate them all!
No fucking way!
I couldn't do anything!
I just had to watch it happen!
My entire team!
God!
That was scary.
Okay.
This Jeff is good.
This Jeff knows how to use his ult.
Which is annoying.
I hate him.
So much.
Okay.
Please.
Please, someone stop them.
What?
Did he fuck up?
What the fuck happened?
Did he mess it up?
What the fu- What?
What happened there?
Did you see that?
What the fuck happened?
Oh my god!
When he said I was going to unleash it, I didn't think he was going to do it now!
Hey, you're alive.
This is scary.
Oh my god, it's just one of them.
That's five.
That's okay.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, thank god.
I stunned him.
That's right.
I am what?
That's fucking right.
Oh wait, that's not good.
We lost one.
Guys, we lost one.
Guys, they can still fight, guys.
Guys!
Guys, it's not over yet, guys!
They can still contest!
Oh, this is bad.
Guys, please.
Oh my god.
This is bad.
This is actually bad.
Nice.
Oh god.
Oh my god, I'm dancing, please!
All I do is dance!
That's all I know how to do!
That's everything I know!
Oh my god, I'm fucking... I'm gonna go...
I'm gonna break.
I'm gonna fucking break, guys.
I'm fucking... I'm gonna have a breakdown.
I'm gonna...
Devon, please give me...
Guys, okay, the worst part is that...
MVP gives you 40 plus points.
That's the worst part.
If I could get MVP, I could get 40 plus points and I don't even need to play one more game.
That's the thing.
I wouldn't need to play one more game if I had 40 plus points.
It...
It sucks!
Cause support...
It's so hard for the support to get MVP.
I don't know how...
How to get it.
It's like DPS and tank.
They can.
Right now, it's our...
It's our Mantis.
But the thing is, the Mantis is DPSing.
So it's like...
It's so difficult.
Cause like...
It relies on...
DPS versus heals.
So like...
Being DPS is faster to rank up.
Which is like...
The downside.
DPS is actually...
Uh...
Faster...
To rank up and stuff.
That's how like...
Surefour was so ahead of me all the time.
Because like...
He just...
He keeps getting MVP and because he gets MVP, he ranks up faster.
I almost went back in.
That would've been so bad.
Oh my god!
Guys!
This is very bad!
Guys, I need you to get out of here!
I do not feel comfortable being here.
Guys!
Please!
This is it.
We fight this.
We fucking fight this.
We fucking...
Oh yeah.
Oh!
I guess I die.
I...
Why did we fight that for so long?
High ground was not it.
High ground was definitely not it.
I did not feel good about the high ground fight there.
Okay.
I feel like if we split, it's better.
Are we gonna do this again?
Okay.
I'm just gonna heal here.
It's just easier.
Please.
No.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh no!
Oh!
Please!
Cause I don't have anything!
I'm trying!
You're taking so much damage!
Alright.
We die I guess.
Goodbye.
Oh my god.
Please!
We have Storm ult.
I have to save my ult for Storm.
We're so bad at pushing.
We don't have any picks.
To be fair, our Punisher is not doing so well.
I don't think our Punisher is doing very well either too.
I can't.
I don't have an angle.
Oh my god, we actually got a kill.
Oh my god!
What?
Oh my god.
Aww.
This sucks.
This was last fight too.
Okay, nice.
They have Storm ult so I hope they do something.
Alright!
Goodbye everybody!
If you live, congratulations.
If you live.
No!
They were right!
They were right when they told me to avoid Devon!
They were like, Devon's bad luck.
He was right.
He was.
Can't believe it.
Alright.
Who do I avoid?
Oh my god, I'm in like...
I'm actually in hell right now.
I'm in fucking hell.
Oh my god.
Wait, who do I avoid?
I don't know.
Let's see.
Do we actually avoid Devon?
I'm gonna avoid Devon.
They were like, avoid Devon.
And I was like, do I really?
Okay, I avoid.
Alright.
Okay.
Alright, guys.
I'm gonna lock in now.
Okay, I'm gonna put it on text.
Jokey is locking in.
I'm locking in.
I'm not gonna talk.
I was gonna lock in now, but like, why is this taking so long to get a match?
Like, who's internet is this?
Like, I was so ready to lock in.
Like, I was so fucking ready to lock in.
But why is my game not in yet?
Like, I was like, okay, this is taking way too long.
How am I supposed to lock in?
How?
I'm locking in.
Finally.
Okay, nice.
Alright, now I'm locking in.
What I needed to do was sing, really.
Three, two, one.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Got it?
What Loki has begun in Asgard, I will complete.
Looks like the mission area is yours to capture now.
I'm hurt.
The
mission area is yours.
I'm making a comeback.
Let them come and face the queen of hell.
Control locked.
Be your best self.
An opportunity for combat.
Needed that, thanks.
Glow
up.
I'm making a comeback.
Unleash!
Their team's capture progress has passed the halfway point.
Glow up.
I am ready to put on a show.
Your powers are mine.
I'm back in the fight.
I think it's a tank, dude.
It's like fucking...
It's a tank.
It's a fucking tank.
My team didn't lock in.
What do I do when team doesn't lock in?
Oh my god.
What do I do?
My team isn't locked.
I don't even know who's doing anything.
I guess our Namor?
Our Namor.
So I guess I'll give this to my Namor.
I'll give this to him.
Alright, locking back in.
Locking back in.
This will be fun.
It's a scratch.
Mission
area is yours to capture now.
Capture the mission area.
You are fortunate Namor was here.
Gosh, you saved my little spot.
No swimming away now, little fish.
Keep an eye on this spot.
Capture
the mission area.
Keep going.
You'll have to keep fighting until you have a winner.
I think it was impossible with this team.
Guys, we're back to three games.
I'm stuck in this loop.
I'm actually stuck in this loop.
I'm fucking stuck in this crazy ass.
In this crazy ass loop.
Oh my god.
When will I break the loop?
When will I break the fucking loop?
It's been three games for 20 years.
I'm never gonna break the loop.
Oh my god.
This is crazy.
This is actually crazy.
I thought I was stuck flat one.
Games are so rough.
Alright.
Okay, next time I'm not gonna mute myself.
I'll just...
I'll express myself.
I'm gonna express myself.
Oh my god.
Now the queues are taking forever.
I played for so long.
I played for so long that it's not instant anymore.
Oh my god.
I'm actually in hell.
I'm in hell.
I played for so long that my queues aren't instant.
I have to keep going.
Oh my god.
I think the worst part is that I play and the other people are still playing as well.
And then...
So the cutoff keeps getting higher and higher.
Oh my god.
How high?
It's Diamond 3.
The cutoff is currently Diamond 3.
I'm going fucking insane.
I'm actually...
I need water though.
I need...
Oh my god.
We actually...
We actually have been stuck in this yellow hell of Plat 1.
Alright.
Come on.
Oh my god.
Why is this taking so long?
Holy shit.
I'm gonna fucking go crazy.
I think the worst part is that I feel like I'm being held hostage by just the loading screen alone.
I wanna know who it is so I can, like, queue dodge this.
I...
I just want you...
I just want a fucking top 500.
I just want top 500.
Please, I'm so close.
I was supposed to record stuff today.
I was told today's the deadline.
I'm sorry.
I'll record it right after this.
I'll record it right after.
That's why I said...
I didn't think...
I didn't think it would be...
take this long.
I legitimately didn't think it would take this long.
By the way... No, because I've been recording every day.
I've been recording every day.
And then, like...
But it's a lot of...
What?
Oh my god.
I've been recording every day.
And it's a lot of recordings.
And...
Today was, like, the last day...
Like, I've been sending recordings almost every day.
And today's, like, the last...
Like, but then I...
Like, it was just one last recording.
Is it one last one?
Yeah, it's one last recording.
But, like...
Oh my god, it's...
Oh my god, I wasted eight minutes for that.
Oh my god.
No...
Guys, we're gonna do it.
We're gonna do it.
It was just a lot of work.
And it helped I was, like, coughing a lot too.
So, like...
I couldn't record a lot of stuff.
I had to, like, pace myself.
Because, like...
I also...
Because, like, I was coughing a lot.
So I had to pace myself.
Because if I record too much...
It got really bad for my throat.
So then I had to, like...
That's why I'm locking in now.
Because I'm locking in.
Because I know, like...
Ah, fuck, like...
I can't keep talk...
I didn't think it would take this long.
I thought... I didn't think, like...
The cutoff would go so fast.
That's the thing.
I didn't think that...
I thought we could just be plat one.
And it'll be fine.
But the thing was...
Who keeps fucking not loading in?
There's someone in my team that's shitty fucking internet.
Alright, I'm gonna...
Oh my god, we have a Wolverine play too.
What the hell?
Alright, I'm done.
I'm not rich as this.
Oh, recycling the...
Okay, I'm not gonna mute myself.
But I'm gonna lock in.
So I won't talk too much.
I'll actually try really hard.
I don't remember what my team was last game.
Do you die in matches this time?
Yeah, I'll get one more absolute.
Just get a good one streak.
The what?
How?
Like, okay, I guess I don't take the portal.
Okay.
Guys.
I don't think this is...
Oh my god, this team.
Like, what is...
I don't feel good at this, you know?
Oh.
What?
What hit me?
Wait, is this the same team as my last game?
Wait, is it really?
I didn't even notice that.
This might be a stack then.
There's no other way.
This might be a stack if it's the same team.
They're not talking either, too.
So unlucky.
That's actually...
I'm that unlucky I got my same team as last game?
Bro, this team is like...
This team is so...
I don't know how they're playing.
They're all just split up.
Split up.
Okay, I'm not locked in anymore.
This team is actually dude.
Like, shit.
I was gonna say dude, but I'm like, no, what the fuck?
It's actually legitimate shit.
Somebody shoot him!
Instead of me!
I'm plat one.
I'm one tier away from top 500 because top 500 is D3 right now.
But it sucks because...
I could have got it.
But like, something...
I had two...
I had games that were a bit trolly.
No, I could just avoid them.
I need to avoid the worst player though.
This last fight...
This is a really bad team.
They're so...
I have to use this.
Just so like...
He's alive.
Just so he can be alive.
Just attack.
Legitimately just attack me.
Like, just tap me.
Like...
Just hit me like one time.
Top 500...
A lot of people in top 500 just stack.
So like...
What the fuck?
You didn't kill her?
I'll kill her myself.
How are there two people behind us?
Alright, that's fine.
He's not healing his team.
That's fine.
Jesus.
Alright, that's fine.
That's fine.
He is literally not with his team.
Kill him.
That's fine.
That's really funny.
Not gonna lie.
That's pretty funny.
That's
pretty funny.
Are you
really serious?
I can't do anything.
I can't.
Oh my gosh.
Maybe...
My team got three kills.
Oh my gosh.
Alright.
We're fine.
We're so fine.
Oh my god, this team.
I can't.
I can't deal with this team.
This team is so special.
I can't.
I have to like actually focus so much.
I have ult.
How?
Oh no.
We double ulted.
That's really bad.
We double support ulted.
This is so bad.
Oh, this is so bad.
I didn't think she would support ult too.
I'm running.
I'm fucking skiing.
Skate, girl.
Skate.
You have to touch it.
It's your fucking...
Why are you not touching it?
Why did you wait the DPS?
You're such a fucking...
I'm avoiding this guy.
I'm avoiding Captain Koi.
That's the first guy I'm avoiding.
Oh my god.
Why the fuck did he turn around?
I'm gonna look you up.
Oh, I can't.
I wish you can like look people up.
Wait, maybe?
Oh, I can't.
I can't look at history.
I'm gonna look at your profile.
I'm gonna examine your profile.
I'm gonna be so fucking toxic.
I'm gonna look at your profile.
After this game is over.
Alright.
That was such an insane throw.
To be fair, we have fucking Wolverine.
But like...
We have...
Okay, I either avoid the Wolverine or I avoid the fucking...
I don't know which one.
They're both pretty fucking terrible.
They're both pretty bad.
Oh my god.
I'm just getting griefed right now.
By unlucky matchmaking.
Look who just shook.
Why didn't you fight him?
I'm fucking losing.
I saw that and I was like, I'm fucking gone.
Good luck guys.
Please keep up.
Just keep him up.
He is the most important person in our lineup.
He's really our only tank.
Just keep this guy up.
That's all that matters.
Like who cares about...
Oh my god, please.
Guys, I need you guys to kill one person.
Please.
I need you guys to kill one guy for us.
Okay, if anything, we should get Moon Knight to fucking change.
He's fucking terrible.
Honestly, I'd say just fucking change Moon Knight.
He's actually terrible.
I heard her.
I was just like, fuck that.
I cannot be bothered.
I can't be bothered to hear that.
Starts clicking heals.
I cannot be bothered to hear her fucking heals clicking.
Goodbye.
Oh, thank god.
Hello again.
You know what?
Fuck this.
I'm dancing.
I'm just gonna dance.
We're fighting this.
Jesus Christ.
How many ults?
How many fucking ults, guys?
Oh, I thought he was closer.
Please.
We danced the pain away.
We actually danced the pain away.
Oh my god.
We're gonna dance it all away.
This has to be the worst team I've ever got.
And I had a team that was like, swap Spiderman or I throw.
Oh yeah, swap the tank or I throw my game.
But no, this has to be the worst team.
Because individually, they're all fucking terrible players.
Like individually, in the other ones, at least the other players are actually good.
Individually.
But these guys, individually, these guys are all fucking terrible.
Like, kill him!
Oh my god, help!
Oh my god, I'm actually gonna fucking shoot you.
How bad are you?
Oh my god, I thought I could hide from the wall.
Oh my god, you're all...
Okay.
Alright.
Poor games.
Oh my...
Wolverine, guys.
It's not just...
I don't think they don't realize.
It's not just the Wolverine.
Our Moonlight player was just as fucking ass.
There's no way.
Our...
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
Wait, our fucking Psylocke player was ass too?
Oh my god.
Alright.
Avoid as player.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Wolverine was actually the worst player.
Moon...
I thought Moonlight was doing nothing.
But he actually did the most.
He felt like...
He felt so useless to me.
Holy fuck.
Okay, I avoided the Wolverine.
Oh yeah.
I need to look at his profile.
How do I look at his profile?
Wait.
Can I?
I thought I can.
Oh, I have to be in the history.
Guys, no.
It won't be possible.
I believe I can do this.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
This is not looking so good right here.
We're both like...
Okay.
He has a 50% win rate?
Oh my god.
Oh, you can't see his statistic.
Good for him.
I was about to be toxic.
What about this guy?
I mean, that's not 50% at least.
But you're a Wolverine one trick.
Which is one of the worst characters you can play.
Oh no.
Okay.
How far?
Four games.
It's Diamond 3.
It's literally the edge of Diamond 3.
Yeah, everything is Diamond 3.
Everything.
Everything is Diamond 3.
Like, the moment we hit Diamond 3, it was there.
Oh my god.
Come on.
I need Diamond 3.
This is where it's gonna change.
I believe in us.
I believe in you guys.
No, this is it.
This is it.
This is...
Alright.
I'll get up after this game and stretch a little.
The worst part is that I am like back where I started.
Like, not back where I started.
But I'm back where...
Surefour left.
Because I got so close.
After he left.
This is where I was.
This is where I was after I left.
Okay, sure.
Alright.
Let's do Jeff.
Today's a Jeff day.
Might as well.
Might as well fucking Jeff it up.
Gotta do something different today.
Is that the rule of who...
No, when he left, top 500 was still...
Top 500 was still plat 1.
That's the thing.
When he left, top 500 was still fucking...
I'm avoiding.
I'm avoiding so I can play Luna next game.
Was still...
Top 500 was still plat 1.
And then we kept going.
And now top 500 is Diamond 4.
So...
Or Diamond 3.
Top 500 is Diamond 3.
Alright.
Okay, this is a good Jeff map though.
This is a really good Jeff map because I can...
I can throw people off.
Alright.
That's fine.
Jesus Christ.
What is going on?
How many fucking tings do I have to reload my mouse?
Oh my god.
We lost our two supports.
Which is me.
And our Luna.
I should not have stayed there.
Okay, I actually need to lock in though.
I'm not playing my main.
Can't headshot when I'm underground.
Jesus Christ.
I looked away for one second.
Really?
Oh my god.
I had to reload my mouse.
Oh, I didn't see the bomb!
I think three tings is not it.
I don't...
I think I have to play Cloak and Dagger.
Because there's not enough heals for three tings.
There's actually not enough heals.
I don't know what else to do.
Okay.
I don't think...
I think I have to play Cloak and Dagger.
Three tings...
Oh, we have two tings now.
Okay.
No way!
They mined the entire thing up!
Alright, it's time to learn.
It's time to learn.
I got death counted!
The mines actually counted me!
Oh my god.
I need to avoid all Luna players.
They know what they are going for when they ask for Luna.
And I insta-lock Luna.
No!
Winstreet starts next game!
I've just been unlucky with...
I don't know how I've been unlucky with teammates four games in a row.
I've just been very unlucky.
I wish you can avoid more people.
That's why like...
No, everybody stacks now.
In top 500.
It's so annoying.
Or like to...
Or close to...
People close to top 500.
Or like in top 500.
They just all stack.
That's what I was like doing.
Because like...
It's so annoying.
I mean, he's the only one making the portal.
No one else went to the portal.
I'm sorry, Dr. Strange.
I'm sorry.
We didn't care about your portal.
What?!
Where's my DPS players?!
Wait, wait!
None of our DPS got kills!
Wait, you're right!
Oh my god!
None of them got kills!
You're fucking right!
I
don't think we win this, guys.
It's just...
It's just life.
It's just life, guys.
I just...
I never stop left-clicking.
I never stop left-clicking!
I just left-click forever.
You'll be fine, Dr. Strange!
No cloak, just dagger.
Guys, we really need the heals.
Like...
Legitimately, if I don't stop left-clicking, we fucking die.
It's...
It's sadly how we have to do it.
Alright, look, see?
He dies.
At least I'm learning cloak.
Guys...
It's just...
It's just how it goes.
It's just how we gotta deal with it.
Oh my god!
No dagger, only cloak.
So nothing died, ever.
That's so true!
That's so fucking true!
Nothing ever fucking died!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I just need to keep avoiding all the...
I just need to keep avoiding all the Luna players.
That's the only way.
Mantis is too hard.
I can't learn cloak...
I can't learn mantis...
Um...
Intent for this ELO.
Oh yeah, no, I forgot to get up!
I forgot to get up and stretch!
No!
Oh my god...
I forgot to get up and stretch...
Fuck...
Oh...
I need to lock in my character!
Okay...
Oh!
Okay, I'm gonna stretch right now.
Ah!
I'm gonna stretch right now.
Hmm...
Ah...
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, maybe we have DPS players.
Maybe...
Maybe we have DPS players now.
Maybe we have...
Maybe we have DPS players.
It'll be different.
We'll have DPS players this time.
I believe.
What the fuck do I power up?
Oh, let's just power up Thor.
Actually, I don't know, because they're both flankered tanks.
They're both like tanks that flank, so it's like I don't know who...
Who I should go to.
Okay, who's like farther up?
Okay, I should give it to Thor then.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
I'm sorry, I have to heal.
Nice.
C'mon.
Just kill something, anything.
That's fine, we're just... we're just gonna dance.
Oh my god.
Holy shit, he does so much damage.
Okay, I have to go now.
Oh, nothing is dying.
Nothing is dying and I'm scared.
No!
But I'm dying!
Okay.
This is fun.
How?
Wait, what?
Oh, it's the low-key ult.
I was like, what?
Why did he waste that?
Okay, I put it...
Where did I put the...
Not venom, I did not put it on venom.
I need to put it on venom.
Okay.
Please, can we have a normal tank?
Can we have...
Can we have a normal tank?
Like, what are you...
Why are you looking at me?
Help your buddy!
Help him!
Why are you...
Oh!
Guys.
How do I get...
Guys, what's my RNG?
Really?
How is my RNG this bad with teammates?
Like, four games in a row.
This is actually crazy.
Hire a DPS player?
I don't know anyone that's awake at this hour that's gonna play.
I legitimately think I just need a DPS player.
Because I've been getting tank players that don't know how to play.
Bro, I...
Okay.
Okay, I'm alive somehow.
That's crazy that I'm alive somehow.
That's...
Oh!
My god!
Bro, at this point I don't even have a team.
Bro!
What is my team?
Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
I can't.
I don't think I'm underperforming.
Am I underperforming?
I don't feel like I am.
Oh my god.
I'm fucking trying to find DPS players right now.
Or tank player.
I think...
I don't care.
I just want to duo with either a DPS or a tank player, so at least one slot isn't a fucking Luna player.
Like, and I get three more avoids.
I get three more avoids.
I need more avoids slots.
I don't know.
I don't think I'm underperforming.
I feel like I'm playing...
I feel like I'm playing the same.
I'm playing...
All right.
This is what I do.
I know, like, I could use the stairs, but this is faster.
Oh, now you'll play fucking Penny?
How much do you do rank?
Do you do rank fully?
I hope not.
I've never did rank before, so...
There, see?
Easy.
I just think we're ha- we have, like, we had Venom and Thor, and Venom and Thor are both like, uh...
They're, like, off tanks, I feel like.
They're not main tanks.
I think, like, Doctor Strange and Magneto are both really good.
What?
How did you die so fast?
How?
What?
God.
Jesus.
See?
She doesn't play Cloak in Cloak and Dagger.
Okay.
I'm okay.
For now.
Okay.
Thor.
Thor, I don't like that, Thor.
Nope, goodbye, Thor.
I don't know what you expected there, bro.
I'm assuming you don't know what you expected.
I'm gonna drop down because I can tell they wanted to- yeah.
I could tell they wanted to push me there.
Alright.
Loki?
I don't think Loki's good.
IMO.
Oh my god, Thor.
Thor, why?
Thor!
My god, Julesn!
Oh my god, I guess I've ulted.
You guys gotta liiiiiiiiiiiiiiii-
No it's not.
No it's not spider time.
It's not spider time.
Nope, spider time's over.
Oh, that's what I'm saying.
I feel like I'm not performing badly.
It's just somehow I'm like very unlucky with teams.
Oh my god, really?
Stop, please.
Oh no, this is bad for us.
This is so bad.
Oh my god.
I couldn't do anything.
I was already like stuck there.
Oh no, you got two!
How close was I?
I was not close at all.
I think that's gg there.
The moment she did the ult, I knew it was over.
I knew it was over.
Okay, I'm fucking- I need to get this team out of my fucking game.
Bro, how am I- oh my god, and I'm always like top healer.
I was at the most healers out of both teams.
Oh god.
I need to get up and walk a little bit.
Oh, this is cute.
I need a 50 Overwatch thing!
Okay, give me a sec.
I don't know how I got shitty teams four games in a row.
I need to get... who's... okay.
I don't know who was the worst player.
They were all pretty bad.
That's the thing.
All of them were so bad.
I don't know.
Oh my god.
Okay.
No!
It's literally...
The more you play...
That's the thing.
The more you play, if you know you're at a certain skill level, you hit it.
But it's just...
I'm getting RNG'd so hard with teammates.
It's actually...
Most of the people climbing in this ELO or hitting top 500, they stack.
So when you solo, you have to pray RNG gods that you get the stackers.
I can't.
My DPS is not that level.
All the DPS players are actual top 500 DPS players.
So I'm not that level in DPS.
Yeah.
I did.
That's why I duo'd with Surefour earlier.
Because I knew that a lot of people in this ELO, they stack to get higher.
And now it's so hard because I'm getting RNG'd so fucking much.
I'm actually getting fucking teammate RNG'd so badly.
It's actually crazy.
Like how is it the chance...
Like...
Fuck.
I got it.
When I have like decent teammates, I can pull it through.
Have I tried finding a duo?
I only know two people and two of them said no.
In my ELO.
I only know two people in my ELO and two of them said no.
Because...
Oh my god.
She was bad.
I know.
I think SK... I don't know.
I think SK is like...
She's like...
I think she's offline too.
I've never played with SK before.
I don't know.
I've never played...
I feel weird asking people like...
I've never done like solo stuff before.
I feel weird asking.
And I don't think she's in my range.
I think she's too high.
I know she's diamond something.
She's like diamond now.
I don't know if I can queue with diamond players.
Can I queue with diamond players?
I mean I can...
Oh my god.
I feel so weird.
I feel so weird messaging SK.
Okay.
Alright.
If we lose this one, we message SK.
But if it's not my fault, chat.
If it's not my fault and we lost, I'll message SK and see if she'll be down.
No, I was sure for when to bidge.
I hate playing on this side.
I've never been very lucky on this side of the map.
That was not a good choice for my end.
What?
How are you dead?
Wait, how are you alive?
Wait, how do we have one tank?
I have so many questions.
Okay.
I don't like that we're here.
Please, I need help.
Okay.
Okay, we got one.
Focusing up.
Okay, nice.
We got the control back.
I don't like being on this side though, that's the thing.
It's such a weird comp.
Like, we're so...
We're so...
We're so split.
I don't really like that.
Holy shit.
Oh, that's two.
That's two kills.
We should go in.
Okay, nevermind.
One of us is back.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Standing this.
Standing this!
Both teams are actually...
I'm gonna say it.
I think both teams are equally bad.
I legitimately don't think...
I think both teams are not great.
My team and the enemy team are, like, really special.
Why do I say that?
I can tell from the way people play.
Like, this is...
not, like...
high...
elo.
It is high elo, but you know what I mean?
This is...
This is stupid.
Compared to the games I played earlier.
This feels very stupid to watch.
We'll keep each other up.
Okay.
No, I'm just saying...
Both of...
Both teams play very stupid.
And, like, you can sort of tell...
You can sort of tell...
that both teams play...
very stupid.
Yeah.
Yeah, this is like a fucking clown.
This is a circus.
This is legitimately a fucking circus.
Oh my god, this is a fucking circus.
I'm messaging SK.
I can't.
This is a fucking circus.
I saw the quality of the games there, and I'm like, bro...
Take me back to high elo.
Oh, is she asleep?
Aww.
Alright.
I mean...
I'll mess...
Is she asleep?
Okay, um...
Who was doing the best?
I guess it was our Hella.
So I'll put this on the Hella.
Alright, then I lost all my choices.
I know, like, Booger really wanted to duo.
Because he fucking was, like, duo on Twitter, and he never even followed me.
I was like, the fuck?
Where...
Where are you?
I think he's way too high elo.
So this is the future.
Or one future, anyway.
They want to get better, though.
Jesus Christ.
What the fuck was that?
Actually, what the fuck was that all?
Oh!
Oh my god!
You're not dying on me, soldier!
You're not fucking dying on me!
You fight!
You fucking fight!
That's right!
And then I leave you guys.
If you die, it's...
I'm sorry.
Okay, wow.
I didn't expect you guys to actually fight.
Alright.
Are they okay?
Holy shit, they were not okay!
Nice.
This is a fucking circus.
Winning this game is not...
I mean, it makes me happy, because I finally break my last streak.
But, like...
This quality of this game was...
Okay.
Alright, goodbye.
Oh shit, she's gonna put on a show and send out the spiders.
Oh my god.
That's fucking crazy.
Oh shit!
That's right, do it your way!
Do it your way!
That's fucking right!
Oh, he's dead.
Oh my god.
He is...
He should not have done it his way.
Oh...
Guys, I froze the spider thing.
I did it.
You'll never expect it.
It's been frozen.
Oh shit, I didn't realize there was a Hella.
Thank god I'm still alive.
Oh my god.
Guys.
I finally got the RNG of the teammates, guys.
Guys, I finally did it.
I got the teammate RNG.
Oh my god.
It happened.
I got the teammate RNG.
Oh my god.
I actually did it.
I got the teammate RNG.
Oh my god.
I did it.
I gotta take what I can get.
I gotta take what I can fucking get.
I'm desperate here.
I'm fucking desperate.
I didn't expect this to be such a long stream.
Okay.
Come on, RNG.
We just...
Oh my god, we just...
Okay, Eski said she's down.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright, I'm gonna use the fucking... I'm gonna use the bathroom.
Oh my god.
I get six avoid slots.
Let's go!
Oh my god, let's fucking go.
That's like the one thing I'm the most happy about.
I'm so happy.
I get avoid slots.
I get avoid slots and I have someone that knows how to play DPS.
That's...
Oh my god.
Using Eski as an extra avoid slot.
It's the...
Guys, no, you don't understand.
That's basically...
That's basically what Overwatch was like.
People stacked so they can use avoid slots to get rid of people.
That's also like another thing a lot...
Another thing people would do.
But I can't.
This is...
It's what people used to do.
And I'm fucking...
I'm using up all my old tricks to climb.
Using my fucking tricks to climb.
Jesus Christ.
Because I don't think...
I don't think I'm doing that bad.
I think I have made mistakes here and there.
But I don't think my mistakes could have given me the last streak that I had.
These...
These games were fucking unwinnable.
All of these games were fucking unwinnable.
None of them were winnable at all.
I refuse to believe these games were winnable.
Like, I...
I fucking refuse to believe that.
Oh...
Yeah, no, because like...
I felt like I was doing pretty well.
Or like the situation I was in.
Like...
Oh my god.
Or like...
Would I have to fucking be pushed through?
No way it was my fault.
Like...
I had so many people feeding.
Oh yeah, fuck Devon.
They were right.
I played my fucking heart out for this one.
I...
I kept everybody alive for the longest fucking time.
Fuck you, Devon.
The enemy team was right.
You were a fucking prime avoid slot.
I didn't listen.
I didn't fucking listen.
They were like, you should avoid him.
And I was like, really?
And then I didn't listen.
Fuck you, Devon.
You did not lock in.
You did not fucking lock in when I needed you to.
We hate Devon1 in chat.
That's right.
Shit.
We hate you.
Oh shit.
I got a friend request sent.
Oh my god, they actually added me.
I'm so...
No, get out.
Get out.
Get fucking...
I actually...
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
Save me from...
From the circus.
Oh my god.
Rest in peace.
There's no way, Devon.
Devon1.
You can't be in chat, Devon1.
Oh my god.
And just got off 30 minutes.
Welcome back to the grind.
Wait, what's...
Oh, Plat 1?
Wait.
Wait, you're not Diamond?
I thought you were Diamond 3.
I thought...
Wait, I thought...
I hit Plat 1.
Oh!
I thought...
She was high...
She was on the leaderboards.
So I thought she was Diamond.
That's why.
Okay.
I was confused.
Because I was like...
Wait, I thought...
She had on her stream title her ELO and stuff.
And...
Alright.
That's right.
Get out.
I'm not even going to swap.
That's right, Ashlyn.
That's fucking right.
Oh.
Nah.
I'm trying not to use my voice too much anymore.
Do we have two support players?
Bro, do we have three support players?
Are you fucking serious?
Oh my god.
Do we have three support players?
Are you fucking serious?
Bro, I don't even know who the fuck is talking anymore.
I don't know who the fuck is talking.
Oh.
It's me.
Good comp.
Alright.
Wait.
What the fuck was talking?
I can't tell who's talking.
Okay.
Is that SK?
I can't tell.
The...
Like, I can't tell if it's her.
She's one.
She's literally...
No way.
Here we go.
Is that SK talking?
I can't...
I hate the VC.
It's so buggy.
It's the one thing I hate the most about...
I'm trying to keep you up.
Venom!
Don't climb like that, Venom!
Venom, please!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we're trying.
Oh, I'm dead.
Oh shit.
Alright.
Okay.
It's fine, I have ult.
It's fine, I have ult, guys.
That is not fine.
Holy shit, that is not...
Alright, there we go, guys.
Dance time.
Oh my god!
What a combo!
Okay.
I thought that was a cool ult.
They deserve that.
They honestly...
They deserve that win right there.
I don't care.
What the fuck is going on?
What is going on?
Okay, I need heals too.
Why are people yelling?
I'm making a comeback.
I know, but who was the other teammate saying?
Guys, I thought we would do...
I'd get less of a circus.
Just go support, you can play through support.
It's good.
You won't die though.
Only 60 seconds left.
It's fine.
Sorry team, we got this.
We're doing great.
I am ready to put on a show!
What the fuck?
I think we got him.
He's one.
He's actually one.
Please!
I'm the only...
Oh, we did get three support players.
How do I have this problem?
Every time!
I actually...
I had three support players.
I'm trying to do a TP.
Let's all regroup.
Come on, I'm playing.
We don't have a game to play.
Go outside and help us.
Where are you going to help us?
I don't understand.
Oh, hello.
Hey, can we like go through the TP and help our guy?
I think he needs help, guys.
Oh no.
Oh no, his powers are his.
Bro, I'm fucking scared right now.
Oh my god.
Well, here we go.
I'm ready to put on the show now.
Oh no, there it is.
Okay.
Alright.
Off I go.
Hoping things go better, but I don't think so.
Okay.
They need a one instead of three.
Good try.
Oh.
I'm dancing my pain away.
I'm so locked in.
Where the fuck is our Venom?
Welcome to my circus.
I've just been getting three plus supports on my team.
What is...
Why...
But all my...
But all of these have been my lobbies.
The last six games.
I don't understand.
Why...
Why do I get...
SK Leary is like, I've never had these lobbies before.
This is my personal circle of hell.
This is my...
This is actually my personal circle of hell.
Hey.
Now you can hear me.
Is my mic working?
Yes.
It doesn't show up on the top left.
That's so weird.
It's a bug.
You need to wait like two seconds for the mic to work.
Did I just say it didn't work?
Wait, is it cutting me off then?
No, no, no.
Where are you?
You just don't see me.
I don't know.
I like playing ranks.
Just not voice chatting.
Unless I'm like locked in.
Because if I voice chat with people in rank, it's just me literally just comming.
Like I don't need...
It's not like entertainment.
Like I don't like play to entertain.
I literally play to...
Play to lock in.
Literally.
Wait, wait, wait.
Alright, I got...
Complat 2.
I do rank.
I was in my personal health.
He's low.
Oh my god.
Okay, nice.
Oh, I missed it!
I win one.
Okay.
How could this be SK's worst lobby?
Like literally my game is her worst lobby.
Like that's actually crazy when you think about it.
I've been playing these lobbies this entire time.
Like it's so crazy to think about because these have only been my lobbies.
So I don't know how...
Oh, this is really bad.
Oh.
Oh no.
No.
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
I literally just got it.
Oh my god.
That was so scary.
Nice one.
Guess I die.
She's dead.
I hope you win with that.
Okay.
Okay, you gotta avoid one of the supports.
This is my avoid list.
It's all Luna one-tricks.
Because I'm a Luna one-trick.
I don't understand how no one...
Okay.
The thing is, chat.
I was talking to one of my friends.
Because they would come and play with me.
When I was, you know, I'm going crazy.
And then I was like...
They were like, how are you having this problem?
I'm always forced to fill as support.
I was like, I wish I have your issue.
Like I...
I wish I have your problem.
Because they're like, that's crazy.
I've never had a case where there's too many support players.
And I'm like, how?
How the fuck?
Yes.
They're now Diamond 3.
I don't understand.
I think they're dual support.
Oh shit.
Are they Moon Luna?
Because...
I...
This is my problem.
I told you.
No, suffer.
I don't fucking care.
I'm done being nice.
You fail.
Oh, that's...
No, I'm not going to be toxic.
Oh, he had 20 hours on her?
I was in fucking alpha, bitch.
I was in fucking alpha.
Were you...
Were you in alpha?
I'm done being nice.
I'm done.
No!
SK, please.
I'm done being nice.
Let them fail.
They can't use that excuse.
I literally...
I was in alpha.
With Luna.
It's fine.
She'll learn.
I had to learn.
It's fine.
Clearly, it's not that difficult.
I...
Okay.
I think they actually refused to heal me out of spite.
There's no way.
I legitimately, like, was fucking alive for five seconds.
It's fine.
I can just avoid them.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my God.
You're just feeding them.
I'm not even gonna go in.
I'm not going in.
I think what's funny is that SK is actually seeing my Tech Cloud lobbies now.
She's like, there's no way.
I...
I don't...
I wish...
I wish I don't have that issue.
What?!
Oh my God.
I even hit her too.
What the fuck?
They actually chased me.
I even used the thing that lets me heal.
Okay.
Oh.
Moon's gonna haunt.
Jesus Christ.
Oh.
This is bad.
This is actually bad.
That's fine.
We're okay.
Yeah, I...
Oh no.
What the fuck?
We can fight this.
That's fine.
We'll fight this.
We can fight this.
I believe.
I believe we can fight this.
Oh no.
This is like Groot now.
They're on Groot now.
I hope...
I hope the Moon Luna avoids me.
So I don't have to waste my avoid slots.
God.
That's really it.
That's all I wish for.
If I'm lucky, she'll avoid me.
Just like how I'm avoiding support players.
Jesus Christ!
Oh no!
No!
Not again!
Oh my god.
No!
Wait.
What?
Why do I have two SKs?
I just noticed that.
I just noticed we have two SKs.
Okay.
We gotta break this.
Guys, we gotta break this if we wanna help each other out.
Oh my god.
Really?
Okay.
It's fine.
We're all gonna be alive, right guys?
Guys.
Yippee!
Being alive is so cool.
Okay, now I have it on the right SK.
I didn't realize there were two SKs.
I literally saw ES and then I assumed that was the right one.
But it wasn't.
Okay.
Alright, maybe I do need circus music at this point.
I think I might need circus music.
Circus music.
Penny is feeding?
No, 100%.
No, I agree.
I wish I could put on a show.
Oh no.
Not the stupid trees.
No!
Sorry!
Oh my god, Fortnite.
You fucking whore!
You whore!
You're so bad!
You didn't wanna die to fucking support!
You're such a whore!
You didn't wanna die to a support, you bitch!
Okay.
Push, push, push, push.
Quinn's right.
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh my god, I can't see shit.
I'm too scared to go through this.
Okay.
It's fine.
We're fine.
I'm perfectly sane right now.
I'm perfectly sane.
Wait, okay, so what did you mean by hero bands?
They're gonna have hero bands?
Oh no, I have to learn another character.
XD
I realized that they're gonna have hero bands just now.
Alright guys, we gotta live here.
We gotta live here.
We gotta...
Okay guys.
The Groot definitely has ult by the way, so...
So this is gonna be interesting.
Okay.
Not again!
Oh my god, it's smart though.
I have to admit, that's incredibly smart to do.
So that you can't have fucking one-tricks, which I...
Why is there...
Oh my god.
Dude, they are duo support!
They actually are!
Oh my god.
Fucking...
Oh my...
Okay, let's learn Mantis.
Let's learn Mantis.
Let's...
We're in.
Bro...
She...
Bro, I'm gonna...
Freaking...
How are these my lobbies?
How have you not encountered any of these lobbies before?
This has been my life.
How?
How has SK not been any...
I swear I'm not toxic.
Proceeds to...
Bro, this bitch doesn't know I've been in close alpha with Luna.
And she's like...
The thing is...
No, the craziest shit for me is that...
Look, I'm at the point where I'm gonna be fucking toxic.
Toxic, no filter.
Because I'm not fucking being nice anymore.
This bitch was like, I have 20 hours on Luna.
Like, bro, and?
Like...
And?
What the fuck is that?
You're flexed?
I have 20 hours.
I'm like, what the fuck is that flex?
Like, what do you want...
What?
What do you want me to say?
Like...
You think you're her just because you have 20 fucking hours on Luna?
Bro, 20 hours is fucking nothing.
How do you think you're her?
Like...
Bro, I'm...
Bro, I don't know what you want from me.
I'm fucking recharging right now.
Bro, I'm not fucking toxic though.
Jesus Christ.
Alright, let's get out of here.
I don't feel safe being here.
Oh my god.
Yeah, the game's been out for five days.
She's got four hours a day.
That's so true.
Bro, I've been playing Marble Rivals four hours a day, bro.
I'm fucking gimping Luna.
Like, holy shit.
That's actually crazy.
I'm not...
I'm actually gonna go unfilter here.
There's no fucking way.
I can't...
I can't handle these players.
I actually cannot.
Oh my god.
Please, be aware of your surroundings.
Okay, I'm all...
I'm gonna all in and swap to Cloak and Dagger.
Bro, I'm hitting four hours a day.
I'm fucking him.
Bro.
Alright.
I can't see shit.
Where are they?
Oh my god.
There we go.
Oh, we ulted.
Don't worry, we're undefeatable.
Oh my god!
How?!
Oh yeah, Luna is going so off.
Alright.
Fell through the map?!
Where is he?
Oh my god.
The...
Holy fuck.
The clown world.
I'm trying to help.
I'm fucking...
I'm fucking losing it.
Eventually.
Oh my god.
Zero, two, three.
You can't.
Oh my god.
See?
Zero death when I main role.
Bro, no one told you to fucking play off role.
Just play three supports if you can't fucking play it.
Holy shit.
Welcome to the circus.
That is Marvel Rivals matchmaking.
Oh my god.
I need...
I need SK to avoid the other Luna player.
No, the other Luna player must have avoided me.
I'm pretty sure.
There's no way.
No, SK needs to restart the game.
Wait, how do I need to close the game?
Yeah, no, SK is restarting.
Oh my god.
I'm on the fucking clown circus.
I need music.
I need like calming music.
Am I winning?
I've had...
I've started having the worst luck possible.
Which is crazy to think about because like...
Like...
Oh, I didn't even like to look at the leaderboards.
What the fuck was the leaderboards?
Not leaderboards.
The statistic.
The history.
Are you fucking serious?
Like...
Oh my god.
I don't understand.
How did SK not encounter any of these logs?
That's literally been like...
That's been like...
Oh my god.
I feel like that's been like 40% of my lobbies.
And then SK being like...
Feeling...
This is the first time I've had a lobby that bad.
There's no fucking way.
I'm like, people can have other lobbies that's not as fucked up as the ones I've...
People actually have real lobbies?
People have real fucking lobbies?
I am losing it.
I am 100% losing it right now.
I'm gonna get background.
I'm actually gonna play with music.
I can't...
I'm at the point where I need like some nice music to make me happy.
I'm pulling out my Minecraft playlist.
You guys know my Minecraft playlist.
It calms me down.
Ba-dump.
Ba-da-da-da-dump.
Ba-dump-bump-bump.
Bum-ba-da-ba.
Bum-ba-da-da-da-dump.
Ba-da-da-da-ba.
That's not working.
Bum-ba-da-dump.
I can't play Duelist.
I'm not at a level.
If I play Duelist, I'm throwing.
Because the other DPS players I'm playing...
The other DPS players I'm playing against are actual DPS players.
Oh my god.
No, okay.
If you guys actually want real...
Okay, I think I might get...
I may or may not get hit by like...
DMCA.
Not DMCA, but my video might get unmonetized, but that's okay.
I think it'll be okay if it gets unmonetized.
That's fine.
Why don't we just listen to this?
For the entire time.
Bum-ba-dump.
What if I just...
Would we all go crazy if I put this on the entire time?
Would we go crazy?
Okay.
How crazy would we get if this was our entire...
Wait.
Bum-ba-dump.
Bum-ba
-dump.
Okay, I got an idea too.
I have an idea.
I think...
I think it's time.
Welcome to the freak show.
Bum-ba-dump.
Bum
-ba -dump.
Bum-ba-dump.
Okay guys, let me pull something up.
Let me pull something up real quick.
Alright, is this the right thing?
Okay.
This is how I feel inside.
I feel like I've hit rock bottom.
I did not know this song has more to it.
This song has so much more- What the fuck?
This song is a lot longer than I expected.
Bum-ba-dump.
It's my nose, guys.
There we go.
I thought this was gonna be a fast stream.
At best it'd be five hours.
Oh my god, there's not enough gamers on anymore.
Bum-ba-dump.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
How is it like this?
Oh.
Oh, we got in.
This is gonna be our music.
I swear, this fucking horror is also a Luna one trick.
I swear to- Oh, thank god.
Okay, there we go.
Alright, I can't- I'm sorry.
I'm at a point where I'm not filtering myself anymore.
I'm too toxic right now.
Okay, we're turning down the music a little bit lower though.
Okay.
I can't.
It's funnier if she suffers.
Wait, please.
Alright.
I'm going insane.
Surefour, I bumped into- I bumped into fucking three, four games in a row where everybody was a support main.
Surefour, I'm fucking going crazy.
I was so- I was so close.
I was so close to top 500, Surefour, you don't understand.
And then I bumped into two Luna one tricks in the last two games.
I had two Luna one tricks and then Surefour, I t-ranked Surefour.
And then I got Asuka to play with me and then she was like, I've never had these pro- She's like, this is the worst lobby I've ever played in.
And I was like, these were like my past six games.
I remember my past six games, Surefour.
She's never experienced my lobbies before.
Our lobbies, you were there.
You had some of some- we had some fucking- fucking shit lobbies today.
Oh my gosh, she's so low though.
That's some sucks.
I'm okay.
Pain drop- pain makes us closer together.
Pain unites us, guys.
Pain makes us better.
It builds character.
You know it.
It's okay.
I'm with you.
You need me.
Oh,
he's fucking dead.
Oh my god, he's sicking.
Woah!
He's also dead!
Let's do it!
That's right!
I'm gonna dance!
All I'm saying is pain brings us closer together.
It makes us stronger as people.
I grow- it's called building character.
We're building so much character right now.
Oh my god, he's so low.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Guys, can you guys kill anything?
That's all I ask for.
You know, fuck that group in particular.
Oh, you thought this was over?
We go again.
What did your first say?
What did he say?
Wow.
Guys, I didn't see what he said.
Bro, that's fucked up, man.
After everything- after all the healing I did for you, that's fucked up.
I literally gave you so much fucking healing, man.
Guys, this is making me a better player.
You guys just don't understand.
See, look at that.
LOL
Yeah, but you were alive to kill everything, surefour.
You were alive so you could kill everything.
Pain builds character to character.
A clown that was wearing Gremlin Tidus, but still.
Yeah, don't forget who- it's Mutual Penis.
Are you happy and you know it?
Clap your hands.
We're back to plat 2, but it's okay.
It just makes me a stronger person.
It makes me a better player than surefour because I've suffered.
I've had character development, he hasn't.
He didn't go through the pain I went through.
Chat is losing it.
It just makes me a better player.
Let's dance.
That's right.
If you suffer with me, then you'd be a better player than me, but you don't.
You don't suffer.
You don't go through my elo hell.
I'm not paying attention anymore.
It's okay, I'm locking in now.
No, that's after this.
I'm locked after my death.
Yeah, but that's League.
This isn't League.
This is Marvel Rival.
It's different.
It's so different.
That's different.
You don't know true suffering in Marvel.
Oh my god, bro.
Poor Gatguy.
That was not intentional.
You know that.
You know that you haven't suffered yet in Marvel Rivals.
You don't know that.
You don't know the pain of having encountered two Luna one-tricks.
Luna one-tricks is like two games in a row.
You've never had to go through that.
You also didn't go through... you also didn't go through...
...three plus support mains in four games in a row.
You haven't gone through that in Marvel Rivals.
You might have gone through that in Overwatch, but not in Marvel Rivals.
Not in Marvel Rivals.
That's different.
Jesus Christ, live.
Fucking live.
Oh my god, how the fuck are you still alive?
Oh my god, he was not living.
Oh no, who is he grunting?
4-0 kills DPS.
You haven't suffered.
You don't know what this is like.
I'm dancing.
I'm gonna dance.
I'm gonna fucking dance and you can't do anything about it.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's working.
The music is working.
Oh my god, who would have thought this was a game?
Who would have thought it's working?
Oh my god, this is the fastest game I've ever found so far.
It's not fair.
Doshir for 9.
I want to get top 500.
It's not fair.
You get to be in top 500.
I did it.
It's not fair.
You got to experience it.
I haven't yet.
I didn't get to experience it.
It's not fair.
Oh my god, I'm getting a chance to walk in the snow.
Okay, I can do this.
Okay,
this is it.
The fuck are they talking about?
It's not me because I'm streaming.
Hahaha.
No one knows who I am.
I'm a nobody here.
I'm a nobody.
No one knows who I am until I put the mask on.
The battle starts in 5... 4... 3...
I want to make a 4-stack.
Imagine.
Imagine if I could make a fucking 4-stack right now.
Okay, I should pay attention now.
I'm gonna pay attention.
I'm gonna pay attention now.
I was not paying attention.
I was actually fucking around.
Okay, focus now for real.
I was just thinking about how easy this game would be if you fucking 4-stacked.
But then I'm a fucking...
Oh my god, please do anything.
Please do anything, my tanks.
Jesus Christ, my tanks.
Oh my god, you guys are not okay.
You guys are definitely not okay right now.
Oh my god, please keep blowing water on me.
Oh no.
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh my god!
Where's my...
Oh, fuck!
Oh, I don't have cover anymore, goodbye!
My cover fucking blew up.
I think we need... I hate playing against Brute.
Okay.
Bro, where do I go?
There was nowhere else to go.
It was...
It was actually... Oh, I'm sorry, bro.
Oh wait, no, I'm not!
I was gonna say you might be dead because fucking Brute.
Okay, there you go.
I'm trying so hard to keep you alive, please.
Please.
He lives!
Okay.
Guys, I think...
I think somebody is underperforming.
And I hope it's not me.
Alright.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Somebody is the weak link here.
And I hope it's not me.
I don't know, maybe you'll live.
Maybe you'll live.
I don't fucking know.
Poor Kinkedus.
Alright.
Time to switch things up.
Holy shit.
Surely it's not me, right?
I don't think so.
I haven't died.
Oh, I did die.
What are two times?
Oh my God.
I don't... I don't... I don't...
Oh no, I'm a full-on Luna 1 trick.
I was planning on learning other characters after, you know, touching top 500 today.
But now I...
I mean, I still will, but like...
I hope I get it today.
Okay.
That's really it.
I do hope it happens today.
Oh no, I was so close too.
That was the... That's the worst part.
When you're like...
So close to it.
And then like you just had such an unlucky streak afterwards.
Oh my God.
That's the worst part, I think.
Oh
my God.
It's just the fucking...
It's the... It's the...
The walls.
We're playing against some really, really good group players too.
That's... Oh my God, how are you dead?
How are you dead?
Okay, you're back.
That's good.
Like, what the fuck?
Oh my God.
Like, what?!
I need to blow my nose.
I ran out of clinics.
I'll be right back.
I ran out of paper... paper...
Clinics and napkins.
I'll be right back.
Oh my God.
The cues are instant though.
That's nice.
No, please.
Okay, I could lock it in before it was too late.
I'm glad she's playing in my hell.
I need people to... What did she say?
I haven't put... I haven't put on my headphones yet.
Now this is our hell.
What does it say?
Is this the twilight zone?
Welcome to my personal twilight zone.
I can get us tank and DPS play...
I told you!
Everyone stacks!
Oh my God.
I told you.
This is why you don't experience my hell.
I solo duel.
It's fucking crazy.
It gives me more chances to fucking suffer.
You're stuck in... You're stuck in my lobbies.
No, you're gonna experience 5am lobbies.
Let's get it.
We suffer.
No, no one escapes.
No one escapes here.
That one hurts.
That was one.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Oh my God.
He was so low.
Will I?
It's too late.
I'm in too deep.
I'm in too fucking deep, guys.
I don't escape the Marvel Rivals play basement.
Yeah.
That's right.
I'm a better player now.
I went through hell.
I'm a better fucking player than all of you.
Like, I built my character.
Okay, like, I don't... I can't fucking save you there.
Like, Jesus Christ.
Alright.
Sorry.
Alright, I'm going to ult in.
Okay, I'm actually going to focus.
Oh.
Oh my God.
Please, get in my... We're going to be doing this.
Oh, I'm scared now.
Because I don't know where that is.
Like, I legitimately don't know.
Oh, this is where I die.
I don't know where that was.
Rocket Raccoon is still alive!
Come to him!
He'll keep you alive!
No, he's hiding.
He's scared.
Oh, they see you, my dude.
No, I got frozen!
No, I couldn't touch it!
It's okay.
We can get it back.
Oh wait, we have a portal.
Oh my God.
Oh, we got off.
Yo, we're back at Plat 2.
Welcome.
Welcome to the circus.
Ba-ba-bam!
I can't hear you.
I don't fucking know.
Why do you recognize that name?
Oh,
what?
They didn't fucking push in yet?
Where the fuck were they?
Oh, he's dead.
That's where they are.
Oh, that's smart.
Wait, these guys are coordinated.
I swear, this is a fucking 6-stack.
Fucking nerds.
Actual nerds are playing 6-stack at this hour.
Just for winning.
Yeah, I know.
Fight!
It's time to dance!
Wa-ha-ha-ha!
Oh, shit.
Nevermind, I don't want to dance anymore.
I don't want to dance anymore.
I
need to cover right here.
Oh, this is bad.
This is real bad.
Oh, what?
Oh my god, even Seer.
Okay, I need to up my game sound.
Sorry, I've been listening to this.
To this BGM.
Oh, he's getting back.
Okay.
Jesus Christ!
Bro, are you okay?
Oh my god, how are you alive?
She is one of the best supports.
Her, Mantis, and Cloaking Dagger.
Let's see.
Let's all hope you all live.
Let's hope you live, guys.
Let's hope you live.
Let's hope you fucking live, guys.
Let's see.
Let's hope you all live, you all live!
Congratulations.
Oh...
Let's go!
You're right.
You know what?
I'm gonna heal you anyway, bitch.
Oh my god!
Let's just...
fuck everybody, I guess.
Jesus Christ, like...
Um...
What do you mean?!
I ulted...
What?!
I ulted so much!
Oh my god!
I used my ult to save them so many times and they don't even realize.
You guys have no aura, no presence.
It's not the support's fault.
I can't tell if it's actually their fault or not.
It's just the troll's.
Bro, like, what?!
Please...
How is it my fault?!
Wait, bro, you guys are not taking the trade.
Oh, just because I didn't have ult for like all the fucking aggressive ults.
Was that RIP?
Oh, RIP isn't safe.
What?!
How the fuck is it my fault?!
How the fuck?!
Literally, like...
All I did...
I can't believe it.
I literally Luna ulted every aggressive ult I see.
But, like, the one time I didn't have a Luna ult.
Like...
The one time I didn't have a Luna ult.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
If I have ult every fucking...
Oh, I'm sorry.
Let me have ult for five different aggressive aggression ults.
Like...
Why is...
Why does my ult have a fucking cooldown?
Good fucking question.
Why...
Oh my god.
Yeah,
why did I decide to have, like...
If only I could, like, fucking Luna ult every, like, fucking...
Every...
fucking three...
Oh my god, I can't even word anymore.
This guy actually tilted me so hard.
Like, legitimately?
That guy?
That was like...
Why don't you... Have we never had a Luna ult?
That guy actually tilted me so hard.
Like, I've never been that tilted before.
I've actually never been that tilted before.
That shit, like, actually fucked me up.
Every Luna ult I did was an aggression.
Like, was a defensive ult.
Like, holy fuck.
That guy belongs in plat.
Yeah, I hope he never gets top 500.
Holy fuck.
I can get this whenever.
I just want it fast.
That's the only reason why I'm trying to get it now.
You have to have a spider weapon.
Bro, please.
Please help.
Please help him.
Oh my god.
I can't help him anymore.
I can't.
This is my circus.
I literally pocketed this guy so hard.
No, I have.
I'm fucking going crazy.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I don't think we fight that anymore.
Magneto, please.
Please.
Oh my god.
Yay!
We're gonna do this.
Oh my god.
Not him again.
I'm just trying to make sure our fucking Magneto doesn't fucking die because he's not having it right now.
He really isn't.
He's not having it.
Bro.
Jesus Christ.
Nice.
I almost died to that.
Oh my god.
I don't know what you want from me.
I don't.
I'm dead.
Surefour, please.
Surefour, I'm suffering right now.
Oh my god.
I brought Esky down into my fucking hell.
She's never experienced my lobbies before.
She's actually never been this tilted before because of...
She's never been this tilted before.
She's never had to go through what I went through.
Surefour.
If you didn't stop, we would've avoided all of this.
If you stayed for one more hour, we could've avoided all of this.
Surefour, come on.
Get over here.
You know you want to.
You know you wanna be here.
Come on.
It's a party.
You know you want to.
You wanna join this party, don't you?
This is peak hours right here.
Peak gaming hours.
What the fuck?
Okay, I got him.
I got him.
Oh, I...
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
Are you guys okay?
I don't think they're okay.
Okay.
Alright.
Jesus Christ.
What's going on in my lobby?
Like, what's going on?
Good shit.
Please.
Oh my god.
He's literally one.
I think I got a headshot.
Oh, nevermind.
That's good.
There we go.
I'm still here.
I'm still here, guys.
I'm not going in there.
I don't want him to gen me.
Okay, now the goal is to get plat one back.
Bro!
Like, holy shit!
Bro, I can't outheal all that!
That's way too much!
There was no way I could heal all that.
I'm sorry, SK, that brought you to my circus.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry I had to be in the circus.
You gotta save your fucking KD?
I...
Oh my god!
I gotta save my fucking KD?
Did I heard that correctly?
Oh my god.
Surefour, get in here, Surefour.
I'm gonna fucking spam you on Discord.
What do you say?
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Yo, fuck you!
Actually!
Oh my god!
I did not say it was nothing, Surefour.
I said you can't compare, cause you haven't gone through Marvel Rivals, babe.
You haven't gone, you can't Q snipe, you're in Diamond!
You fucking idiot, you can't Q snipe!
We're getting plat lobbies, you have to be in plat!
You fucking idiot!
Get in here.
Oh my god.
Bro!
Oh my god!
Did we not avoid?
Oh my god, we should have avoided one!
Oh my god.
Oh my... no, bro, I give up.
Fuck you, okay.
Let's run three supports, let's go.
Actually, yeah.
Oh my god.
Okay, we gotta avoid one of them.
We gotta avoid one of them.
One of them.
I used up all my...
all my avoid slots.
Okay.
Fuck it.
Alright, we made a deal.
Surefour will join, but he gets to play Wolverine.
I'm...
That's fine.
That's fucking fine.
I'm okay with that compromise.
Oh my god.
I'm okay.
I'm okay with that.
No, Surefour, you said it.
Get on.
I'm gonna tell SK to be part of the circus.
I don't care anymore.
Playing Overwatch, guys.
It's okay.
We got this.
It's fine.
Is the team of Ashley good?
Am I healing?
I can't tell.
I can't tell if it's doing anything.
No!
Oh, it got cancelled.
Nice.
Alright.
Don't Q yet.
Don't Q.
Wait.
Alright.
Come on.
Get in.
I'm waiting.
Wait.
The music stopped.
Hello?
You're suffering.
Yeah?
Come on.
Let's go.
Where's the self-harm tag?
Come on.
I'm already in too deep.
Might as well.
I want you to play Wolverine.
I might as well.
At least you have hands.
You on Wolverine...
You on Wolverine is better than 80% of the players I just got in the last three hours.
Hawkeye isn't even enough.
It's okay.
It's alright.
We're all just gonna suffer together.
You are not picking Luna!
You're not fucking picking Luna!
Surefire!
We agreed!
We agreed on this!
You're not picking Luna!
I literally went through eight hours of Oh my god.
It's been nine hours.
I've been playing I've been playing nine hours.
You're not picking Luna.
There's no fucking way you're picking Luna.
There's no fucking way.
Oh my god.
There's no way.
We're suffering together.
Alright.
I'm getting SK in this VC.
I'm getting SK in here.
To maintain a fair gaming environment and verify misconduct, voice chats are subject to recording.
Creating a group chat.
Okay.
He's not picking Luna!
I'm picking Luna.
He is not.
I'm the Luna now.
Guys.
SK, how are you enjoying the circus?
What the fuck is happening?
How much do you value your rank right now?
It's already chopped.
I didn't answer the question.
Zero.
I'm picking Wolverine.
You on Wolverine is better than every single person we've gotten so far.
I've never had lobbies this bad in my life.
You don't know pain.
This is like oh my
You gotta carry.
I am carrying, that's the crazy part.
If you're losing, then you're not carrying, right?
Not hard enough.
You have to carry the world on your back.
I'm 1v3 in DPS.
I don't know what's happening.
You don't understand.
We were up 6v4 and everyone was just standing in spawn and I had to yell at them to push.
These people don't play Overwatch.
I'm picking Luna.
You're picking Wolverine.
You're fine.
Pick Luna.
It's fine.
If you're faster than me.
We were losing so hard and then finally when we had a chance to win, our Dr. Strange got stuck under the map and we were 5v6.
The Curse of Ra worked.
He literally cursed us.
You don't know the Curse of Ra?
I know the Curse of Ra.
The Curse of Rod.
He fucking cursed me.
He was like, I hope you get into loser queue.
That's right.
I don't know where she is, bro.
Should've been faster.
Pick Wolverine.
Don't be a pussy.
Play Wolverine.
You want me to play Wolverine?
Yeah, do it.
Don't be a fucking pussy.
I ain't fucking shit.
Shit.
Oh my god, as long as you get flamed and I don't, that's fine with me.
I don't get flamed.
You're gonna get flamed because you're gonna be on Wolverine.
Nah, I hard carried that one game as Wolverine.
What about the other game?
You didn't heal me enough.
Oh, yeah, yeah, this fucking orb that's on you 24-7 is not enough healing.
It wasn't enough.
Wait, do we have...
Oh, wait, we do.
We have Doctor Strange.
And we have Tank.
Guys, now that there's three of us, that means we have nine avoid slots.
Nah, you two are cooked right now.
Oh, no.
You guys are already mentally cooked.
No, no, I'm not.
I'm cooking.
I'm locked in.
You're locked in?
I'm so locked in.
Pick me up, bro.
Pick me up.
Yeah.
Launch me in, motherfucker!
I'm going in deep!
That's one!
You have so much energy for 6am.
Motherfucker, I drank a coffee.
Why did you drink coffee?
Yo, where's my heals?
Oh, what do you mean?
You had an orb.
Where my heals at?
There's three of me in the back.
I can't help you, SK.
I'm sorry.
Yo, no fucking yeet me.
Yo, Hulk, come back here.
Throw me.
Throw me, motherfucker.
Yeet me in.
Put me in, coach.
Okay.
I'm coming back.
You're not getting heals if you're so far.
You're not getting heals.
Heal me.
Get closer, SK.
Give me the orb.
I need a healing.
Alright, we're fine.
This is the circus.
I love the circus.
I'm in the back line.
Oh, they're chasing you.
They are chasing you.
That is not my fault.
I needed healing there.
I gave you so much healing.
That could be possible.
Oh my god, they're gonna...
They're gonna use the eye of something and then we're gonna be fucked.
There we go.
I called it.
Putting a show.
You're getting as much heals as I can give you.
I'm surviving.
I'm not.
Don't worry, I almost have bonkai.
Wait, just...
Isn't this your first ult?
Yeah.
Okay.
We have two fights left.
You know what?
I hope we de-rank sure for two.
So I can get it back.
Oh,
that is not good.
I got an ult out.
Wait, did you not ult?
Oh my gosh.
What happened?
Everyone's died.
The other team is extremely powerful.
Wait a minute.
He's gonna crash out.
He's gonna...
I think...
Oh!
The Hawkeye swap.
I have to go bonkai mode.
You have to.
This time, we gotta fucking go in though soon.
Oh, that was one.
But you'll be fine, right?
Here, now hit this guy.
Oh my god.
I got it.
The eye is here.
Guys, I think Wolverine is a bad character.
I need healing.
Oh my god.
You're fine.
Who would have thought?
Wolverine is just...
It's not a good character.
You're lucky I like winning more than trolling.
I wouldn't have any other way to show for it.
My winner's spirit took over.
I can't believe the only Canadian character is the worst DPS.
He's Canadian?
Yes, he's Canadian!
You're Canadian!
I don't know anything about fucking superheroes, bro.
Okay, that doesn't mean I know every Canadian in existence.
You should know every famous Canadian as a Canadian.
Yeah, I know.
Alright, goodbye.
Oh my god.
I guess I die?
Blank kite!
Aimbot arrow.
We're dead.
We're all dead.
And you're dead too.
Why is he dead?
You literally ulted when we all died.
Ice shooting arrow!
And team dying.
Ah, she-bear.
Okay.
I'm not cut out for this life.
The hella life.
What are you on hella?
I don't know.
I'm desperate.
You're a meta slave.
You're a meta slave, but yet you don't play hella.
Play magic, don't be a coward.
Magic is ass.
Alright.
Oh my god.
I'm scared now.
I-oh my god.
I just needed one little touch.
Of heals.
That's okay, we have like two more fights.
We have one fight left.
What the fuck?
Fucking, our Magneto is fucking crazy.
He got a kill though.
I have ult here.
I'm gonna wait until I hear the I of whatever.
Okay, nevermind, I'll do it here.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, you guys.
He's gonna use the I.
For the last fight.
There it is.
Who would've thought he was gonna use it.
Wow, he did it.
Let's change this one.
I'm gonna reload.
It's winnable.
Please, someone kill this Loki.
That's right here.
Oh no, it's not anymore.
Unless...
Why am I deflecting not working?
Not another I.
How did he do that again?
Alright guys, we can defend this, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Nah.
It's okay.
Back to Wolverine.
You're gonna make Fabian man fucking cry.
Yeah, but if he crashes out, it's funny.
He's like asking if someone else I don't get it.
Like, I don't know what that even means.
Like, what does that even mean?
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
It's fine.
My girlfriend says she loves you, Doki Bird.
This is an escape, by the way.
Best fucking life.
They're like saying there's no way that's it.
Look up there, Vaan.
Not there.
Yes!
Bro.
Don't worry, Lady Sapphire is saving you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
She's saving you.
Your reputation is safe, SK.
It's only my reputation that's getting dragged.
No, I'm 10-4.
I'm juicing.
I'm the ace.
There's no loose streak that can ever affect me.
Ever.
I've been through the pits of hell and back.
I stared into the abyss and I crawled out.
Yeah, they are.
I was like, bro, that sounds like something that's gonna fuck us up.
That's crazy, though, that he was like, that's not...
What are they doing over there?
I got you.
Double K.O.
Yay, double K.O.
Yay.
Wait, there's more people over there?
It's only a knockout, not a kill, because heroes never die.
There's a person over there, too.
Guys, I think we got a touchdown point.
Oh my god.
What is going on on my screen?
Why are they able to just run me down?
I may have died.
I may have done a little bit of dying.
Uh oh.
Oh no, now we have one.
Oh my god, what?
Our team's crashing out.
This shit is over.
Which...
Which part caused the crash?
Surefour on Wolverine?
Or everything else that happened?
It's gotta be my hello scoreline.
Where do you think was his fucking breaking point?
By the way,
I'm just curious where his breaking point was.
I got the double support ult out.
What do we do now?
We have nobody...
What do we do?
I love...
This is the actual escape.
Oh my god.
SK, are you enjoying this?
Yeah.
Are you happy that I got invited you back into the Marvel?
I'm really happy I'm up at 6am for this.
Yeah.
There's nothing I'd rather be doing.
Guys, I love...
I love Marvel Rivals.
Wolverine.
Marvel Rivals is so fun, guys.
Guys, lock the freak in.
I am locked in!
I literally have the most healing out of both teams.
What have you been doing?
I had like 11 final blows.
Okay, SK, what about you?
I'm locked in.
You're locked in?
You guys better be locked in, guys.
Give us Wolverine.
Unless you're a fucking pussy.
I am what I eat.
Which is?
Pussy.
This is fine.
This is so fine.
It's awesome time.
I believe in us.
What can go wrong?
What could possibly go wrong?
We only have one healer.
This is seeming like a problem.
Guys, it's okay.
I can heal all of us.
It's okay.
I think maybe we're adding another loss to the board.
The sooner we win, the sooner I can go to sleep.
Maybe we're losing the gaming.
SK, you're gonna leave after one win?
You're gonna leave?
You're gonna leave after one win?
Maybe we get another loss on the board?
What if we just keep losing so she'll never leave?
I like losing.
Very poggers.
Maybe we're doing a little bit of losing.
Maybe we do need another healer.
Guys, I just need to know if I die, it's over.
Don't freaking die.
It's easy.
It's fine.
They got a fucking Wolverine.
They got Wolverine and it's so over but he's angry.
It's so over.
It's hard.
They have two healers.
Two healers?
How do they have two healers?
I see.
They're fucking cheating.
They're cheating.
We have one.
They should also have one.
There's no way.
It's moving fast.
She gets healing.
Here's a concept for you.
If you're a healer, you don't have to heal.
You don't have to be healed.
Then I have to heal fucking scrubs.
Oh, SK's a scrub?
Yeah.
I am not a scrub.
I'll have you know.
SK, why have you been winning?
This is the fake SK, remember?
Oh, yeah.
I'm an impersonator.
Real SK who plays video games for money would never be bad.
He would never have a bad game.
Bad games happen.
That's fucking life.
Guys, the moment they use a DPS ult, we're fucking dead.
Oh, there it is.
There's the DPS ult.
Guys, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
Support's dead.
It's only Hella.
Kill the Hella.
Oh, no.
Not Jensen.
Guys, I'm coming back.
My queen, Seraphine.
Oh, god, I'm fucking... I'm keeping you alive.
No, no, no.
Dude, they're 4 DPS now.
They're 4 DPS!
Oh, god, Groot is...
Groot's not having it.
It must have been 4 DPS that fight too, right?
Because they have... Wait, I'm so confused.
No, they saw our comp and was like, if they can do that, we can do that too.
2-2-2 is overrated.
Yeah, 2-2-2 is fucking stupid.
We're not Overwatch, we're Marvel rivals.
He's trying to steal me!
Help!
Oh, my god.
I killed him, I killed him, I killed him.
Thank you, thank you.
Are you alive?
He tried to fucking abduct me, bro.
We got fucking kidnapped.
One fear.
They are flanking!
Flanking left!
Oh, Penny, please.
I'm one support.
Oh, no.
Please, stand in a line.
So I can get all of you.
She hit me with a thumb!
Oh, my god, help!
How do I follow this?
It's because of my fucking aura.
He saw me play Wolverine and said, watch me.
And now it's my turn.
I'll show him how it's fucking done.
Oh, shit!
He went Hulk for you!
Throw me in.
He's going Hulk for you.
Oh, no.
It's over for them.
Okay.
How can they stand up to this?
Wolverine-san.
What are you gonna do now?
They're broken.
Let's go!
I don't know what to do.
Oh, my god.
He's gonna throw you like a baseball.
Hulk 2 on that thing.
Oh, he's going on the right side.
Of all the games we played today, this is the game we win?
I can't.
No way.
I gotta throw now.
I can't let this be my legacy.
It's because our teammates finally have aura.
You see this guy?
His name is Thanos Aura.
Oh, that's true.
Our teammates didn't have aura until now.
Oh, but he's the one that's not coming with us.
He's leaving.
He's looking at Google Maps.
Get him!
Dude, he sucks at throwing!
I got hit.
I don't know.
Surefour didn't dive anybody and I got dived.
He threw me.
Move in and fight!
He's won!
Oh my god.
You didn't even kill the Wolverine.
His passive proc.
What do you want from me?
You have the same passive.
Yeah, he ran away.
There he is.
Move in and fight!
I win!
You died!
Why my Wolverine blood not protect me from shotgun?
You're right.
You have the fucking bones.
It lives through that.
We win.
The better Wolverine wins.
That can't be the last game.
Time to queue some more Wolverine.
Yeah, those are some bad...
He knows it.
That was a bad throw.
I'm not gonna lie.
Wolverine dip.
The Wolverine dip, yeah.
The last streak is broken now.
Now this is where the win streak starts, right?
Curse of Ra.
The curse has been broken.
No more Curse of Ra.
I can make this curse whenever I want.
No, no, no, no.
The curse is broken now.
I'm not trapped with you.
You guys are trapped with me.
No, no, no, no.
My rank means nothing to me.
He's holding us hostage, guys.
He's holding us hostage.
What do we do?
There's nothing we can do, I just realized.
Alright, guys.
I'll add the foogie in.
I have to log in to my Discord.
And that's why there was no foogie chat.
Oh, there it is.
What's a foogie?
Oh, it's like the Discord thing that lets people know.
I'm so fucking bouncy.
Yeah, it lets people know who I'm playing with on Discord.
Oh my god.
Whose internet is that shitty?
Whose internet is it?
It's on the Samsung smart fridge.
I'm sorry.
It's got a wood PC.
Fuck you.
Whoa, hey, whoa.
Yeah, I'm saying it.
Yeah, what you gonna do about it, huh?
Pick Wolverine.
Oh, is that a threat?
I'm so scared.
I have to give it to him.
Where the fuck is the name?
Why is it not showing?
Oh, it is.
It's just really tiny.
It's fisting time.
Huh?
Oh my.
What do you mean by that?
I'm the Iron Fist.
Oh.
It's fisting time.
You're gonna punch people?
I'm gonna fist them.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
Guys, you see the names now.
Now you know who I'm playing with.
SK has so many fans and Marvel's rivals.
Yeah, where's our fans?
Nobody recognized you, Surefour.
Yeah, I don't give a fuck.
I don't give a fuck.
Tekken Icon!
Wait, it's not even the real SK.
You're right.
I'm an impersonator just farming.
Farming compliments.
You please.
Yeah, this is why you gotta impersonate people.
You get to feel good about yourself.
Someone stole my fucking name.
Who the fuck took Yazdaskafraz from me, bro?
No way someone took that.
Yeah, they fucking took that, bro.
They took fucking Yazdaskafraz from me, bro.
That's the weirdest name to take.
Out of all of them.
Get the fuck over here.
Get in there, SK.
Get in there.
Gonna taste my venom.
Venom, venom, venom.
Nice.
19 inches of venom.
Ooh.
High five.
This is it.
I'm baiting, I'm baiting.
I'm healing!
Oh my god, she's dead!
We're dead!
I thought you were gonna block.
I blocked the damage for SK.
You did not block.
I got hit with the thong.
You didn't block for me.
Okay, we might troll there.
Ouch.
Wait, take a little damage so I can heal Surefour.
No, it's okay.
Nevermind, it's fine.
Oh, oh, oh.
Awkward.
Oh, I'm taking damage.
He's dead, he's dead already.
They blocked my shit.
I was gonna 2v1, bro.
You win that if it's won.
Oh my god!
Okay, there's a Black Panther behind us.
I'm baiting them in.
I went the wrong way.
Alright, I'm coming over.
Got my one.
Yeah, but you're all gonna die.
Unless...
Surefour, I need you to...
Surefour, what the fuck are you...
Okay.
Noob, noob, noob.
I was healing.
I need a healing.
Wait, I have Bankai.
But they have their ults.
Alright, here we go.
Oh shit.
Okay, I'm going to go in.
Here we go.
Alright.
That's one!
I am...
Oh, uh oh.
I'm leaving in four seconds.
I'm leaving now.
I left.
Please.
No!
I needed you to fucking spit on me, Jeff!
Oh, ow.
That's a 2v2.
Uh oh.
I believe in you guys.
I'm literally coming back.
Let's do more.
Oh my god.
We have one more fight.
Okay.
I'm fine.
If you guys want to know, I'm okay.
Alright.
Oh shit.
I got you.
Surefire, I got you.
Alright, 90.
Oh my god, but who's got me?
Okay.
Oh no, Venom!
No, no, no, no!
I'm stuck!
Ow.
Venom's coming over, guys!
He's dead.
Where the fuck did she go?
Oh, she invised.
Oh my god, we're alive!
Yeah, because I fucking clutched out.
They call me the king.
Alright, SK, who actually clutched it?
That was all our health.
What the fuck?
I touched point!
We have a lot!
My bad, actually.
Knock on me.
Oh, I'm in there.
You're in there?
I'm doing it.
Oh, I'm not doing it anymore.
I got you!
Oh shit, I left!
I got scared.
We win this.
SK, get in here!
Oh my god, my savior.
You're okay!
My hero, Academia.
We're okay!
Everything is working out!
Who's next?
Come on, I did it first!
Oh shit!
We're okay.
How did we win that point?
You're talking to golden limbs.
Why?
Because I clutched out!
I already said it!
Oh shit, sorry guys!
For your ears, guys, sorry!
The scoreboard doesn't lie, I'll admit.
That's so true.
He's beast moding right now, chat.
He's full on.
Just wait until I have my Bonkai.
Oh my god.
Caffie is kicking in hard.
I'm beating the shit out of this fucking wall.
Oh, he's TPing, he's TPing!
I'm gonna tell my team I'm gonna TP one day and just sit there and see how long they'll wait.
You do that in Grandmaster.
Oh, I'm dead.
Wait, what happened?
Oh my god, I might be dead too, I'm going back in!
Oh, I got scared!
Oh, he's coming, he's coming!
I'm beating the shit out of him!
I'm dead.
Everything is fine.
The panther is low.
I'm not fine, I'm not fine.
Oh wait, our strange is still alive!
Wait, they're voring?
It's a vortex?
Oh, Jeff.
That's my goat.
He's only killed one, but that's okay.
I got double solo ulted!
My space is immaculate!
Hey, he's my fucking space, guys, I got fucking solo ulted.
Hey!
He's won, he's won, he's won!
Hey, we did it.
It's okay, we should regroup now.
I'm coming back in, no one's gotten the point yet.
I'm contesting.
Contesting!
Oh my god, dude, he's ulted.
We were so chilling.
That was a sacrifice of my life, win the fight.
Now.
There's a tree in front of me!
Win the freaking fight now!
Yeah!
We won the fight!
I died, there's a fucking hello right behind us.
I'm beating her ass.
Hey, you think you can run?
Wait, guys, Jeff is...
Is currently, you know...
Oh my god!
You solo ulted me, bitch!
I have the power of god on my side!
Go, fucking fight!
Go!
I solo ulted to save your fucking life!
You better kill somebody!
I'm out of this, bitch.
Bro, their whole team's here, I can't do shit.
We're all, we're here!
I can't believe you didn't kill anybody.
I'm beating the shit out of this tree!
I can't believe you didn't kill anyone!
I can't believe!
It's fine, we got 48%.
I believe in us.
There's a black panther here.
Kill him.
I'm scared.
I'm gonna burn all trees.
Oh my god!
Avenged.
He's low, he's low!
I'm beating the shit out of this tree!
Who's next?
I'm coming!
Out of the air!
Just live, just live!
Supports are here now.
I'm micro fracturing my fists.
Don't worry.
I got you, you got orb now.
You're free to go wherever you want.
Oh my god.
This guy is just fucking...
Shooting me from like that.
My ultimate ability.
Nice, there's a black panther behind you!
He's so low!
I got my one!
Me too!
I'm putting on a show as well, watch me dance!
I'm beating the shit out of this mantis!
Do it, do it!
Where was my luna ult at?
You were definitely not on it.
You were definitely not on the luna ult.
That's for sure.
It's okay, we have hell ult.
That's the game changer.
The eye of agamotto is almost charged.
I got my one!
I'm going in!
I need help.
The mantis is low.
I'm just saying, we healed you.
We 100% healed.
I made the space.
Oh yikes.
Please don't turn around!
She's one.
Help please!
Oh my god, our health is so stuffed!
Wait, it's winnable.
She solo ulted me again bro!
You got double solo ulted.
I blocked the group ult.
I might be dead though.
No!
Oh wait, winnable.
You have shark, you have to rely on the shark.
Our hella is not a person.
She is absolutely helper.
She helper.
I clutched out.
Wait, we lost?
They have it!
Sheeper.
He had the point!
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm just saying, our hella is not good at...
I'm gonna say it, I hope he watches the stream so he knows he's bad at hella.
And sees what, saw what I saw in that POV.
That's why I said it.
He's the number one Doki Red fan.
He's been looking up to you for so long.
Never meet your heroes.
Uh oh.
Alright, here we go.
It's awesome time.
I'm feeling awesome.
I believe in us.
Oh, he's on Hawkeye, he wants to win.
Mmm...
I'm gonna shoot my funny little arrows.
Your silly little guy abilities.
Please.
Oh my god!
This Psylocke is really low.
No, Dr. Strange, please.
He's bringing them to you!
No!
Yes!
I killed their tank.
That Psylocke is low, that Psylocke is low.
I distracted their supports to make that happen.
That's what I did.
What the fuck is this Pog?
What?
I hit her shadow, but she went from 1 HP to literally full health.
But then they also Luna ulted, so...
Alright, I Luna ulted too.
Guys, they have point, guys.
This fucking passive doesn't do jack shit!
I think we lost this point, guys.
Deflect projectiles my ass!
Oh my god!
This one ain't looking good, squad.
Oh, they used their big ultimates.
They only have small ones.
They saved multiple ults for me.
What can you do?
You know what that means?
It's time to pull out.
Wolverine?
I was thinking Winter Soldier, but you know what?
Winter Soldier is even worse if they save ults for me.
No, no, if you do it again 6 times, you are behind a tree, by the way.
They locked you up.
Yeah, fuck it, bro.
Doctor Strange is on the point.
Wait, they got 2?
Oh, SK got 2?
Yep.
I'm dead.
Oh, I saw that.
That's pretty cool.
I got my 2.
The portal just disappeared in front of my screen.
I got my 3.
There is a shark at the bottom?
Alright, now is our time.
We're going to reversal it right here.
Oh,
they're all left side.
They're coming for you.
He's boring.
He's boring?
Oh, okay.
Oh my gosh.
He did it.
He got 3.
Wait, there's so many outside.
I can't help it.
Yeah, I can.
I got one.
Nice, nice, nice.
Epic.
Oh, I accidentally fell down.
I didn't realize the hole was up.
Alright.
Uh oh, time against the world.
I don't remember what that hole is.
Someone needs to take care of this.
I'm the person for the job.
Can you try to help Doctor Strange?
Watch out for that black panther behind.
Alright, she's dead.
Get the tree, get the tree, burn the tree!
Easy.
So easy.
Alright, they have like 5 ults.
It's fine, I have one Luna ult and that will deny every ult they have.
This guy has been holding Doctor Strange ult for the whole game.
Look, he's waiting for the perfect moment.
This is gonna be the perfect moment.
Just wait and see.
Just you wait.
I'm dead.
No you're not.
He's won.
I have forced the Luna Snow ultimate ability.
I got a no reg.
Have you tried not doing that?
They forced my Luna Snow ult too because of Doctor Strange.
Oh, he used it, he used Doctor Strange ult!
He used it!
I got hard focused by Swag.
Oh no, I am Groot.
No!
I got Hella ulted!
That's fucking life, isn't it?
Wait, can we still touch it?
Wait, we have another fight.
Not really.
I mean, I can touch.
I'll touch Jeff, don't worry about it.
You can use your ult.
Are you touching?
I'm touching.
I'm so dead.
I got solo ulted again.
Oh my god.
Jeff, where's Jeff?
No, Jeff got solo ulted too!
He got ulted!
It's not our fault.
It was not our fault.
Like, look.
SK got ace.
I'm the ace.
Yeah, I don't think it was an us issue.
I think like...
Um...
Oh shit, the Hella has 50 kills.
It was on Hella, so you can like have that.
You know, since we lost, we can't end it on a loss now.
Yeah, we can't.
You're right.
I feel like I'm being held hostage.
Now you feel like you're being held hostage.
Last one, for sure.
Last one?
Yeah, gotta be.
Oh shit, that's the people that think you're not real.
We used the bathroom.
Oh no.
The people that know I'm not real.
Oh, we got a good game ahead of us here.
Yeah?
Think so?
Yeah, we were locking for DPS for a second.
Oh, that means everyone's a good player.
Woah, woah, woah, woah.
She went squirrel girl.
I don't like that.
Wait, we have the person that thought I'm fake on our team.
I thought she was on the other team.
Oh no, she's leaving spawn as squirrel girl.
Disaster.
I'm worried.
I'm concerned.
Nah.
It'll be fine, surely.
Surely.
I need to prove to her that the fake SK can get some kills.
I realized we're defending.
I thought we were attacking.
Uh oh.
It's okay, you guys don't need Luna until later anyway.
We have to go through stuff anyway.
Okay, I was there.
That's not me issue right there.
Our healers are already dead.
I'm right here.
Well shit.
Oh, I need help though.
Guys, I don't...
Oh my god, I can't.
It's Spiderman.
It's fine, we're fine.
Awesome.
He's frozen.
Oh, I might be dead from that.
Yeah, that's not awesome at all.
Nope.
Guys, I have a Venom blocking me right now.
Venom!
Just politely ask him to move.
I'm sure he'll listen.
He seems nice.
Guys, I need...
We need help.
I'm almost here.
I can touch the point.
Sure, forcibly getting healed from my excess healing from other stuff.
Oh, it's Jover.
Oh, I couldn't press Q!
It's never been more Jover.
Oh my god, I tried to press Q.
Oh, Spidey's one.
He has no extra, excess heal, Venom.
Venom has no excess heal.
Oh!
I'm gonna use my ultimate ability soon.
Yippee!
Oh shit!
Here we go.
Awesome!
You're fine.
You're so fine.
We got Venom.
There's Spider-Man.
He's fine.
Spider-Man is super...
He's dead.
Super one.
When do I heal again?
Oh, that's fine.
I died.
Is he ready to put on a show?
Okay.
You guys gotta stop.
Stop what?
You guys gotta stop the fucking double ult there.
Jesus Christ!
Oh, Venom's low.
Yeah, he is.
Okay, he has...
Lucio beat it for us.
Oh no!
Oh my god, please.
I need transcendence.
Oh no, we need another transcendence.
Please!
I'm kidding.
I broke their respawn thingy.
I got my one.
We're coming back now.
It ain't looking good for me back here.
That's fine.
Lady Sapphire has...
This is not fine because...
Oh shit, it's again!
Don't worry, I clutched out.
It's whatever.
Yeah, don't worry.
I try not to make a big deal out of it or anything.
It's whatever.
I thank God that we got two tanks and that's why we're able to stabilize.
Yeah, awesome.
Thank God.
Shout out Lady Sapphire.
Yeah, shout out to Lady Sapphire for saving that game.
Wait, what about shout out me?
I thought you said it was nothing.
No, I was trying to be nonchalant about it.
I was trying to be nonchalant about it.
So you're not helpful at all.
There's a chill guy that just wants a little bit of praise every now and then.
Alright, you did a good job.
That doesn't mean anything anymore.
Oh shit, that's too real.
I'm a sad guy.
You need a lot of praise.
I'm ultimating.
I messed up really bad.
It did not work.
Oh, nice.
Perhaps...
You Roadhogged him.
There's a Hella behind you guys.
Why?
Why did he do that?
Alright, no more dancing.
Dancing's over.
Magneto is quite low on health points.
Oh dear.
He's dead.
Nice, he's gone.
I think our Venom might be dead.
That's another day for a chill guy like you.
Yeah, it's whatever.
It's whatever.
I just killed Magneto.
He's nothing, right?
He's supposed to counter my bullets and shit.
I'm fucking Bucky.
I'm the Winter Soldier.
I love him.
Aren't you going to be the new Captain America soon?
Huh?
I thought that was that other guy that's becoming Captain America.
Isn't there like a...
At one point, Bucky becomes Captain America.
I don't know anything about superhero movies.
I watched the Avengers movie.
I know like in the movies, yeah, but I know in the comic books he becomes Captain America at one point.
Oh my god, how?
Oh, hello.
Thank you.
I broke the respawn.
Nice.
We're all dead.
That's not awesome.
That's not, yeah.
That's not really awesome.
He also walled us off.
You put three trees.
What do I do, Surefour?
It could be worse.
Oh.
It's going to be fine, right?
We win that one.
Yep, always.
Just another day for a chill girl like me.
Oh, good.
You're all so healthy.
I'm literally watching all your HP being super fucking healthy.
I'm farming.
Alright, let's spawn, Captain.
Fuck it, let's roll.
Hella's wa-uh-ful.
Yeah, Hella went back into her spawn.
That seems right.
Oh no.
I don't feel so good.
It's okay.
He can't again us.
He can't again us, guys.
I did it, I saved us.
Okay, I got you guys.
Excellent.
I don't know who has Venom, though.
Oh, nice.
That's my goat.
Oh, what the fuck?
Don't get real firepower.
Oh, I have to reload my hands, sorry.
Oh, I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead.
No heals.
No problem.
I thought you said there's no problem.
It's okay.
We have Surefour's ult.
He's gonna go again.
I have an orb on you.
There's an orb on you.
He didn't go again.
I have to bide my time.
I must have my ultimate again.
Get shit on!
Nice.
This might be it.
Oh, shit!
How did none of them die there?
Are you serious?
Jesus!
Holy shit!
I knew I should have fucking trusted only myself.
I did not say you can do it now!
I said you have it.
I didn't encourage anything.
Now I'm not saying you.
I have ult.
I'm doing it.
It's okay, SK is here to make up for it.
I died.
They're all dead.
It's fine.
You did what you needed to do.
I sacrificed myself.
What time do y'all usually go to bed?
That's a good question.
Like 6am.
So you still have another hour?
No, it's 5.30.
You still have another hour?
Half an hour.
What's another hour more?
The sun's about to rise over here.
That's crazy.
Wait, but you just had coffee.
That wasn't me, that was him.
Yeah, I know, I'm saying Surefour.
Didn't Surefour just have coffee?
Yeah, so you're gonna go to bed after?
I sleep better if I have shit before bed.
Wait, really?
Caffeine?
Yeah.
That's the opposite of what caffeine does.
No.
You guys wanna play more tomorrow?
Yes.
We have to get out of the circus.
Are you sure we're gonna play more tomorrow?
But not at 6am.
I got things to do tomorrow.
What?
You have things to do?
Like what?
Dungeon some dragons and throw it in Liberty.
Oh my god.
But tomorrow's not the weekend.
Yeah, but it's Wednesday.
That's when I have D&D and throw it in Liberty.
Oh my god.
We gotta fucking kill Tevin, the arch boss.
Who's Tevin?
Who the fuck is Tevin?
Tevin is a world boss that only is once a week that all of the guilds try and get and they drop really important weapons.
Yeah, but like what time is that?
It's super important, you gotta be there.
Yep.
Yeah, but what time is Tevin?
It's at like 7pm.
And then I have D&D at 3 and that usually goes to like 5 or 6.
Oh my god, you have a long day.
Yeah.
That's why I said I'm busy.
You said you're busy as in like D&D.
D&D.
No, Dungeons and Dragons, nerd.
Yeah, D&D.
Yeah, Dungeons and Dragons.
Yeah, I didn't say it's not Dungeons and Dragons.
Yeah, but I said I'm busy because I have D&D.
Okay, what's the current storyline for D&D right now?
Where were you at in the D&D part?
I've eliminated the raccoon.
We're doing Curse of Shrod.
Curse of Shrod.
The Venom has no extra heals.
He's at HP.
Or he's after HP.
Venom has been eliminated.
Venom!
Hey, we did it.
We just saved the Wizard of Lion's establishment.
Nice, we did it, guys.
And then I stole his healing potions.
In D&D?
Yeah.
You stole his healing potion?
Wait, what are you playing as in D&D?
I'm playing Greml, the level 8 Intelligence Barbarian.
Totem Warrior.
Is level 8 smart?
No.
8 INT is really bad.
Oh, I thought 8 was pretty high.
Yeah, wait.
20 is high.
We're playing hardcore and random world stats.
Oh.
Oh my god, I was against the world!
Hardcore means it's a lot more difficult and it's way punishing.
Like, how so?
Like, for example, I lost my arm because a scarecrow feared me and then crit me and then I went incapped and then he rolled injury dice and the injury was me losing my fucking arm.
Holy shit!
That's rough, buddy.
That's fucking rough, buddy.
How are we winning this?
Oh, I'm missing now.
Oh no!
Why did I say that?
I always
come back.
Wait, who's in your...
What other characters in your crew are?
Sorry.
I don't even know if that was great English.
We have Brag, who's a priest.
Greg the priest?
Yeah, Brag the priest.
We have Glory and Garen, who are two halfling brother and sister.
Wait, don't fucking shoot at me.
And then we've had five characters die already.
Wait, five characters die?
Did they just stop playing?
No, no, no.
New people come in.
Oh, so like, they die and then you just grab new people in?
Well, like, they make a new character.
Oh!
I thought like when you say that, I thought you meant like they just got kicked out.
Some people do things like that.
Yeah, I saw a YouTube video about that.
That's like a guy who's been playing one game forever.
My character and Brag are the only OG characters still alive.
How does a level 8 barbarian stay alive?
I don't know.
8 INT.
We're level like 5, I think.
Yeah, but how is he still alive by being so dumb?
Yeah.
Because he is a spirit.
I think it's totem something.
Basically, when I rage, I take half damage from everything.
Oh, I see.
Then I have adamantite half plate, so I don't take any extra damage from crits.
Oh!
I'm scared.
I'm a gigatame, pretty much.
With no arm.
He didn't again me, but everybody else is dead.
Again!
He didn't kill me, but everybody else is dead still.
Oh!
Bum bum bum!
Bum!
Oh!
My fucking support didn't look at me!
Hell is broken.
Hell is hella broken.
Okay, I'm locking in now.
Coming back in.
I think the D&D talk might have distracted us a little.
Oh!
He's low.
Venom low.
What the?
Dr. Strange is half HP.
Oh!
By the eye of Nagamoto.
Just saying my thing.
There's a Cloaking Dagger behind us.
I got cancelled by Hella's E again.
I have Venom behind us.
Oh my god.
Someone has to stay on board.
I didn't think he was going to hit me.
We got help by Mantis.
Our man needs help.
I'm coming back.
Yay!
I'm opening a portal.
Awesome!
Oh my god!
Kick him out!
Holy shit!
He never got past the portal!
We never let him through.
I can't believe we body blocked the portal.
I have ult in 20.
There you go, farming.
And he's frozen?
I don't know.
Honestly, it looked like he was.
I have ult here.
Oh, he's nice defensive though.
Guess I use it here.
We have to kill some people first.
I knew it!
I had a feeling I was going to use it too.
No!
You have Mantis.
Oh no, Mantis is dead.
No!
I'm coming back.
Oh.
I had to pick and choose what to ult.
No!
You're so close!
I had to pick and choose what to ult for.
I didn't know we would live the first aggressive ult.
Well, you can't expect to win them all.
That was a good game.
I'm going to sleep.
I can end on that loss.
That loss is fine.
Really?
You want to end on the loss?
I'm gonna...
You are such a bad influence.
Really?
Yes, yes, yes.
Oh my god.
You can't loss, right?
I can do whatever I want.
Yeah?
And what is that?
Whatever I want.
You still have 30 minutes till bedtime.
I can do whatever I want.
Yeah?
Alright, fine.
I'm cool with that.
Cool.
I can't believe.
I can.
The games went through this bad.
How did it go this bad after you left?
You don't want the answer to that question.
Knowledge in life is better left unanswered.
Wait, did I get you back down?
Are you...
No, you're still diamond?
How?
Yeah, you're fucking mad.
You're still diamond.
How the fuck?
You're mad.
I am mad.
I want you down in the pits here.
You're mad.
Down in the dungeon.
In the fucking circus.
Can you play the right version?
What?
Which one is the right version?
Tell me the right version.
No.
Why is he saying oh yeah, let's throw?
What the fuck happened?
There you go.
I sent it to you.
Oh, it's because we have 3 DPS.
I'm not playing that on stream.
I want to keep that.
I'm down.
I've lost 10 in a row.
Oh, bro.
Welcome to the dungeon.
Get the orb.
I can't believe you won't play this song.
I can't play it.
It's not...
I won't have my VOD.
I've been streaming for 10 plus hours.
Do you want to keep the VOD or not?
I can't believe you won't play this song.
I'll play this song if you'll stay for another hour.
Oh my god.
What the fuck happened to this guy?
Wait, there's a guy right here.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
I'm just going to get stuck on some random shit.
Oh my god.
Things are very rough.
That's fucking life, isn't it?
We got two kills though.
Let's go.
Oh my god, we got three kills.
Is it my birthday?
None of us went to the checkpoint.
Yeah, why are we just sitting there?
That's the guy that won't lose it.
That won it what?
Won't lose it.
Oh.
I'm just...
Let's dance.
Let's just keep dancing, I guess.
Let's just...
Yeah.
Let's just keep dancing.
Oh my god.
I'm bored.
Oh, he jumped off.
He jumped off.
Oh, he's dead.
Oh, I'm dead too.
Unless I start skating.
Such is life.
Alright.
I don't think Brex is okay.
I don't think this guy is okay.
He's on a 10 loss streak.
That's like worse than what I've been going through.
You're fine.
Oh, never mind.
You're not fine.
Oh, you're so fine.
No, I'm chillin'.
You're so chillin'.
Like, Niels won?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Who did he kill to get an...
Oh, yeah, the low key.
We have low key.
Oh, that's...
very unfortunate.
I got stuck on a random fuckin' tree.
What
hit me?
I thought she got...
She got like...
She got stunned, but then she got unstunned.
Yeah, but on my screen, she was still stunned.
That's why I was like, what?
No.
You're not getting me.
Alright.
Worth it.
Oh my god.
Why is it always a show?
This is the longest fight.
There's a Magneto to our left.
What?
There's a Moon Knight to our left.
And a Hela to our left, too.
I was trying to kill the Hela, but she's a rat shit.
Oh, this Hela!
This Hela!
I got 2v1'd by the Magneto and Hela.
Bro, this Hela...
has been fucking it.
Oh my god, the bane of our existence.
Oh my god, I'm scared of this Hela, guys.
I think they're capping that.
Yeah.
Why do they always get the Magneto?
Woah!
That's where I get Moon, too.
Just ask the Penny Parker very nicely to swap.
They're not going to.
You don't know that.
Remember the last time you said that?
And then, like, you know...
This is my first...
I think he's actually fucking mind-broken.
Yeah, that's fucking life, isn't it?
That's why you're losing 10 games in a row, and you're being shut out right now.
I don't know.
Holy shit!
Un-fucking-believable, bro.
I can't kill this guy.
He's getting pocketed.
I had an orb on you.
I don't know what you want.
But he's getting Jeff-pocketed.
Jeff-pocketed?
Bro...
I'm...
I didn't see the Magneto.
There were two Penny Parker webs.
I couldn't tell where things were.
There are so many Penny Parker webs.
Moonable.
Oh, no.
No.
No!
I'm bored.
Me, too.
We're in the Vortex.
And he jumps off.
Of course, this fucker.
It's fine.
We still have the other support.
I just hope the other support is healing him.
I can't help you guys up top.
Bitch actually getting hard-pocketed by Jeff.
What the fuck, man?
That's fine.
We killed him.
Oh, my God!
Venom!
Why is he asking about Venom or Squirrel Girl?
Hey, look.
He asked nicely.
You think he actually plays Squirrel Girl?
Nah.
You think?
You think he actually knows how to play her?
Nah.
Why don't you believe in them?
I don't believe in humans.
I believe in myself.
You don't believe in anybody?
No.
Who hurt you?
God.
What did God do to you?
He didn't make cat girls real.
But if you fuck a cat girl, isn't that... aren't you a furry?
No.
It's not furry if it's only ears and tail.
But they have cat characteristics.
No.
It's a human with cat ears and a tail.
That means you have an attraction to cats.
No.
I have an attraction to aesthetically pleasing things.
So cats are aesthetically pleasing?
Women with cat ears and tails are aesthetically pleasing.
What's the difference between that and a regular cat?
Because I don't want to fuck a cat.
Yeah, but like...
But it still is a cat.
No.
You just wouldn't fucking get it.
What do you mean?
You don't even explain it.
I don't explain it so that I could get it.
I can't explain it because you don't listen.
I'm listening, I'm listening.
You don't listen.
I'm listening right now.
That's your problem, you don't listen.
Oh my god, look, you died because...
you died because you weren't listening.
Spider-Man's going spider mode.
Oh shit.
He really said, it's sticky time.
He's what?
Oh shit, that guy fucking died.
It fucking has to be duo'd with this death, Jeff.
Why?
Dude, he's fucking squirting on that bitch like his life depends on it.
Okay, but like Jeff is the weirdest character to fucking use as a pocket.
Jeff fucking pumps.
Oh my god, oh my god.
What was the plan for that guy though?
He's like flanking or some shit.
I want to cap this.
Okay, the Magneto fucking...
Okay, we're not capping this, I don't think we're capping this.
This Magneto has...
Bro, how?
The Magneto, please, the Magneto solo, please!
Bro, shit!
I get another egg!
Okay.
Are you serious?
We just need to shoot the Magneto!
And then he went hella mode!
Okay.
Coming back.
Oh my god.
I can't keep healing this.
Okay.
Where the fuck did they come from?
I couldn't heal that.
Oh my god, I turned around just as she fucking birded.
I'm putting it on the Spider-Man.
The Spider-Man is having...
He's just fucking running around.
I can barely heal.
The Spider-Man needs to fucking stop.
Okay.
What happened to him?
He just held it.
Get the Magneto, please, he's actually one.
The Magneto's actually one.
No, I was at the edge of that.
You have no supports.
Oh wait, you have Loki.
My god, if we had anything but a fucking Loki, man.
Oh my god.
I'm sitting right beside this guy and he's just DPSing.
Can any of us touch it?
I'm on it putting a show right now.
Dancing.
No.
Let's Wimble.
Please, we...
We just...
We just need...
Please just kill him.
The fucking Magneto.
Magneto never dies.
Magneto doesn't die.
I'm gonna Wimble.
Oh my god.
He literally just let Magneto just live.
For 20 years.
That's fucking life, isn't it?
God, I fucking hate healing this fucker.
He just jumps everywhere.
It's...
Oh my god, I wanna...
Makes me wanna go outside and find a spider and squish him.
I am ready to put on a show.
I got you.
Thank you.
Our fucking Spider-Man's finally squashed.
Oh my god, she...
I hit her once and the fucking Jeff just squirts.
It can't always just be Jeff.
Oh my god, I have to use it.
Or I'll die.
Because the Loki was not healing me at all.
I'm using DPS.
I'm damage boosting.
Just kill everything.
Oh my god, we reached the checkpoint.
Isn't that crazy?
Yeah, Spider-Man's been killing the hell out of this clutch.
He knows what he's doing.
Our Loki is...
MVP right now, by the way.
How does that make you feel?
Makes me feel mad.
How mad though?
No, I swear to god, please get me out.
I'm bored.
Get me, let me die.
Please, stop.
Stop.
I wish I'd know who's talking.
It's like someone.
I still don't understand how that's not fixed yet.
I can't see you guys.
Because there's a...
There's a Venom behind us.
He used his heal thing.
Oh, he got away.
I'm watching you.
I'm watching you trying to kill him.
Did you get him?
I got him.
Alright, we have one fight left.
I don't know if I can grab my ult in time.
Oh my god, I need heals, please.
Where?
What the fuck?
You were in the air, I didn't know where you were.
Yeah, I had to fucking crow so I don't die.
I don't know if I can grab my ult in time though, that's the thing.
Oh my god.
Oh no, not that ult.
I can't!
I'm catching through!
We see nine!
Guys,
I think I deranked to plat 3 from that.
Yippee!
I think I got deranked.
There's no...
Oh my god, I think I actually deranked from that.
Oh no, I'm safe.
Anyway, you wanna go again?
I'm fucking done.
You're done?!
Yeah, it's fucking bedtime, it's 6am.
Oh no, it's your bedtime.
This is curfew.
Your curfew, the sun is out.
Alright, gg's man, gg.
I don't think the sun's out yet.
Is it not?
It's 6 in the morning.
It's like encroaching or some shit.
Alright, gg's though.
Those were fun games.
I hope you suffer.
What?!
Why would you say that?
Because Curse of Ra and Loser's Key was funny.
No, come on, come on.
That's not fair, you get to be top 500.
You look at my chat, you know what they say.
They pray for that shit all the time.
Yeah, but that's not true, that's the environment you created.
You say noob down whenever you can.
That's the environment you created.
You're not supportive at all.
Half the time you type, it's to say noob down.
That's not true, I said that one time.
That's true.
You want me to pull up your logs?
I'll pull up your logs right now.
I literally said that once in your chat.
Pull up the fucking logs.
Yeah, pull it up right now.
I know I said it only once.
Well, you said...
lol silver.
Yeah, I remember that.
Is it team ranking or is it still quick play?
Welcome to silver.
Put the VTuber model on for the full experience.
Then you're shit-talking me for playing voice of the void.
Yeah, where's noob down?
Where is it?
You've said it somewhere.
It's on the deadname account.
That was fucking so long ago!
I told you!
It still fucking counts.
No, it doesn't!
I told you I didn't say it!
I didn't say I'm Doki Bird.
I didn't say it.
Yeah, I won that argument.
It wasn't an argument.
I won the argument.
Curse of Ra, I hope you lose everything.
You're going back to gold.
You're going down to gold.
You're going to fucking gold.
Yeah, if you play early.
Because I have to start stream at 2pm.
Yeah, start stream at 2pm.
You know what they fucking said to me?
My manager said these fucking bum-ass streamers were so late on their start times that they had to say I have to start early and they're forcing people to start their streams early for the sponsor.
I have to start early for these bum-asses, man.
Wait, are you...
Wait, you're streaming a sponsor at 2pm?
Yeah.
Okay, so how early are we Marvel rivaling?
No, Marvel's Rivals is the sponsor.
Wait, you got sponsored to play Marvel Rivals when you were already playing Marvel Rivals?
Well, it was supposed to happen earlier but then the streamers that are always late ruined everything.
Alright, I'll see you at 2pm.
Your time, right?
Yeah.
Okay, yeah.
I'll see you at 2pm.
Your time.
Good luck.
Godspeed.
What do you mean good luck?
We're going to be losing together.
No, aren't you going to keep playing right now?
No, I'm fucking calling it here!
What are you, a pussy?
I am not going to get top 500 today!
Fucking solo queue!
Believe in yourself!
I solo queued and then I got 3...
I kept getting support mains.
You'll play for another hour, right?
And you're going to quit?
Yeah, you quit.
I didn't quit.
Yes, you did.
You literally quit.
Yeah, you quit.
Or I'm queuing up.
I'm alt-f4ing.
You quit!
That's not quitting.
Alt-f4ing is quitting.
Not true, not true.
Yes, it is.
You're literally quitting the game.
Yeah, I'm quitting the game.
Yeah, that means you're quitting.
Yeah, you're quitting.
No, you're quitting.
Not top 500.
Whose fault is that?
It's not my fault.
Yeah, you were going to say, whose fault is that?
You were going to try to bring me into it, when you're the one that lost it, without me.
It's not my fault.
The queues...
The queues fucked me over.
You tried to throw hands for a second there, and you caught yourself.
You caught yourself.
I actually got the worst RNG.
Yeah, I...
SK was the witness.
She experienced one of the queues I was going through.
You don't know pain.
I've stared into the void.
And I survived.
These Marvel Rivals games, they only last, like, what?
10 minutes?
League of Legends, you're stuck there for 25, 30 minutes.
With the pits of all of humanity.
Yeah, but that was a choice.
Yeah.
And I fucking went through it, and I became stronger.
I went from D1 promos, to Emerald 5, 0 LP, 3 losses, all the way to Masters.
How the fuck did you do that to yourself?
Because I have the mental of a god.
I thought you hated god.
Yeah, that's why I need to become god.
You need to become god to destroy what you hate.
Exactly.
Now you're understanding.
I guess I'll see you on Thursday then.
No, wait, I also have to...
Let me see, I need to get this for you.
What?
I'm finding it, don't worry.
This is the furry chart.
The what chart?
The furry chart, bro.
Oh, the furry chart!
Oh!
So this is your baseline.
No, I'm at Neko.
You're at Neko?
Yeah.
What's the animal structure?
It looks the same.
What's the difference between animal structure and Neko?
The borderline furry and Neko, what's the difference?
Because they got cat paws and shit.
You have cat paws?
So they have cat paws, you're like, that's out.
Yeah.
How would you know?
Because I can see their fucking hands.
Because I have fucking eyes.
How would you know?
You're out though.
You've never seen one with cat paws.
What if they wear gloves?
You can see through the gloves.
What if you only see the shoulder up?
And you didn't notice?
What do you mean?
What if you see from the shoulder up?
And then you're attracted to it.
If I'm going to have sex with it, I'm going to see the whole body at some point.
What the fuck do you mean?
Only the shoulder part.
I'm not trying to have sex with some VTuber that only shows their shoulders.
What the fuck are you saying?
I meant if you get attracted to it.
If you like shoulder up and then you like got attracted to it then wouldn't that make you a borderline furry?
What?
Yeah.
You're just making shit up.
Okay, you're saying that you're not attracted to furries.
But what if you only see the shoulder up?
Then you'd be a borderline furry because you can't see the paws.
That's not how that works.
How's that not how that works?
You're just waffling right now, you know that?
You're waffling.
I'm just saying.
You're just trying to make shit out of nothing.
No, I'm saying no.
Your brain is cooked.
It's fried.
You clearly are like if it has cat paws then what if you don't see the cat paws?
What if they were like those big gloves that hide the cat paws?
And you'll never know.
This kind of talk has happened on the internet forever.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Yeah, so?
What's that got to do with this?
You should know.
What I'm talking about.
What's that got to do with this?
You know Astolfo?
No.
What's Astolfo?
It's a correlation to the talk you're trying to represent right now.
What the fuck is Astolfo?
Wait, why is people saying oh no?
Because they know.
Wait, why are you saying stop right now?
They know.
Oh, sure.
Yeah.
Where am I going with this?
Because if you don't know then once you know is when you decide.
So if I see them and only see the face I'm like damn, they're hot.
But then they show their hands and I'm like damn, that's not hot.
I don't like you anymore.
So the hands aren't a deal?
Oh, that's fucked.
The hands aren't a deal breaker?
Yeah.
Man, that's pretty fucked.
I'm not trying to get paws on my shit, bro.
See, don't touch.
Ears and tail, that's the limit.
Ears and tails.
Because they're not real.
What have they become?
You don't know if they're not real?
They could be real.
What do you mean?
Maybe when you're 80 they make catgirls.
Dude, I'll be plugged in the fucking internet by then.
I'll be fucking whatever I want on the internet.
The world's gonna be my fucking oyster.
Elon Musk is gonna have the Neuralink fucking finish and I'm gonna be fucking jacked in.
Holy shit.
At that point you could have anything you want.
I could literally do whatever I want.
Dude, our fucking old person homes are gonna be fucking lit.
It's gonna be a LAN cafe every day.
And then technically you can live forever with your own in-house catgirl.
Okay, now that's the plot to Stalker.
That's the plot to Stalker?
Having your own in-house...
I thought you were gonna say something like uploading your consciousness to something.
Not the catgirl.
I'd be like, there's catgirls in Stalker?
There might be.
Oh yeah, you're not...
Wait, I thought you finished Stalker.
Yeah, I fucking did.
You didn't.
Yeah!
That game was way too long for a VTuber.
Yeah, but Marvel Rivals is different now.
You've worked like quadruple overtime today.
Yeah, I know.
I know, and I have a stream tomorrow.
Guys, I might change it to Marvel Rivals, guys.
I'm sorry.
You're gonna get on another lost streak?
No, I'm gonna win!
I've just gotten lucky!
I'm gonna win!
Let's do that match history.
No, don't do this to me.
Okay, but it's not my fault.
Ooh.
Wait, keep scrolling.
Whoa!
It was okay back then, but then...
Ooh.
Wait, when were all those victories, though?
Whoa!
Oh my god.
Who was in those games?
Well, I did some by myself.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, some of those wins were for me.
And then you tell when it stopped.
You can tell when things got bad.
You can tell exactly when things started getting bad.
Gulp.
All I'm saying is Catgirls are in Area 51.
I can turn it around.
They're hiding shit in there, 100%.
They're keeping it for themselves.
Wait, no.
You also helped me lost, too.
You were part of the losses, too.
You were part of the losses.
Not true.
Yes, you were.
When?
Like, literally last game.
And the game before that.
The last three games, you were part of the...
The last three games, you were part of the lost streak.
Yeah, but I wasn't trying.
I'm nonchalant like that.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, Mr. I swapped to Hawkeye because now I want to win.
My drive to win overpowers my drive to play Wolverine.
It's like a subconscious thing, you know?
My subconscious takes over, but I'm not consciously like you know, like type shit bro.
True.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, sure.
Wait, guys.
Is the VOD 12 hours or 11 hours that it's supposed to end?
If it's 11 hours, then whoops.
What do you mean the whoops?
Oh, 12 hours.
In YouTube VODs, the reason why people don't do long streams on YouTube is that when it goes to 12 hours, the VOD cuts off.
And you gotta make a second stream.
What?
Yeah, that's the YouTube thing.
So, like, when it hits 12 hours, then the whole entire VOD cuts off.
So, like, everything is gone after 12 hours.
Or 11.55.
11 hours and 55 minutes.
Okay, we still, okay.
Alright, so we're safe.
This VOD is safe.
Well, like, wouldn't it, like, if you just stream like 30 minutes over, it doesn't matter.
They only lost like 30 minutes, right?
Yeah, they lost 30 minutes, but that's still losing content.
Content?
Yeah.
You should keep going and keep the content going with the long stream.
No, that's fine, sure.
That's fine.
I want to hit top 500.
No, that's real content.
People want that.
No, I want to hit top 500.
The people want me to win.
No, they don't.
You've created a hostile environment to yourself.
No, I haven't.
That's your own fault.
I created an actual environment that encourages me.
They don't encourage you.
They do.
Look at them right now.
They're like, go to bed.
I want her to win.
You guys are pussies.
I think pussies.
Oh, having a positive environment where my chat is encouraging me and everything.
You're just jealous.
You're just being coddled.
You're being coddled from the harsh realities of this world.
And one of the realities is not everyone gets to win.
Some people have to lose, so others can be winners.
But I'm one of the winners.
Not in your match history.
It's not even mine.
You're part of this.
You're also a loser.
I'm just a chill guy playing a chill game.
No, I'm just a chill guy playing a chill game.
You're a loser too.
No, no, no.
Wait, wait.
Who's trying to get top 500 and who's not?
Oh, oh.
Yeah, you already got experience that.
You already got touch that one.
Like I can get top 500 and I'm just like a chill guy just moving my mouse every now and then.
Oh, sure, sure.
You get top 500.
Yeah, sure.
Sure, sure, sure.
You're gonna totally gonna end top 500 this season.
Yeah.
I totally believe in you.
I was top 50 in the beta.
Yeah, sure you were.
Where's the proof?
I was.
It's in the puddin'.
Where's the proof?
Beta's wiped.
It's in the puddin'.
Beta's got wiped.
You got no proof.
Wipe this.
Oh, yeah.
See, look at that.
These guys, he's just jealous that he doesn't have what we have, chat.
What is what you have?
Well, I have a nice chat that encourages me when I'm noob.
Fuck a nice chat.
Instead of your chat where people be like, fuck a nice chat.
Noob down.
Noob down's funny.
They also type wide among us gay sex.
What?
When do they use that in context?
Whenever they feel like it.
What?
Why not?
Alright, guys.
Guys.
We're gonna try again tomorrow.
Today was... we sort of self-sabotaged ourselves today.
We should've stopped at plat 1.
We'll go again tomorrow.
We're...
IMO for Marvel Rivals.
We'll see if SK's down.
Surefur's fucking busy with D&D.
I'm busy.
And Throne and Liberty.
And if we don't... I hope we make it tomorrow.
I might play some more off-stream.
Not today, not right now off-stream, but like in the morning off-stream.
Bro, you're missing all the poggers and moats, bro.
What do you mean?
It's YouTube.
You're missing people ragers.
What's people rager?
You don't know people rager, bro?
No.
Dude, that's a god-tier emote.
No, I don't.
That's a twitch thing.
I'm a YouTubie.
You're missing out.
Someone says, I blame Surefur.
He obviously...
No, okay.
Finish that sentence.
No, it's okay.
I didn't finish... What was LilPup saying?
What was LilPup saying?
I didn't write that.
You look at my chat and you figure out who said that.
Help me back?
What are you going to say to that guy?
Hold these nuts.
Okay.
Alright, gg Surefur.
Wait, I'm showing people rager.
You're showing people's rager?
What does it look like?
I'm sending it.
They spam that and again...
Guys, no.
Don't be like Surefur.
Don't pray for LoserQ, guys.
We gotta...
Everyone pray for LoserQ.
Do not pray for LoserQ.
Do not pray for...
Pray for LoserQ.
This is what he sent me.
This is apparently the emote that...
They spam that and again.
Oh yeah, I did that too!
I did that in your chat!
I just didn't know the name of it.
It's people rager, bro.
Nope.
Alright.
GG Surefur.
I'll see you on Thursday for more...
more Marvel Rivals.
No, gg.
Don't have nightmares.
Oh, thanks.
I'll try.
I still have to work after this too.
I have to go back to work after this.
Workaholic out here.
No, I was supposed to work today after this stream.
But this stream ended up being about 11 hours long.
So, yeah.
At least you got overtime pay.
No, I don't.
I don't.
So, yep.
GG's though.
GG's.
Bye man.
Bye.
Alright.
Even though we didn't make it to top 500.
Because...
Q's were a little bit too unfortunate.
For us today.
They were...
They were some pretty fucked up Q's.
Not gonna lie.
I don't know what I did wrong.
I don't know.
I felt like I was doing pretty well.
I think like maybe some of my alts were pretty sketch.
But like, how can I fucking save an alt for 200,000 aggressive alts?
Like, I...
I had to pick and choose.
I...
But...
We will...
We will try again tomorrow.
Like...
We will...
Uh...
We will try again tomorrow, guys.
To get that top 500.
I hope we do.
I really hope we do.
But, thank you again to SK and Surefour.
For playing with me today.
It was really fun though.
I had a lot of fun.
Even though we didn't get top 500 today, I did have a lot of fun.
I'm sorry that we're rescheduling Doraemon, guys.
I'm so sorry.
For those who are looking forward to Doraemon.
But I really want top 500.
Guys, I...
Oh, sorry.
Later today, I really really want top...
I'm desperate.
Oh my gosh.
I'm...
Guys, it's my life now.
It's my life.
Alright, guys.
I'm going to not sleep because I have to finish my recordings.
But, as always, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.